These people are so deranged. It's actual derangement. >> Tell
me if this is not true. Have you not doxed people on stream before?
Soy pill is literally like, "Bro, can you not destroy my whole
reason for like why I think I can interact with you?" >> I
don't know why we're playing. The word games here are really
funny tonight. I don't know if this is intentional or not. Like
not so erodite is here. Okay. How are you a woman? You do this
to other women. How have I become the guy who notices this and
points it out?
Okay. Hold on. Let's just we'll check this out real quick and
then I might roll back to see what he's getting pressed on. >> One,
Destiny, I already get so many DJers in my DMs telling and not
because you told them to, by the way. I know that's not it, but
just because of like just disagreements that you and I might
have, but two, like tell me if this is not true. Have you not
doxed people on stream before?
>> Yeah, pe people related to
I don't know who or why. It doesn't matter what your justification
is. My point is that like you've done things that I would say
I
it's so funny. Oh, I'm allowed to dox those people. Don't you
understand? Those are the rules. We're allowed to dox those guys,
dude. Okay. All right. >> I think that's okay. And I'm
sure you could find
all
>> I'm not trying to make these things. >> He actually
he actually just SSRI
sighed at soy pill over being like, "Don't you dox people?" Oh,
whatever. You don't even know what you're talking about. You
What's wrong with this guy? >> I'm saying is like if you're
saying, "Oh, well now I can never ever ever do anything with
this person because it's a tacid endorsement of everything they've
ever done." Whether that is >> not No one even said that.
No one was making
behavior. It's about collaborating with people that are actually
trying to destroy the other people in your space.
>> Like that like that's a very simple thing. It's not
like somebody said a bad thing and now you're
that's way different. Destiny would never try to destroy somebody
in this space ever. He would absolutely
never do that. >> Like they're actively Hassan will
>> It's way different. Don't you know that Hassan is trying
to destroy people? >> Trying to destroy people in this
space. Like you were on argue. Well, not at the same time, but
Dylan Burns was on there. Okay. A guy who we've all watched.
I think we all are personally friends with or at least I I am
friendly with
call this guy a war tourist. Okay. A war tourist. All right.
And was regularly roasting him. And then why do you think Dylan
was on it?
probably because Dylan had some he wanted to talk about the Ukraine
issue because absent
matter that Dylan went on there and promoted good messages despite
the fact that Hassan was on that panel. >> You just totally
touched up what I brought up though. I'm just saying that Hassan
is like will personally try to destroy using personal not like
these are just political >> the whole thing is you're criticizing
me for potentially working with him. >> Wait, Wick called
Wait, Wick called Dylan Burns a war tourist.
That's crazy.
That's like got to be insane panel verse jealousy, right? That
has to be
>> him, which was being on a panel that he was on as well.
Dylan was as well. Dylan has even more personal beef because
of what you just described and yet said, "You know what? I think
I can do more good introducing a liberal pro- Ukraine message,
especially with all the anti-Israelit that panel." It's like,
"Hey, look, I'm actually like talking about other anti-war things
that matter, and I think he did more good doing that than I would
have if you said, "Oh, Hassan Hassan was really mean to me. I'm
not going on this mean to me." >> Yeah, but just just real
quick. I want I want I don't know like maybe maybe I'm separating
myself from Destiny here, but I am not criticizing you or Dylan
for still working with Progressive Victor. You do what you >> So
I think this panel is just them the far left a parasite on democracy.
Dude, by the way, Soy Pill, just watch what happens to Soy Pill
because he's like saying these things because he's just like
saying totally regular normal things. Okay.
I would love I I hate that it has to get litigated, but I'd love
for Soy Pill to just go, "Why do you justify doxing these people
again?
What did What did Supreme do to you?
What did What did any of these people do to you? You know, the
history of Kraut and doxing others. I know that
there was something to do with a police thing with him and bad
empanada. That's it. That's all I know. >> You think is
best for your goal, >> but I mean Wick clearly doesn't
care about people doxing, right? Wick if Wick's having panels
with multiple people who do it. No, by the way, like not even
at at some point you could forgive somebody for doing something
bad, right? But like there's no remorse whatsoever. There's nothing
like this. Arerite is about to join too. Fantastic. Let's go
back. Let's just roll with this right off the bat. Why not do
this right off the bat? We can just cover this for a little bit.
We'll do this panel. You just know that Soy Pill joins up and
he's going to say some things to defend like progressive victory
and associating with leftists. So someone's got to be in there
immediately, right? Immediate. How dare you? How dare you say
that? How dare you say that leftist might not be poisonous scum?
How dare Oh my god. What does Hassan Pika do online? What does
he spend his time talking about? It's either spreading disinformation
or his personal vendettas. That's literally all he does. >> You
That's That's not all he does. I spreading disinformation and
going after his personal vendettas.
I like I'm sorry
you are describing somebody in the space and they are on the
panel with you but you're it's not quite Hassan
even like even for um even for Destiny that would be totally
misleading right like and I don't I obviously don't like Destiny
but even if I if I said the only thing Destiny does is go after
people covers personal vendettas I do think he rolls his personal
vendettas into his politics but Hassan's the guy who's been like
the socialist democ like socialist type for a long time. Desi
is the one who will flip on issues because these people, okay,
but in any case, he still does political advocacy. He still went
to like an event and tried to do something with the National
Ground Game people,
To try to say that, oh, all they do is do the um like misinformation
and and attacking people based on personal vendettas.
That's that's just not true. People always forget that there's
like these these two stream Well, Hassan streams eight hours
a day, right? or seven six seven hours a day
you you see
of it and then you're like I have a good idea of who this is.
No, you're looking at this distorted lens. You have no idea who
the person is. You don't know what the content is like at all.
>> Usually the left also, right? I feel like that's a thing.
I think it'd be weird if I spent all this time attacking conservatives
and then people just spend all their time attacking your son.
I think it'd be really strange. But I don't know. When I look
at that movement, it feels like they're more concerned with attacking
other Democrats than doing anything against Republicans. >> Yep.
No, I don't disagree. But my issue is this is how how much are
they able to hurt the left versus the right is and that's what
I think the proportionality should be dedicated to. Like don't
get me wrong, these people are actively announcing their >> WHICH
ONE WHO IS HASSAN obsessed with. Is he obsessed with Democrats
or is is he obsessed with Asmin Gold? Cuz I was told that he
can't stop talking about Asmin Gold ever. Some people how how
do we run both narratives at the same time? Hassan literally
is so obsessed with Asmin Gold he can't stop thinking about as
gold.
Or is he obsessed with I guess
I I actually don't know, but I see two different communities
running with that same thing. And then they'll post clips of
like which could to a total Julian look very compelling that
make it look like he's only obsessed with one of these groups,
but somehow they're from the same period of time. How does that
>> You know, ideals to subvert the Democratic party, subverting
better candidates, like pushing someone like in my opinion a
platner over a Collins, which I don't think is good. Um is it
Collins? No, doesn't matter. Point is, uh like that sort of
excuse me, thank you. Um >> that should have and should
be talked about. Uh but when it's like all right and then let's
focus on the fact that my day-to-day life is materially worse
every day because of MAGA. Uh that deserves a lot more energy
right now and how we can like fight back against that. That's
all I'm saying.
>> Most people Well, I think most people agree that MAGA
is bad. That's not a disagreement. The disagreement is that the
people in Assan camp are saying that Democrats won't do anything
better for it, which I think is problematic when the right can
cast them as our figures, which they do. They love to do that.
>> That's not true. That's literally not what that like
literally if you listen to the talk between what is it? um Mockler
and Hassan. It's like not true, right? Like Hassan says, "Oh,
Hassan agrees that the outcomes for certain groups are going
to be way better with Democrats rather than Republicans." He's
just saying it's more of the same managed decline. That like
things will continue to go in a bad direction until there's a
paradigm shift. But if we are going to go in a bad direction,
pick the Democrat bad direction and not the MAGA bad direction.
It's not an equating of the two. Um well, they do it in a way
to just damage us and never damage those people, right? There's
a reason why when they bring Hassan up on Fox News, it's kind
of like the laugh and make fun of him and then they make fun
of all of us. But they're never ever trying to cancel these guys
cuz these guys are invaluable to the right. And then, you know,
meanwhile, when it comes to us evaluating our own movements,
there's this huge apparently genuine rift right now with some
people in the party for like should we welcome with open arms
people into our movement that want to destroy the entire political
party,
which is what Hassan and other want to do, but nobody seems to
understand or won't recognize even though basically explicitly
said this across multiple
>> Yeah. And it's not something this is what I want to
try to get get across to you, soil, right? into the audience
listening and I see a lot of you guys um who disagree in chat
and that's fine right but >> Odashara super chat soy pill
which group of creators in the uh in these political projects
would do more advocacy for the democrat in general in the general
progressive victory or digital ground game there is your answer
to where well it's literally national ground game I don't know
why you said digital you think DG I guess okay there is there
is your answer as to where to spend your >> and unless
someone stands up and says hey this is a really bad idea to let
these people in positions of influence in the Democratic party
uh because they're going to push us away from good policy liberalism
in general. And also I I personally think it's going to be >> Oh,
are they doing a thing where they're renaming it so it's like
DG? Oh, that would be funny. >> A gift to MAGA, right?
They're going to just run ads about how
look at the far left and how they're cozying up with Assam [__]
and they'll be able to put together some really just like of
all these clips of him calling all sorts of things, right? Of
him going off on these
>> Can I You have to say the things, man. It's just so
disingenuous.
Calling all sorts of crazy things. Okay. Well, Wick, I'm going
to say that you've called blacks all sorts of crazy things because
you called irrelevant articulate once on a panel. Okay. Like
it
you called people in Oh, it's just of him doing all these like
awful. >> It just always feels like it's set up to be misleading
in the exact right way. >> Awful things. It's saying these
awful things and they'll put pictures of him, right, hanging
out with Roana and all these other kind of politicians, Bernie
Sanders, AOC. I think we just don't like that's going to hurt
us immediately.
fighting on in my opinion, but go ahead. >> That progressive
victory thing is going to be one of the most ridiculous things
that we've seen in years. I can guarantee you that like he usurped
that he was everyone who was in there, including I think >> Oh,
I I would love to hear Kraut defend this. He us So, if you guys
have are just catching up now, if you're just getting in now,
this guy keeps saying that Hassan usurped or took over progressive
victory. Uh I know we watched Hassan comment on this the other
day. I was sent the clip of Hassan commenting on it. I would
love to see what evidence there is of this because this is as
far as I know >> by the way not but apparently this is
I didn't even know this was a progressive victory event until
they released it. They've been constantly uh asking me to be
a part of it for like the last week or so and I was like [__]
it. Why not? Sure. And Progressive Victory has uh
totally took over that organization. He totally took it over.
That sounds like that. Doesn't that sound like he took it over,
guys? Doesn't that sound like a guy who's got some machinations
going on? He's scheming behind the scenes. He totally took it
over, man. HE TOTALLY TOOK IT. COME ON.
I I'm pretty sure like if you want to say somebody took it over,
it's probably like uh Crystal Crystal Ball and Emma Vigland seem
pretty involved. Seem like core parts of that, right?
I feel like Hassan just got asked to show up on a stream and
he was like, I guess so.
>> Gary, do two of you in here that organization, right?
And he he accused you all of being like black money, scionist,
conspiracy, whatever the he user this organization. The first
thing they do with its account is beef with people for his personal
vendetta. He subverted a policy or just so he could use it for
his personal vendettas. Oh. Oh, dude. Destiny is about to explain
that this guy sounds totally deranged. He subverted a policy
OR JUST TO JUST FOR his personal vendettas. No. And I I said,
"Dude,
can anybody
>> can anybody think of a reason Progressive Victory might
not like Destiny?" Like when he basically agreed and backed up
Hassan that it was his own personal slush fund and all of these
people were so ungrateful because he got them all paid by Progressive
Victory. Could it be that they don't like that? Could it be that
he consistently has talked about them for the past six months?
Could it be that? Could it be any of these? No. No. It has to
be that Hassan took it over and made them start talking about
Destiny for his personal vendettas.
This dude is actually a total
Why did people even know who this guy is?
This guy is brain dead. First thing they did with it that I saw
was they made an excuse for why Hassan openly docked people that
were part of that organization, which is something that he was
going to write up and not a video that had the public filings
of the addresses of a bunch of people that were part of Progressive
Victory. Assan went over it and then the PV account came out
and they did like an apology tweet for Hassan saying that it
was actually their fault or something. It was ridiculous. >> well,
let me
I don't want to defend the what Hassan did because I think that's
an unexcusable to show all those boxes. But the what PB did specifically
was say and this was their fault in the first place. This is
the reason it was out. They paid out of the wrong org. It was
supposed to be I think it was the LLC instead of the pack and
they paid out of the pack and because it was pack you have to
then disclose all of the addresses and names of all the people
you paid out to. And that was someone in their or that up. Now
Hassan capitalized off that and then made it worse by broadcasting
it. So it's like oh you can't say oh it's public therefore it's
not a big deal that now I have a
So Zoy Bill corrects the record and well we don't like that.
>> Old man Lingre did that. Not Hassan. Wellre did it too.
Hassan No, Hassan did it. If you're amplifying a docs, if you're
amplifying something somebody was under the impression that they
had hidden that you are digging up and finding or even just having
it broadcast to you and you're amplifying it, you are doing something
that's not quite as bad as finding it yourself, but you're doing
something like that. So I don't want to minimize what Hassan
did. It was doxing and for I think some of the people specifically
it was quite bad. Not for Hutch. Hutch got zero information published
on him that was not openly available on the internet. Okay. That
he had published intentionally himself
like knowing to public like intentionally publicly attaching
to his persona as a streamer. Okay. So for Hutch that was totally
fake but for other people it was real and and there were some
there's information on them that shouldn't have ever been shown
on a stream by Hassan. Pick might have made a mistake, but Hassan
was aggressively and maliciously using that information to other
political
obvious like if Hassan's mistake was 100, PV's mistake was like
like five or 10. Like it wasn't that >> sure. That's the
thing is he was able to amplify that into a much worse thing
because despite the fact that it's public, it's like yeah, I
can find someone's public information, but if I then broadcast
that even though it's public, no, people aren't already looking
for that. Like he's the one who made that much. I don't think
he should make that excuse and they're using the clout of Assan
on that panel that I was on to be like, "Oh, well, now we can
use this big, you know, platform to promote our policies, which
to them seems like a better trade-off than dealing with the fact
that >> malice would imply intent. Um, it's hard to say
for Hassan what the intent is like necessarily.
I think the unfortunate thing is not for me the intent isn't
that he wanted to dox people. The intent to me would be you're
like being willfully reckless. I know if if I know this then
Hassan definitely knows this. I'm not going to watch a bad empanada
video on my stream without pre-checking it. I might someday watch
a bad empanada video on my stream, okay? But I'm never gonna
do that without knowing the content of that video and knowing
that I'm not going to publish somebody's information when I do
it, right? And I if I know that Hassan definitely knows that.
And so to me, it's like you're being so reckless. Maybe he you
could argue. I don't really care to argue like to try to mind
read >> This person abused their mistake and turned it
into a bad thing for all their creators. So yeah, >> even
after Hassan had abused
the people the Progressive Victory were working with, right?
its creators that they had worked with and uh had made contracts
with and had promoted and had you know um the creators had promoted
progressive victory as well to to excuse the abuse that Hassan
did is a betrayal. It was a betrayal, right? It was a betrayal
and it is a betrayal and that is something to watch again.
He abused them. I yeah I guess like
it is kind of rough
the percentage of those people
I don't know how to say this without sounding like an
um
h it was I would say it seems kind of weird for progressive victory
to come out and say like oh this isn't a problem because we were
the ones who originally leaked it right yeah this
it's just like okay Wick
that don't you think it's a betrayal to people you've streamed
with people who have been on your stream to platform somebody
who openly like gleefully doxes them like you are doing something
very similar yourself right now it's it's a little weird now
I think that
that that doesn't necessarily answer the idea that for progressive
victory I do think it's weird for them to come out and say like
oh this isn't a big deal. But I think that was fundamentally
just somebody dumb running the account. I think some people are
under the impression that doxing is just the first time. Like
if you look up somebody if if somebody finds a doc, they collect
it and they publish it, that's the bad person, and it's all like
located on them. It's all on them. But that's not really what
it is, right? There's a lot of other downstream effects. And
Hassan amplified that docs and he did it in a way that was reckless
to people that he doesn't
So, it's very difficult for me to go, "Oh, well, he had no negative
intention there at all." Now, for a lot of that info, I do think
it was like not a big deal. But, there are some people who were
quite affected and I don't think Hassan had any concern to reach
out to them, make sure they were okay, make sure that and that
that's where like the the politics is at online, which is just,
right, like a thing to do. But Wick seems to be more angry at
Progressive Victory than he is at Hassan, which is kind of interesting.
an organization that saw a man >> abuse its members, call
it dark money shills for Israel, spread all sorts of malicious
hate and lies about it, which we had to deal with every day
just to kind of crawl back on their knees and beg for a crumb
of clout for him.
Wick Wick was angry about the progressive victory hate he was
getting way before any way before Hassan was aware of it. Way
before anybody he's he's putting all of that on Hassan, which
is hilarious. He was already indignant about the progressive
victory stuff when all of us were saying, "Hey Wick, you should
disclose this. Hey Wick, it's inappropriate to do political content
for money. Like you're getting paid by a political or for your
political content and you don't disclose that. That's up." And
he was indignant about that criticism for
months, right? >> Is I don't I don't know the word. It's
kind of disappoint. >> Yeah. Suck my suck my off. That's
the only thing you have to say to someone like that. He can off.
He can take his little pack of idiots and ride off into the sunset.
I have no doubt about the fact he's going to destroy that organization,
that progressive victory group. That's done. He's going to burn
it in the into the ground to serve his personal indebted. And
the the only lesson that people like me and others here may have
to learn from it is next time around when people like that come
around, you always say no. I It's so interesting to me. I are
the only people that will go
this guy's like an actual [__]
Like this guy has no idea what he's talking about at all. nothing.
>> You tell them to off right away. Don't engage them.
Don't have any illusions about working like people like that
with people like that.
>> I'll say this, the reason I still work with them and
uh I'm not sure how long that will be depending on where they
go, especially considering I'm seeing where Tanky and Hassan
type stuff coming from them is that they do promote candidates
that I like and I have yet to encounter and this might be a naive
from me uh better organizations that take what they're doing
and move and mobilize people with audiences like me in ways that
I'm okay with. Like for example, when they did work do work in
the past and I do like the work they did in the past and I do
know people that have been in charge of that stuff and have left
the organization since. Uh, for example, Destiny's campusing
events that helped flip Georgia. Uh, those are the things that
I have been like screaming for. And, uh, the as soon as a better
alternative exists, I think I could absolutely snap up on the
opportunity. >> You want to know the best thing about that?
All of that was basically that if you like that stuff, I'm just
telling you, there's like an Asian dude that you should go hire,
okay? Who made sure all of that stuff happened, who made sure
all of it, who actually did work, who is actually somebody who
can do work. All right? You should go find that Asian guy who
was super neurotic and got everything done cuz that was like
the whole
that was all of it. All of those every DGG event every
It's Sagon. It is Son. Okay. All the DG events all the that other
people helped. But I'm telling you the core of the nucleus of
that stuff was Son. That Son was the person who was like actually
getting stuff done there. He was the person who was actually
doing work. Destiny wasn't doing work. I do know that. So other
people went and other people did help significantly at those
events. For sure they did. So I don't want to make it seem like
nobody else helped at all. Lots of people helped at those events,
right? But in terms of getting it all organized, the the actual
like professional person there who who acted and and worked and
got done with Sedon the whole time. So if you like that
if you like that Soy Pill, you should go figure out where Sedon
is. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I don't This would just be like
a mean 4v1 against you Soy Pill, but >> like it was against
me. >> Okay. No, my criticism is a little bit different.
Um, even though liberals and socialists, they're not really ideologically
aligned. Liberals and socialists are more ideologically aligned
than liberals and MAGA are. So, I do think that even though MAGA
is the greater threat and most more liberal time should be spent
critiquing MAGA, um, the more that you interact with socialists
on a friendly manner, I think it's more dangerous. It's more
toxic. It's it's more corrosive to to the Democrat party long
term. I know leftists who really had enough of him. Like I am
friends with leftists who they're mostly involved with him. And
one thing that I know from talking to them, the thing that they
all universally tell me when I talk to them is there is fear
in leftist circles of talking speaking up against the sun. But
he's completely
huge like
>> I can't do it. >> We should forget that either.
>> I will say you're going to have to be careful. You're
giving Hassan way too a lot of credit there. It's not necessarily
Hassan that's done it. It's Hassan has kind of been the recipient
or the beneficiary of this huge like online weird lefty ecosystem
that's been set up that he's now just
Whoa, whoa, whoa. It's almost like you're trying to Oh, hold
on, Kraut. You're giving falsifiable points. And so, let me step
in and give a totally unfalsifiable theory that is just me skits
posting. Okay, let me make it totally unfalsifiable so that when
people come in and try to argue with us, we go, well, look, Hassan
Hassan said some bad things. That's unironically what we're about
to watch. I I bet five subs on it, okay, to myself. to enjoy
the benefit of being part of that. >> It's also possible
that he's just the smartest grifter. I'll give you that as >> Kind
of pioneered the field of like politics of video games on Twitch.
So like that was all right. >> But I'm saying like all
the weird like obsessive like snarky dramatic like doxing like
the people that are swatting me over and over again didn't necessarily
come from just community. It's like this weird peripheral online
tanky movement that has like so much influence in so many different
online places. Oh, there there are tankies swatting Destiny.
Dude, everybody everybody swatting these people apparently. All
swatting, all doxing is all the same group of people. That is
everybody who dislikes Destiny. Do you know what a far more explicable
thing
A way better explanation. Way better. Okay.
Destiny's an inherently unlikable person that a lot of people
can just dislike without coordinating in any way. That that's
actually just way it explains everything way better. Turns out
he's just a far less he's just a totally unlikable totally irredeemable
person who a lot of people hate. irrespective of anything else
and without coordinating in any way. >> He does seem to
be kind of like their figurehead though, like their chosen avatar,
if you will. At least from my
>> Yeah, it's like ahead weapon for sure. >> Oh,
yeah. >> People always cringe when I say that, but it's
like a a parody of Stalin's personality cult the dear leader.
Like, how many times have you encountered people say, "But he's
such a great symbol of >> Dude, it's so funny because
listen, I'm sure I'm sure everybody here loves the hatred that
Kraut's bringing. He's just
he's got a Dude, you gotta you gotta go, man. You're saying the
dumbest thing. He's such a great representative of the left.
The dear leader this basically. And I'm here Stalin. >> Yeah,
he's Himbo Stalin.
>> I think we're mostly in alignment of the things that
need to be fought against, especially with someone like this
subverting a leftist movement. I guess maybe Destiny you can
speak on this because I think you even maybe said this before.
Do you think, and I'm going to on Dan a little bit, but just
because he's like a prime example of this, some people do have
like Hassan derangement syndrome. We were talking about things
that you just don't need to and spending a disproportionate amount
of time on things that are not, hey, this is an important uh
push back against this movement of the left wing, but like oh
boy, look at this silly little thing he did that we >> Whoa,
who is Dan? Desi doesn't even know who Dan is. What the >> call
out for a week, right? >> Yeah, a little bit. But whatever
Dan went too far on Hassan does that on a regular basis and you
guys all give him a passport. I'm not entirely sure about that.
But you do though cuz you're willing to work with him. >> When
am I willing to work with him? In what capacity?
>> Was that a serious question? >> Yeah. Like do
you mean like being on the panel with him? >> Hassan said
I will start an or to Sorry. >> Yeah, just one day ago.
I mean, what do you all the progressive community were there
when he was on that panel and Mike was and all those people that
I didn't like. I'm on them in chat. I'm like I don't like these
people but I'm willing to like if there's like an operation Barbar
Roa type thing where Hassan says I'll pour $2 million into a
camping event for Senate Democrats in general races. Absolutely.
I'd work with him. But like the question is about the oneway
street, right? >> I don't think he will pull $2 million
for obviously
pill. Soy pill you're just one disavow away. Okay. You just disavow
Hassan one more time. These people will not
You're right there. Just one last disabel and it'll all be fine
>> to work with you. Like Assan is never jumping on a liberal
project ever. >> Yeah. If I thought that working with Assan
could get >> Oh, this is interesting. It is true. This
is actually true though. Yes. All this discourse about the candidates
needing to avoid Hassan is the same arguments that were used
to argue that Dems shouldn't platform Joe Rogan. It's wrong to
go on Joe Rogan is Camala Harris, guys. It's wrong. Yes. Now,
I wouldn't say that's the majority of people, but those these
are the arguments they used. Yes.
Michael >> has done better than
Is it bad for politicians or political actors to go on to a platform
where people hate them and to just like shill their ideas and
try to be likable? And I thought that was like sort of the key
thing that you're supposed to do. You're supposed to go anywhere,
talk to anybody and go, "This is why I think we see this is where
we see eye to eye and I like you guys and here's like some stuff
we could work together on and maybe come watch my stuff or come
look at my
right." You're trying to pull people from that audience into
your audience. This was like a thing that we all agreed was was
good.
Wasn't this why?
Wasn't this why he talked to Lauren Southern and Nick Fuentes?
Was Wasn't this the point back in the day? Wasn't that it? I
thought that was it. >> Not did I not do it? And I guess
they that's that's my question. >> It's It's strange how
when all these conservatives wanted to talk to Destiny, that
was the way it was. And then when they all decided they hated
Destiny and they don't want to talk to him anymore, now it's
actually bad for everybody else to do it. Isn't it funny how
that works? As the opportunities come and go, the justifications
change over time.
Well, when all these people do want to talk to Destiny, when
they all do want to hang out, it's totally fine to go and talk
to them and debate them and and whatever, even just go for ice
cream with them. But then, as soon as those opportunities start
receding, they start going away. Well, actually, guys, it's just
wrong for you all to do that. You're all terrible people. Actually,
that's not >> here. I mean, like, so the counter question
would be, let's say that tomorrow, okay, Fentes is really upset
about everything that Trump has done. They, you know, he's joking
about talking about building Democrat. Let's Fent starts up like
a pro moderate dem coalition or whatever to fund raise, whatever.
Would you be part of that panel thing, or thing, speaker thing?
Um, would VM be speaking out against him? But if he's giving
us money, uh, it would hard to turn that down.
>> Yeah. Like if Elon Mus wanted to donate to the Democratic
party right now, I would probably accept the money and work
coming from actually. Yeah, it's
made like a speaker panel and he called it progressive destroy
Trump victory or whatever. Would you join it and participate
in the same manner? >> I guess not. But also to be clear
Hassan didn't make this panel. Hassan was invited on that panel.
>> Also that panel was uh it was taking the the side that
Soy Pill supports on an issue, right? And broadly I think that
org is trying to help certain Democrats get elected that Soy
Pill supports, right? If if Fuentes was supporting in a truly
in a non like here's the problem is Fuentes in a genuine way
is never going to support a candidate that Soyill likes, right?
That's the issue. Hassan will Hassan is actively supporting candidates
that Soyill likes. So it's a totally disingenuous comparison
because Soyill wants to get certain people elected. He likes
them as candidates. Is that not what what's going on here? He
wants certain candidates elected. Hassan is working towards getting
those candidates elected and they can basically butt heads over
the on the things they disagree with and and take the, you know,
the good and the bad. They can agree on things. They could and
then Soy Pill will basically go, "Hey, Hassan, you you went after
some of my friends. I don't like that."
Right? As long as he's doing both, I just don't understand what
the problem is. What is the issue?
You bring up Nick Fuentes, but it's not the same. If if Fentes
somehow had a genuine change of heart and was genuinely going
out for candidate soy pill liked and causing positive motion
in their direction, he was trying to help them, right?
Then yeah, you would work with him, but it's just it's not real.
>> Okay. Well, if the Okay, Grapers made the panel and
then Fentes went in the same way that Tankies made this panel
and then went. >> See, that's my issue is like if you could
tell me that PV was primarily made of tankies. First, when I
joined PV before, they had a lot of like regime change stuff.
Um, it was people that explicitly when asking me about my politics
said, "As long as you aren't anti-electoral, we'll work with
you." And I'm like, "What do you mean by that?" And they're like,
"Hassan, right?" So, that was the previous like admin of this
group. And now it seems >> that was not so >> sh
a little more of Vashi. Uh, which I'm not as happy with. But,
if they're like partnering with Han on a panel to be anti-war
versus Hassan is a primary and member figurehead of this group
and we are endorsing all of his politics, I think those are two
different things. So, if it was Hassan's audience primarily making
this panel, I would agree with you in the same way that that
would be analogous to Griers doing it. But when it's people that
would like invite him on, I think that's a little
>> Oh, he he literally
I think the framing is just totally disingenuous. But it's hard
to especially when it's 4v1 think of how the framing is disingenuous
when you go to argue >> so like do you believe that your
interaction with with this group is better overall for the liberal
project than it is for the socialist project? >> Yes. I
think I think >> oh the answer should be
I think that the social the socialist project is not very powerful
at all and so while I have a hard time I have a hard time even
gauging how much it helps them it helps liberals like pretty
massively
and so I'm willing to risk helping them more because I don't
think basically we're like we're at 99 and they're at one and
so I'm not worried about getting to like 955
that's not scary to me. I've got so much runway here that I don't
care. And then they'll go, "But Hassan's like Hitler. He's like
the Nazi party. He's like Hitler in 1932."
No, he's not. But no, >> the candidates that are being
endorsed and given money to overall are people I'm happier with.
Uh like I like Oliver Larkin. I like Roana, but Oliver Lin does
go on Hassan stream, right? And then they have people like Mike
from PA and Hassan on this panel. I'm like not happy with this.
They have some candidates on there that were saying some pretty
wild [__] that I'm like, not really happy about this.
And that's why actually when people are posting that link, it's
like the hey, go donate. That stuff is distributed equally to
those candidates. And I said, "Guys, if you if you like a camera
on here, don't donate to that. Go find that Canada and donate
to them. Don't do it equally." >> I don't know. I uh I'm
not. >> So Soy Pill won. No response from anybody. So pill
is literally sitting here. Hey, I actually I actually don't even
like those candidates. Let's go and let's go and donate to some
other guys. >> sure that I can support a candidate willing
to work with Hassan. Um frankly, so any of these people who are
going on his stream and having >> What would you for Bernie
Sanders? Um,
DUDE, WHAT IF GAVIN NEWSOME GOES ON HIS STREAM AND THEN WHAT
IF he's the WHAT IF HE'S THE CANDIDATE? DUDE, WHAT IF GAVIN Newsome
talks to Hassan?
What are you going to do? AOC, you hate AOC. You hate Roan. You
hate Bernie Sanders. You hate all these people. What the
That's wild. That's insane.
He's He's now
>> I would vote for Gavin Newsome over JD Vance. Unless
Gavin Newsome went on Hassan [__] stream, in which
case, listen, I might just have to give it to JD Vance. Guys,
this level, by the way, this level of hysteria is why I can't
take these people seriously. It's why all of the Hassan history
is like totally disingenuous.
like pretending that he's close to Nick Fuentes, pretending that
he's close to Stalin, pretending that there's like some some
communist movement that's very close to a revolution in your
country and needs to be like totally abolished, totally done
away with. It's all insane.
You are insane for suggesting this. >> I had multiple appearances
with >> I did actually now would you? >> Uh, probably
not. No. >> Okay. It would depend who's running against
I want to be very clear. any of these
outright endorsing Hassan now. Did you hear the thing I said?
I feel like you're trolling Jorge the First. Outright endorsing
Hassan now. Hassan is not Nick Fentes. Hassan is not Hassan is
not Stalin. Oh, you're just outright endorsing Hassan now. E.
Uh-huh. Opposing JD Vance. I'm voting for them, right? Like JD
Sure. But in the primary, let's say it's Bernie versus like >> Wait,
hold on. Now, would you >> uh probably not
depend who's running against like I want to be very clear. any
of these opposing JD Vance, I'm voting for them, right? Like
because JD >> Okay. Okay. No, it's not quite >> sure.
But in the primary, let's say it's Bernie versus like the most
like center left possible, probably farther away from your politics
than than Bernie would be, right? Like Bernie has worked with
Asan. He's buddy up with Asan. Yeah. That's not enough for me
to say I'm never going to vote for this person who aligns with
me all these other >> again. It really it really depends
on on the you have to it's like fact-based question you're asking
me, right? Because I have now that I'm talking about
and all his views. I'm not going to vote for them. But just real
quick, as a rule of thumb, I am saying that if you are willing
to work with Hassan [__] then you are probably not
on my team, right? You are probably uh more than likely going
to be against a lot of the things that I stand for because you're
willing to put up with a level of anti-semitism. You're willing
to put up uh with a level of harassment. You're willing to put
up with a level of just communist brain rot that I think would
if we accept it in it's it's like a it's like ingesting poison.
It will eventually kill us. It might make you feel good at first,
but it's eventually going to kill you. I just this is to me unfortunately
and I don't want to make all these things things seem equal because
they are not. I think that's politics are like really bad but
like this is to me like every time
it's not just politics are really bad. His personal behavior
and everything is deplorable. It is the worst.
>> No no shot.
No
Dude, how how how
in the world do you get
the G to come on this panel and say those words
as
pot kettle? But it's not pot kettle. It's not. It's like the
pot calling the stainless steel frying pan black. It's not. You
are covered in grime. You are gross. That that is a brand new
stainless steel frying pan compared to you. Okay. It's not the
same. >> I'm going to get into that. But that's less bad
for me than the politics which are like I think are going to
>> I feel like more harassment easier than almost any other.
>> There's no way. There's just no way. There's actually
no way. Destiny repeatedly came. Okay, I got to collect myself.
I got to collect myself for two seconds. That's insane. That
was an insane thing to say. That was a totally insane thing to
say. I had to be chill. >> I'm saying if I had crowd then
go ahead. >> I don't know what that say. I'm not saying
they're good. Right. If I were to say, you know, this guy went
to murder your dog to cut his throat and say, "Well, I wouldn't
say that behavior because you see that behavior is plural." I
think it's probably been responsible for more harassment for
anybody like at the center of probably maybe any other single
individual. >> Destiny, the thing I was about to bring
up was like whenever I appear on screen with you, I get so much
for all of the accusations against you. The >> Destiny
actively harasses people he's like openly victimized.
actively harasses, actively goes. He is a totally deplorable
piece of [__] I have no idea
how in the world he could say things like this. It's so crazy.
>> Doc stuff like any and all the other
thing is I'm willing to say real quick. Who do you think that
comes from though? >> It might be Assad's community. >> Yes,
it is. That's the point. You're making my point. Yes, correct.
>> How much I don't know how much of this is legitimate
criticism or not, but my issue is I value your politics and your
movement far more than I do potential accusations and how true
any of these things are. And so when I hear the stuff of like,
>> dude, dude, soy pill is literally like, bro, can you
not destroy my whole reason for like why I think I can interact
with you? Can you not like obliterate the whole reason if you
if you take this position, I can no longer interact with you.
Can you not burn my bridge with you accidentally? Can Hey, Destiny,
I'm trying to say I would put the politics. I'm trying to separate
the art from the artist. Destiny, why are you saying you can't
separate the art from the artist? Destiny, isn't that what you
said? Isn't that what you said when you came back from the pixie
allegations in the first place? Isn't that what you said? Guys,
just separate the art from the artist and keep watching me.
Dude, dude, Hassan is a horrible person. It's like, yeah, in
a lot of ways, I agree with this. Like, this is just obviously
true. But how much am I willing to use this person in the same
way he's trying to use us to promote my goals? And it's like,
if you could show me that this is more harmful to my movement,
that's when I change my mind. >> Hold on, Hassan. Is that
>> it's not worth saying that like the personal behavior
is bad and so far as like there might be some misgivings about
how they conduct, whatever. Hassan will directly attack people
like in these communities. Like, would you still be willing to
work on if you found out that the meme messages you get when
you come on my stream are me messaging my fan base and like another
Discord? Like, hey, you guys need to go.
>> He literally did this to Pisco. He literally did this
to Pisco. He routinely and repeatedly did this to Pisco. He routinely
and repeatedly did this to Taylor Loren. He was every single
time he replies to Taylor Lens on Twitter, he's posting that
in his chat
at like 3:00 a.m. He's fighting with Taylor Loren on Twitter
and he's posting every one of his tweets back in chat so people
can go harass her. This is so beyond mirror posting. This is
like looking at who you are as a human and and assuming nobody
else can exist except in the way you function. >> Harass
the out of the story this guy. >> I honestly would I honestly
like that honestly in this case in this case you have to acknowledge
when you're having conversations that you are way outside of
the norm and that your opinion is not
most people will not most people will not tolerate that type
of behavior. It's an insane thing for the average content creator,
politician or whatever to deal with as another huge content creator
that's actively and I don't mean like by way of having a dis.
>> Lefty purity panels are back. Ker, you just missed Destiny
saying that Hassan is uniquely bad because he harasses people.
Destiny got on a panel and said Hassan is different than all
of us because he harasses people. He like doxes people and stuff.
Destiny got on this panel and said these words
>> and one it's difficult to find the words to even respond
or whatever else but it's directing their community to directly
go and harass another person. That's like a that's a really out
there >> No, it is first of all
wait
I already get so many DJs in my DMs telling the myself and not
because you told them to by way I know this not it but just because
of like just disagreements that you and I might have but two
like tell me if this is not true. Have you not doxed people on
stream before? Uh
well wait wait wait just wait guys if you if you missed this
we covered this right when we started but if you missed it okay
what do you think his response is oh well I only dox like like
nonhumans
>> yeah people related to I don't know who or why it doesn't
matter what your justification is my point is that like you've
done things that I would say I don't think that's >> people
related to
like like people who went on your stream for years people who
like went on your stream for years and you were close personal
friends with for years,
like people like that. Maybe
>> that's okay. And I'm sure you can find out your
I'm not trying to make these >> HE HE'S OFFENDED. HE'S
OFFENDED THAT SOY PILL EVEN BROUGHT UP HIM DOXING PEOPLE. HE'S
ACTUALLY OFFENDED, DUDE. He's like actually exasperated sighing
at Soy Pill for bringing up that he doxes people. >> What
I'm saying is like if you're saying, "Oh, well now I can never
ever ever do anything with this person because it's a passive
endorsement of everything they've ever done." Whether that is
>> No one even said that. No one was making behavior. It's
about collaborating with people that are actually trying to destroy
the other people in your space.
>> dude. I I actually I I
>> like that's a very simple thing. It's not like somebody
said a bad thing and now you're doing something. It's like they're
actively Hassan will actively try to destroy people in the space.
Like you were on argue well not at the same time, but Dylan Burns
was on there. Okay. A guy who we've all watched. I think we all
are personally friends with at least I I am.
>> Destiny has absolutely never done that. Destiny was
absolutely not saying that Pisco should be kicked off of Lib
and Learn and that the liberals should own Lib and Learn again.
The show Pisco made. Destiny was absolutely not saying that Pisco
had was totally mind raped by socialist women in his life like
Joanna and Straight Raid. He Destiny would never do that. Destiny
would never try to totally slander Pisco repeatedly. Right.
Right. Right. He would never do that.
Is that Kouty? That is Crow. Yes. I call this guy a war tourist.
Okay. A war tourist. All right. And was regularly roasting him.
>> And then why do you think Dylan was on
>> Probably because >> uh by the way, if you didn't
know this, apparently Wick also called Dylan a war tourist.
So this is Was he really claiming that about Joanna? Yeah, he
was. Yes, he was. He did that openly. He fed that narrative to
his chat. He repeatedly, routinely leaned into it over and over
and over again.
Absolutely he did. So Wick also did that. some a little bit here.
>> You wanted to talk about the Ukraine issue because I've
absent
that on there and messages despite the fact that Hassan was on
that panel. >> You just totally what I brought up though.
I'm just saying that Hassan is like will personally try to destroy
using personal not like these are just >> dude. This is
a level of mirror posting we've never seen before. He's he's
taken it to another level. I've never seen anything like this
in my entire life.
He'll he'll just do personal attacks. He'll just he won't even
go after the politics. He'll just go on a personal
saying is you're criticizing me for potentially working with
him, which was being on a panel that he was on as well. Dylan
was as well. Dylan has even more personal beef because of what
you just described. And yet said, you know what? I think I can
do more good introducing a liberal pro Ukraine message, especially
with all the anti-Israel [__] in that panel. It's
like, hey, look, I'm actually like talking about other anti-war
things that matter. And I think he did more good doing that.
I would have said was really mean to me. I'm not going on this.
I want to make it clear. >> Yeah. But just just real quick,
you know what I mean? Like maybe maybe I'm separating myself
from Destiny here, but I am not criticizing you or Dylan for
still working with Progressive Victor. you do what you think
is best for your goals and things like that. I have to be clear.
If you can make me a compelling argument why this is ultimately
more detrimental, I will stop. >> Just let me finish, right?
That that's not why I'm here today. I'm not here to like be convert
you from progressive victory. That's not that's not the point
of what I'm talking about. I I just want people to understand
what is happening because as Kraut said, Hassan has subverted
that organization, right? Or Hassan fans, right? It's like Crow.
It's like exactly like this guy said when he said the exact thing
I wanted to hear. It's exactly like that, guys. It's like the
same. Okay. It's like exactly like that. Um
Han subverted progressive victory totally. Meanwhile, Han is
like, "They tricked me. They tricked me into joining their event."
>> Right. Maybe not him directly, but >> subverted
basing that off of like I Destiny, you know Jonah, right? >> Yeah.
like has he he is I'm very trustworthy of him and know that he
knows the internals of this and to my knowledge there's not some
like tanky subversion prohassan movement in this thing despite
some things you might see that do come out of progressive victory
and are you have you been >> grim right
>> this kraut guy is actually this grout guy is making
the look so >> has been cheering the Russian invasion from
the start
>> waiting are you saying that Jonah has come out and publicly
said that >> I don't know if he's public said that I'm I'm
asking if you've talked to him about it. >> Okay, I won't
quote any individual person, but that entire organization has
been completely and totally subverted. Yes, every center left
liberal has been exised from that or it is excl Dylan
Is Dylan Burns not a center-left liberal? If Dylan Burns is not
a center-le liberal, who is? Is this not explicitly wrong?
What What does Dylan Burns consider himself? Maybe progressive.
In which case, I would wonder who the center left liberals were
from before. Counterpoints. I don't Who are the center left liberals?
If Dylan doesn't count, if Dylan doesn't fall in that same category,
who are the center left liberals that could have existed there
that aren't there anymore? >> Exclusively socialist and
tank now. Yes, I know that 100% true. I >> I've heard I
shouldn't even say that obvious by looking. No, you haven't.
>> It's 100% tankies now.
It's 100% tankies now. I know that to be true. >> Has been
completely and totally subverted. Yes, every center left liberal
has been exised from that or it is exclusively socialist and
tankies now. Yes, I know that 100% true. I I've >> I mean
I shouldn't even >> I know that 100% to be true.
>> It sounds like Soy Pill is saying that's obviously not
true to him that he knows somebody who is not like a tanky and
that he trusts that guy. No obvious looking. No, you haven't.
I I literally am talking to Jonah right now like in
>> You don't know that soy pill. I'm literally talking
to the guy I brought up right now. I'm literally directly talking
to that guy.
This is actually
Are we participating in kink is the question really at this point.
Does Destiny just enjoy being humiliated completely? Does he
just enjoy being completely humiliated? Does he want to run this
thing into the ground? I don't know. Is he like like is he
>> So like whether or not that's true, >> I got to
I got to pause a little bit. He does that all the time. He asserts
things as if they are facts without knowing. I know he does.
I know he does. >> I'm not I'm not saying you're wrong
or lying or something. I was like I have heard differently. >> Yeah,
Ryan Grim is on there. The that guy the night the >> this
guy is so this guy is so far >> tanks rolled into Ukraine.
His nasty lectures and how all of this was the Americans fault.
Ukrainians won't last and should surrender.
See it into my memory. That guy.
That guy.
Uh not so erodite hitting the paddle up. Not so erodite is here.
Okay, cuz 4v1 that was going pretty badly for some people. So
why not 5v1? Let's go.
This soy pill guy needs to be put in his
Put this in his place now, Arerodite. Okay, Arodite is about
to cam up and be like, "Look, I just got way more out of the
gym than you. I'm way sweatier than you right now." Hey, soy
pill, you think you just got out of the gym? Take a look at this.
I actually don't know that. I'll be right back. two seconds.
>> I I guess so. Paul, the way that I would look at it
is if you think you can do good by by interfacing with these
guys, go ahead. But like if you turn around and suddenly your
community is like 80% tanky, you should probably double think
it, you know? >> Uh I don't think most if any of my community
is tanky, but we'll see. Wait, Kylo, back me up here. I'm not
accusing you of that. >> No, no, I you don't have to cuz
I just know it's not true. But even if you did, um hey, >> hi.
What do I What do I
tanky right now?
I would say so >> if you have Ryan. >> Yeah. Did
you see my beautiful
you're saying in your chat I was just in a meeting with Jonah
3 hours ago. It is primarily taking or yes. Like so I don't know
what he's saying in your time but yes 100%.
I'm going to read I'm going to read you Jonah's words verbat.
>> You are conflating tankies and socialist. Socialist
yes. Tanky no. It's pro-electoral socialist.
>> It's democratic socialist. There are definitely pro-electoral
socialists and >> oh so Oh. So, they're just totally intentionally
misunderstanding.
Intentionally misunderstanding again. Total the same total intentional
misunder. Wait, hold on. I wasn't here when she cammed up. I
wasn't here when she cammed up. Uhoh.
Oh, I'm totally correct. I'm to I'm Dude, I I said it before
she cammed up. I did not have spoilers. I just knew that was
going to be the case.
How do I know every Dude, I could just
I see everything. Okay.
It's so funny.
>> It's democratic socialism. >> There are definitely
pro-electoral socialists and there are definitely probably accelerationists
that would love to co-op the socialist space. >> Can you
can you tell me what exactly the point of democratic socialism
is? If the only thing you get to vote for is who is on your firing
squad. >> Two purposes. Number
>> Oh, get this guy out of here. Get this >> You
can be a communist without uh having to outline your power level.
Number two, it's for coward communists who don't really actually
hold up just real quick. Jonah, we can bring Jonah on and ask
>> I'm telling him you should come on and clarify this,
but yeah, he wants to. >> Oh, boy.
>> Oh, hey, there we go, buddy. That was my >> Hey,
now that you uh now that you're here in the in the hot seat.
Okay. >> I don't I don't want to I don't want to be here
for very long, but yeah, basically I I I describe Tanky as uh
like pro-Russia, pro-China when it comes to China, Taiwan. That
is not the position of the leadership as I understand it. >> That's
what
you're not
talking about leadership. We weren't talking about leadership.
One tie. Go ahead. Destiny. >> Wait. They absolutely Wait.
Destiny absolutely was talking about leadership and stuff. It
was org, right? The org. There's nobody left in that org. I thought
I thought he actually So, he actually made a differentiation.
I thought he was explicitly talking about the org. >> No,
we weren't talking about the leadership. We're talking about
the people they're working with.
>> Am I crazy? I could have sworn that he was talking about
the or explicitly because it was like I was like, "Oh, he kind
of just undercut the point I made." Maybe not. >> No, no,
no. We weren't talking about the people we're working with. We
were talking about the organization has been subverted by Hassan
and his movement. That's what was said. >> Yeah. Or Hassan
fans, right? When when Wick said Hassan fans, did he mean the
creators? Did he mean like Crystal Ball is a Hassan fan and she
subverted it? I think they're just trying to gaslight soy pill
in that he's totally vindicated and they're trying to gaslight
him into believing that he was wrong. Actually, we meant all
the people. Even if you say all the people, I still don't believe
you actually get tankies. You might have Mike. You might I don't
even think you have Assan, but you might have Mike and then I
don't even know beyond that. Who Who is that beyond Mike? >> They're
clearly working with tankies. They're working with >> Vos's
audience more than it's Assan's audience in PV. >> It's
It's entirely Bosch's audience. >> Yeah, I figured. But
Vos is a Bosch is a
We're as close as you can be without
>> Bosch. Oh, I
listen. Bosch has thrown his hat in with Hassan. So now we hate
Vos again. Remember when these guys were like we love Vosch?
Vos is like literally cutting heads off of people who won't vote
Biden figuratively.
Remember when they love Vos and now oh Vos has thrown his his
hat in the the ring with us on. Oh, we hate Vosch
>> Is he watch
I I don't think he is. Does he want to get rid of private property
rights? >> Well, yes, he does. >> That's not what
a tanky is. >> I would say it's definitely moving. Well,
I didn't say that's a tank. >> That's not what a
Dude, it's so funny. You You don't So, when when Soy pill goes,
that's not what a tanky is. I can tell you I'll lay out exactly
what's happening there, right? He's basically going, "Don't bring
up this super
talking point that you did with like straight raid and hutch.
Do not try it with me cuz I will I will expose you right now."
Like he's literally giving her a warning. I like you. I don't
want to have to expose you, but if you try to run down this dialogue
tree, I will. If you try to do this, I will embarrass you. That's
what Soy Pill is trying to Please help me not embarrass you.
I don't want to embarrass you right now, but if you're going
to say, I will have to. What a nice guy. Whoa, that's not what
it is. >> But
watch
I don't think he is. >> Does he want to give away private
property rights? >> Well, yes, he does. That's not what
a tanky is. >> I would say it's definitely moving. Well,
I didn't say that's a tanky, but it's definitely >> one.
You have said multiple times. That's multiple times. That's a
tanky. You have said that multiple times. And then what the do
you even mean it's moving in the direction of? Dude, that's like
saying a wealth tax is moving in the direction of being a communist.
You you support a wealth tax. Well, that's moving in the direction
of being a communist. Which by the way, probably true to some
degree, but also just a thing to say because you're trying to
invoke use a label to invoke some emotional thing that is not
accurate and doesn't actually help like further the discussion.
It's not accurate. It's not informative. It's not helpful. It
is a
>> Moving you in the tanky direction. >> Oh, absolutely.
Yeah, but that's >> How are we defining? Have we done this?
>> How are we defining tanky then? A wealth tax is moving
in the tanky direction, you stupid.
Jesus Christ, man.
like USSR apologist like Communist China is great like yeah ML's
like Lenin is good Stalin is good example there's direct examples
here there's Ryan Grim who ever since the first Russian tanks
rolled in has been on Russia's side >> ban this guy this
guy now this guy now give me an example
you have him on >> do you want me to speak or I I don't
work for >> Hold on but she's literally said outright multiple
times that that is what a tanky is the gotcha is well do you
want to get of private property rights. Well, actually, how will
you ever do that democratically? People won't give them up. People
won't give them up willingly. What do you do then? Doesn't have
to be violence.
That's She's literally run that exact
dialogue tree multiple times.
So, so yeah, I got I I got from that. Um but uh like for example
they're supporting cat Abu Abu Gazawa or how you pronounce it
in the uh Illinois 9th question mark congressional race. She
had some like position paper come out that was like >> in
the event of
figure it out in the event of uh in the event of a Chinese invasion
of Taiwan that the US should actively support Taiwan with weapons
and whatever. Right. >> By the way, I'm not even joking.
It's dude I've been saying it for a while and Madag Glacius is
sit on this too.
I I think people are just underestimate I I would tell all of
these people just be like anti-Israelite. Just be anti-Israel
and liberals and we're like down with you. I would wait like
the Israel thing rises in a lot of people's estimation in terms
of something they have to vote against because of this war because
of how it's affecting the global economy. if you are but because
you will expose very quickly how many of these people are single
issue voters on Israel and are just trying to bully you out of
it. Okay, I'm not joking. They are literally single issue voters
or single issue I guess lobbyists on behalf of Israel, right?
And they are straight and they're just trying to bully you out
of having the same position. They will not support any candidate,
right? And it's like this idea that the pro Palestine anti-Israel
position is only a communist position is complete.
It's actually the liberal position. You should say, "Oh, as a
liberal, I don't really support giving weapons to this country
so they can constantly oppress and and destroy the way of life
of everybody around them." That's the liberal position.
All right.
And that's what this that's what a ton of this is about. And
then you get a whole Well, you just think it's all about the
I don't want it to be about the just literally no support for
Israel. Make it so nobody wants literally just give give the
left no support for Israel. You'll get the entire left and you
lose nothing. And it's THE MORAL POSITION. YOU win in EVERY POSSIBLE
WAY. YOU'VE SET YOURSELF UP PERFECTLY.
It's it's so perfect. How do they not see it? That a lot of tankies
online. They were like like including Ryan Grim who your your
who I agree is is much closer to Teny uh than the average socialist
or whatever but they supported GA and they were like these tankies
this does not change our opinion of her at all. We agree with
her position on Taiwan. That is what I would see as if they were
a tanky organization and from the leadership they would not have
that position. I'm not specific people but the lead but the leadership
I know like I'm not specific people but I know the leadership
is pro-electoral and anti-tanky very explicitly. >> But
what I socialist she lost her primary and then Hassan Per ripped
into her because Oh, that's because you supported Taiwan.
>> Also I what
did Hassan [__] on Cap for supporting Taiwan?
I I somehow don't believe that to be the case because he would
sort of I don't even I don't see how you could possibly like
think that because wouldn't that just be Well, hold on. What
is RIP into? Cuz I could have sworn that
he still said to vote for Well, he didn't like the position.
But this crowd is saying that after the election happened, Hassan
went live and was like, "Oh, cat, she didn't like Taiwan or she
she didn't want strategic ambigu or yeah, she was opting out
of strategic ambiguity." Well, no. He's saying after Hassan did
this and I'm like, well, he spurred her before, wouldn't he look
kind of hypocritical to to go and like be like, "Oh, actually,
you totally yourself over." >> I feel like there
go ahead big names. I feel like it's the Israel thing that they
care more about and she was quick to ID some APEC funded uh dark
money group that was against her as well. So, I'm pretty sure
Israel is the the big motivating thing for a lot of these >> totally
weird,
right? Like he's an anarchist,
>> dude. It's it's actually crazy.
They're they're trying to make it so that being against supporting
like a genocide, being against supporting apartheid, being against
supporting war crimes is the anti-liberal position.
When people are trying to convince you of this, just look at
them, you know, look, they're obviously lying. They're obviously
like motivated by something else. With these people, I don't
know if it's that they're paid. I do believe it is far more the
idea that if they flip, Hassan gets to go, I was right. Vosch
gets to go I was gets to go I was right. Like all the people
they hate get to go I was right. That's probably what keeps them
from doing it right is the ego way more than getting paid or
anything like that. Spitebased it is spitebased politics because
again Madaglacius said this perfectly. This is like the best
issue that you could reach out to the left on and it's the thing
they all want. So why aren't you doing it? It's the math is so
easy.
Just give them that you get all of the left like enthusiastically
on your side. Hey, we're going to cut off aid to Israel. We actually
don't think it's appropriate to aid Israel. That's the position.
We are not going to aid Israel until they show in terms of elections,
in terms of their actual decision-m that they are going to start
fixing things that they are going to change the way they act.
>> So simple, man. >> Libertarian or whatever. >> I
don't quite know what to do with the comms mostly because they've
just like abandoned reality in a way. >> Instead of like
anarchists do actually
>> instead of fixating on the weird labels like here's
the thing is will they support Democrats in the general? I do
you do you like how this shifted entirely away from how Soy Pill
was correct. Soy pill gets to extract zero concessions. He was
totally correct in everything he was saying. This guy came on
supported everything Soy Pill was saying. They are all wrong.
1v6 or whatever. Soy pill is correct but sorry 1v5 actually 1v
yeah 1v5. Soy pill is correct but none of them none of them will
ever let him get that out. another pontificating on how all anarchists
are >> that's that's like the main motivation >> I
mean literally
right why that's how many years ago was that I don't know why
that's relevant
>> tequila sunset basically soy pill came on and explained
why he doesn't think like an organization that works with his
evil and then he was kind of winning that argument cuz kraut
and short fat taco
and so Destiny joined because he had to show everybody that actually
soy pill is totally wrong and then he humiliate iated himself
and then Eerite joined and I mean I guess if you want to say
the the tanky equals wants to abolish private property argument
if that's humiliating then she also humiliated herself and now
we're in some weird state where everybody's trying to basically
obiscate that soy bill won soy totally won >> well that's
how many years ago was that I don't know why that's relevant
>> maybe you won't do it anymore well the reason I could
bring you
hold one time
literally said I think he wouldn't vote for Gavin Newsome in
general because of his position on Israel Palestine. >> Oh,
okay. Well, that's stupid.
>> I This is the Trump stuff. Wait, do you not say the
minimizing the minimizing language? Wait, they're like, "Oh,
this is what you want to use. I'll >> No, no, no. You're
saying it's not words, but it's like it's indicative of your
state of mind cuz you keep doing this over and over and over
again where anytime it's a bad thing, you're like, "Oh, I guess
indicative of your state of mind. Yeah, he finds you performative
and
obviously
you've come in and said actually you can't separate the art from
the artist with facade and he's actually evil because he harasses
people. You Destiny have come in and said these things. Yes,
you are cringe and he's trying his best not to have to deal with
DJers again flooding his DMs telling him to kill himself. So
he's trying to stay away from just saying you are obviously a
performative who doesn't mean anything you say because he doesn't
want the >> It's kind of bad. Oh yeah, that's not great.
Oh yeah. Okay, I guess. Like is that a thing that >> because
I'm more aligned with people on this side, but it's like if you're
going to be anti-electoral to say I'm not going to vote for Gavin
Newsome in general, it's like yeah, you're not really part of
my movement then. Sure. >> The the the point is wait and
see wait and see if if Pave is going to do exactly that. And
if they do criticize them, call them Tanky, call them call them,
you know, no better than the DSA or whatever. The idea the idea
is that you can take your headwake, but the idea is that there
is no proof that when there is a competitive race, which there
will be this year, and you will see them support the Democrat
in the election in a competitive Senate race, competitive House
races, you will see that happen this year. >> If you don't,
then I'll I'll join you in
If I may,
shut up.
>> Shut up. Shut up. Okay, let me finish my thought and
then we got some >> Don't Don't comment on how Erdite's
trying to act like a child. Don't comment on how she's adopting
the Emmy strategy and is going to act like a
is I don't so much care what the leadership says they are. They
are consistently
promoting overwhelmingly a group of people who are anti-democrat.
Right. Wow.
What's the difference between then and now? Uh Wick was getting
a thousand bucks. Okay. That's the difference between then and
now. Wick ain't getting a th000 buck anymore. So, of course,
he's got to make this point now, right? Wow. >> Who are
you?
>> I just went to their account. They're literally retweeting
Kat Fumadora. What reason do you have as a serious political
organization to repost Kumadora out of all people? >> It's
I'm guessing that has something to do with the idea that he had
a clip that was compelling for the point they wanted to make.
>> California is so compromised.
>> What the is this? only one US Congress member does not
take Apac money that what that's like a blue state that's like
entirely going after dem Dem what >> and and so they can
say all they want oh I support like in the general we'll support
them but if you spend the whole time just trashing Democrats
all day and then the day before the election or the week before
the election you're like okay guy just uh vote for the Democrats
it's cool right quick >> entirely to my point of
>> the the thing that gofumodor here's a gatumodor retweet
Israel is now seized a larger percentage of Lebanon's total land
mass than Russia was taken from has taken from Ukraine since
its 2022 invasion. The latter was immediately met with the international
uproar and unprecedented multis sectoral sanctions while the
former is barely even mentioned. Wow,
that I can't believe you you'd retweet what excuse is there to
retweet gapumor in
well apparently they agree with this.
Apparently they agree with this seems to be the case. why I'm
willing to work with such an organization if they do what they
did, which this is literally the like that inspires me to like
move stuff and criticize people like for not doing like this
in the general in runoff elections in Georgia and Senate races.
Okay, let's go put money and people out there and make sure we
win this. If they're not doing that this year, I'm out. That's
why I'm trying to do stuff like this. And so like the idea that
like an alternative to this, >> I would absolutely jump
on that instead because they are half of these people they promote
are people like you said Kraut and other people are bringing
them up, people I don't like, but half of them I do like. I do
like Rakana. I do like Lark and I like a lot of these people.
We don't have to guess. We don't have to guess if they're going
to if they're going to still advocate for the person they didn't
like because they No, no. They did this already. They advocated
for someone else in the governor race in uh was it New Jersey?
They they really did not like uh was Mikey Cheryl. And then they
still made tons of calls for her after she won the primary. So,
and that's not even in a competitive race. That's in a race that
like we probably were going to win. So, they're doing that. They're
going to do it in other races. >> Okay. I think there's
one thing. So, there's a
>> So, I I understand what you're saying guy who's involved,
but I really hate Hassan. I really hate progress. Like, sorry,
maybe not progressives. I mean, progressives. Yeah, I I hate
these like left-leaning people. And so, I'm going to make some
point right now that's not going to make any sense. It's going
to be totally basedless speculation or totally like me leaning
into to tropes that have been basically fabricated from the ground
up. Okay? To point out that these people hate democracy. These
people would be the same as Trump. >> Couple things to
keep in mind. Number one, the incentives, right? We need to be
aware that anytime there's a progressive more socialist camp
within the Democrat party, the main competitors that they will
have in any type of election is in a blue state where they can
run against Democrats. A progressive is almost never going to
be running against a Republican. It's exceedingly rare. I think
the only time we've seen states go from Republican to >> I'm
curious what what was Terico doing? What is Terico doing right
now? Right. Isn't Terico didn't he just win a primary to make
a challenge in the general or sorry in the midterms?
Isn't he a progressive that's going to run against some candidate
in the midterms? Platiner is the better example. Oh yeah, sure.
Maine. Maine's a purple state. Yeah. No, I know he'd beat Jasmine
Crockett. I'm saying that he is now a progressive candidate going
up against a Republican. I assume in Texas that's going to actually
be a thing. No, >> like socialist is Alberta with the NDP
and that was probably a fluke, right? So the incentive >> wait
of election is in a blue state where they can run against Democrats.
A progressive is almost never going to be running against Republican.
It's exceedingly rare. I think the only time we've seen states
go from Republican to like socialist is Alberta with the NDP
and that was probably
>> why would you say states and then say
is your problem? Also, the Alberta thing was because the rep
the conservatives split the vote or the centrist party split
the vote
like that. That's a it's obviously not a progressive place. Okay,
>> probably a fluke, right? So, the incentive structure
that we have to remember for progressives is their main competition
is Democrats. It's us, right? And so >> also that can only
happen in what do you call it? That sort of fluke can only happen
in a parliamentary democracy where you have multiple parties.
That never happens in the states, right? Like both both sides
will have their candidate for the general election. That does
that literally structurally can't happen in the states in the
same way. >> well I mean I guess in Utah it technically
can. In Utah they can run big Mormon third party candidates.
>> Not opposed to people working with I don't really care
that much. I think one of the things that we need to be aware
of when we're working with socialists is we have to be very clear
that we're not in the same camp. If they want to take away private
property rights and we don't, we can work with them on certain
aligned goals like getting a Democrat instead of a Republican.
But we have to be aware at all times that when we're working
with them, we are conferring them power and there are certain
powers that they would want to utilize that we are diametrically
and vehemently opposed to and most moderates that would vote
for us are vehemently opposed to. Uh so I think that this is
something really really important to keep in mind. >> So
easy.
You know, you know what? Say it solves everything. Just slip
on Israel. That's it. So easy. So easy. >> My I guess to
speak to progressive victory, I think the biggest issue that's
happened here is that it in the federal election was dominantly
floated and supported by liberal content creators and social
spaces dominantly being Destiny's community, but a couple of
other communities as well that were also liberal. And it so quickly
flipped hard on them and kind of denounced them and pushed away
liberals in a way that I think is extremely distasteful. And
it is exactly what we should expect from spaces that get captured
by socialists, which is why you can work with them, but you need
to >> the So this is totally ahistorical. It's totally
and they're calling out some sort of capture. Progressive Victory
was always a leftist organization.
It ran stuff before Destiny joined. It tried to bring different
groups together. It was running. It was paying Vosch or was collaborating
with Vosch. I believe in the 2022 midterms. No. Maybe even 2020.
Was it Was that what Vosch ran with for the 2020 election? It's
possible it was. I'm not 100% sure, but I know Progressive Victory
was doing stuff with Vosch, Riverboat Jack, a bunch of far lefties
on Twitch way before they did anything with Destiny. Then they
were like, "Well, we have to make sure these groups don't fight.
We're going to try to build an organization that gets these different
groups on the left, left of center, to work together to get Democratic
candidates elected right
now.
What is the big change that's happened? Destiny and Aerodite
are anti-working with other people on the left, explicitly the
group that progressive victory always was.
So why is it shocking to them that when they start advocating
for cutting these people out of the Democratic party entirely,
why are they shocked when progressive victory comes back and
says, "Yeah, you
how is that shocking? What part of that is shocking? It's the
only possible thing that could have happened.
That is the only thing that would have ever happened here given
any understanding of progressive victory, the progression they've
gone through and who they are as like who their owner is, who
they are as an organization.
It is obviously what was going to >> To be aware that you
are basically in bed with the devil and you need to be very cautious
about it because if you're fundamentally opposed to certain rights
being removed like property rights, they are opposed to you necessarily.
>> Any other questions for you before I >> Not for
me. >> All right, cool. Bye. >> Anything else? Love
you. 2022 midterms. Let's take a look. Progressive Vic,
these were their their team members for progressive victory.
Mafia Jinx, Caseyron, Adept, the best, the Surfs TV, Aspect Decor,
John. Every single one of these people are adjacent to Hassan,
right? Literally, every single one of these would be people that
you would say are adjacent to Hassan, except maybe AB Starill.
Maybe not AB Stariller anymore. Okay, maybe not. Maybe not. But
everybody else of the people I can see, this is 2022.
This is who the organization always was. It's just totally adept.
Yeah. I'm guessing this was like the people who were friends
around
like Hassan, like that lefty group on Twitch, right?
Yeah, obviously.
I just It's crazy to me that people just try to totally ignore
this. Wait, John Ayola was there. What the hell? What the >> how
many Israeli shekels did you get paid for this showing? Ah, he's
gone. I knew he would run away into the tunnel. >> Of course
he did. >> Into the tunnel with he >> Yeah, it's
it I think Erdike kind of uh hit it on the nose. Um the socialists
aren't competing against MAGA. They're competing against Democrats
for the same space. They want control of the apparatus, the institutions
that Democrats have built and set up. And they they can't get
it from
this was never ever if you guys believe this, why did you ever
work with progressive victory? If it's so transparently obvious
that none of you believed this because you worked with progressive
victory in the first place and the entire premise was we're going
to bring all these groups together. It literally was like a dinner
where Vosch Destiny and Keles were sitting at the same table.
This is a totally new belief that didn't exist before. None of
you sincerely believe this and you haven't given me a reason
for Hassan changing at all. The the only thing I see here, Hassan
is the same. Hassan is the same as he ever was. Okay? He's advocating
for the same things. He's the same guy.
The only differences I see are one, Hassan sub some sometimes
retweets substance, somebody who doesn't like
And to me, if you think that's crazy after the amount of Destiny's
and Destiny and his friends have thrown at Hassan, I don't know.
I don't know what to tell you. Okay.
And two, it's become very clear that Hassan had the morally correct
position on Israel from the beginning. And you would have to
apologize and or like out and say, "Yeah, actually, no, that
is the morally correct position.
rather than than say I don't like a genocide. I don't like
I rather than say I want to hold Israel responsible in terms
of I think they owe something back to these communities that
they've destroyed. Rather than saying that, you would rather
say, "Oh, well, I just I these people wanted to destroy us from
the very beginning. These people always wanted to destroy us.
They wanted to destroy our space." This is an argument formulated
entirely to deal with anti-Israel sentiment to deal entirely
with anti-corporation sentiment within your party. You are abandoning
the values you claim to stand for the everyman, the working people,
right? To stand to like shoulder-to-shoulder with billionaires,
I guess, right? The people who fund Third Way, and say proudly,
uh,
Democss, they're actually bad now. We We hate Democss now, guys.
It's crazy. It's wild. Republicans, but they can from Democrats
and they will >> I think that might be true in some blue
states, but I'm not I'm not convinced that this is true overall.
I've um I had conversations a while ago with uh with someone
who works in like um a policy think tank. Um
he probably hates to bring this up um or him up. Um, so he told
me that there's a chance actually for the first time in decimates
>> to turn a substantial amount of Utah
>> because the Mormon community at this point just completely
disgusted with >> Just the complete moral debolter and
everything. And there's a that more and more Mormons in Utah
vote blue. And there's a chance that you could potentially even
flip the state or something, but you're not going to flip that
state with someone like a Hassen [__] So it's it's
varies from region to region. You have to go from district to
district, from state to state, look at the what local voters
want, etc., etc. If you run a Hassan Per candidate in Texas,
in Utah, you're just inviting yourself to lose. I mean, >> I
guess we'll see to Rico, right? It seems to be totally insane
to me the idea that like Terico is the losing candidate in Texas,
but okay. All right. Yeah, maybe there's a socialist who stands
a chance in a place like Maine, Massachusetts, etc., but just
they they want everything or nothing. >> They don't strategize
everything or >> Here's here's my question because obviously
Kyle, I agree with the idea that like these people's opponents
are Democrats. They're running in mostly safe blue districts
because they're never going to win in the competitive one. Is
there a liberal alternative group that excises people like this
that is doing the same stuff that I am attracted to, which is
mobilizing online audiences and communities? No, because it always
gets co-opted by people like you who always say we should work
with Hanky's a socialist. >> People like me, dude.
>> It gets co-opted by people like you up here doing a
>> co-opted by people like you who always say we should
work with Hanky's a >> People like me
in 2020. That's what inspired me to join it, dude. Come on,
>> dude. I >> there's two things. Number one, liberals
is dominantly especially so like yes, Destiny, you're this like
liberal alternative like dark space that's always been like woke
and whatnot, but the dominant liberal actual like space has been
filled with a lot of academic types who have been too afraid
to stand up to socialists because they're very cowardly. Liberals
just like want to stay in their institutions and be safe and
they got the best polic.
>> You give any examples of this or are you just going
to say this thing that
I do we have examples? Can we get >> And I love liberals.
They're very cowardly, right? And so what they did is they shook
hands with the socialists because the socialists were cool. And
then they said to everyone, "We're just like them." And they
were lying the whole time. And that's a really big problem. So
they did get it co-opted, but in part it got co-opted because
liberals are terrified of supporting each other and we're terrified
of off socialists to lose that >> terrified of supporting
each other. Where why do you think this literally all you have
to say? I I want Aeronite's commitment now that she will support
any liberal. Okay, Aronite, tell me this explicitly. Somebody
asked her this question. Will you support a liberal candidate
who advocates
like vehemently for defunding Israel entirely? No American tax
dollars to Israel. Will you support a liberal candidate who says
that? That's the big question. >> Just just to kind
smidge differently. Um because before 2016, it wasn't like this
as much. There was some, but what happened when Trump won the
first time is that liberals legitimately got scared. They thought
they had it in the bag, right? They thought Clinton was going
to win, right? They thought, "Okay, we have a formula." Obama
had already won twice. We know what to do. We know how to handle
these things. We have a great pitch. The people love it. We are
going to win. And when they didn't, it shocked them. And they
made a deal with the devil in a lot of of ways because there
was these socialists, these kind of tanky types in the wings
who'd always been kind of trying to get power in the space. And
they said, "You know what? You guys failed, but we we could win
for you." and we let them into positions of influence and we
started listening to them. But then other than that, I agree
with what you said. A lot of liberals became scared to kind of
stand up to them and now we have a problem. Right. Why?
What do you mean? It seems like a bunch of people have been perfectly
happy to stand up to Hassan or other socialists for years now.
Where where was this in 2024?
This lack of a spine. Where is this? Why are you just making
this up?
Give me the evidence. Give me the evidence. All of you people
told me that Camala doesn't support all of this transit. All
of you told me Biden had moved past all of the woke.
Where where is that argument now? When I when people brought
this up in 2023, 2024 before the election, you guys all went,
"No, they're not woke at all. These people have no power anymore.
No, you don't understand. These people were you just lying for
Were you just lying?
What?
Wasn't this the argument? Oh, well these people don't have power
anymore. They've actually lost all of their power and we don't
support any of that woke anymore. We're not like that. We're
a different party. No, no, no. When has Kamala ever talked about
trans issues on the on the campaign trail? What has she ever
done that? What has she ever done that guys? I got that was brought
up multiple times to me. Now all of these people have totally
abandoned that
>> Huge problem. >> A hu a huge problem. And the
answer isn't clear. Like I the answer isn't never working with
them. Obviously
>> it sounds like it is. >> I think it is.
No, it is the answer. no other world where anybody would be okay
with a group of people who are explicitly saying, "We want to
come in. We want to co-opt and destroy your movement. We want
to do everything we can to funnel more people to our extreme
side and we're not going to support you in the general." >> And
that's
that's okay. I guess that that sounds like what Hassan said.
The whole thing where he's like, I I do think you should take
the moral position on Israel and I will support candidates and
like ultimately I do think that the outcomes for people are far
better with Democrats. That sounds like Yeah, actually we're
going to come in and explicitly destroy you and never work with
you and and like literally just lie to you to your face. >> Okay,
that sounds that's about the same candidates in the general for
competitive districts. I'm not talking I'm talking about Bosch
if he says the same thing about News. I'm talking about PV that
is putting this money behind mobilizing people to get Democrats
>> Liberals should abandon PV if I'm being frank. Like
that would be my position. >> Please give me an alternative
organization that's doing what they're doing. I will join if
you had a better one. That's what I'm saying. What what is what
is your prescription for someone like me who is like I don't
want to I don't like these people. I don't >> they don't
give prescriptions soy pill. Why would they give prescriptions?
What? That's that's falsifiable.
They just want to rent
without doing any work. Why would they give you a >> Want
to work with them. However, >> be doing or what is what
is the thing we're looking to emulate or whatever? >> Uh
a collectivized group of >> banking, canvasing, door knocking.
>> Did they do that much? Wait, did they do that much once
they became like
>> I don't know what the milestone of when that happened
was, but if they're not going to do it, but Jonah says there
already plans to do said thing. They just did this in a governor's
race. That's what he brought up. Like, it sounds like they're
still doing it. >> They've been doing phone banking since
before liberals joined and after liberals have been pushed away,
just to be clear. And when I say
don't like, well, you have to work with them. I mean, you do
have to work with some socialists. You just do. I'm not talking
about tankies. I think the fact that people work with Hassan
and the fact that Democrat candidates are literally slobbering
at the mouth to go on Hassan's stream is a huge part of the problem
is >> well there's a lot of Democrats
worked with Vos in 2020 in a project I agree with right
>> yeah but that was one that was before um first of all
that was when Vos was willing to like kind of be more electorally
minded number one number two if you remember back in those days
remember when I did the panel with Vos and Emma Emma literally
said this is all a waste of time we have no influence anyway
and now she's super gung-ho and excited cuz she's got a bunch
of other tankies on panels with her and now they're excited to
drive like uh influence in that direction. So I mean like we
can go look at all the people invited like these are all like
pretty hardcore like single issue Gaza genocide like both sides
of the same type voters like all of them.
Do you see how it just sneaks in? It just sneaks in out of nowhere.
All of these people think that Gaza is a
Why would that matter to you?
Why why is that in being included in this conversation? Why do
you have to keep smuggling that in? By the way, I pointed out
because I believe that's where the position comes from, right?
I think that's what they're actually hiding is they don't want
to go against Israel. They they want to keep taking the same
side they've always taken. But I could be made to look very stupid
if they wouldn't stop bringing it up every single time in the
exact way I expect.
It'd be so easy to make me look dumb on that. But they can't.
They just can't leave it alone. I said most of them. We can look
at all the people on the panel. Most of them are probably like
that. We can go back and and recount up all the people, but like
like 90% of that PV thing was like about Israel. Like that's
almost the only thing >> very Israel brain and I agree
with you there. But it's like okay if I'm going to look at like
the majority report and disagree with like a lot of not a lot
maybe like 30 to 40% of like Emma's takes and still say hey these
people are still electoral. These people are still promoting
good policy. These people are still trying to get the general
like promoting Kamla. They're going to promote Gavin even if
it happens. Like I don't agree with Matt. Matt's like super tanky
but like Matt's the guy in the back who doesn't even have a camera.
Like do I not do I just write these people off completely? And
if you if you feel if you feel like >> I'm not going to
tell you what to do. >> If you feel like you agree with
about like 50% of what Emma says, then you're probably on that
team. That's like the side that you're on. But then I just don't know
why you either don't recognize it or you're also on that one
or you want to see most people in media right now. And if you're
like agree with true, but I want I want
I want I want to hear from I want to hear from Kraut cuz uh he's
a guy invited on
>> No, please. I need to address this cuz like Okay, Destiny,
I I know you've moved further away. And I think Sam has moved
a lot further left in ways that I don't like. But like Sam Cedar
of Majority Port, like you respect I I respect definitely as
someone who like I think is very well read and analyze these
things mostly with a pretty level head. And if it's like, all
right, if this guy's promoting it, I usually agree with most
of this person's stakes, if
the majority report. No, not at all. Completely on Sam. >> Yeah,
100%. You can't have that many bad people around you for that
long and then like have none of the like
Yeah, that's just insane. Yeah,
Wick, why are you pretending you're concerned about having bad
people around you? It's like radiation.
You are a ghoul. You are literally a smooth You are literally
the opposite of a smooth skin right now. You are so You are insanely
radiated. Okay, you're
>> Yeah, it's a it's radioactive, guys. >> It's wild
to me that you >> Sorry. I mean, a ghoul from Fallout,
obviously. Okay. >> Like I I think if anything my view
of this is similar to your p you know your description of how
this has gone which is Sam has taken a bunch of positions I don't
agree with over the years and has moved farther away from where
I would agree with him back maybe 2018 time. But to say like
hey I used to really respect you and now I have 180 I don't agree
with a single thing that you're talking about or promoting. I
just think that's insane. Like that's not I don't I want no Soy
pill you don't understand. Ultimately it all comes down to they're
MAGA and they will destroy democracy immediately. Okay. It's
a massive threat right now and we need to talk about it. We need
to cut these people out because we definitely have choices to
make with regards to electoralism.
Dude, it's so funny that they do the abundance thing. Oh, just
run the candidate who works best and they totally ignore how
these candidates could work best in a bunch of different >> I'm
going to give it to to Kraut and uh and I got to use Russian
real quick. So, I'll be right back. So, Kraut, go ahead.
>> Kind of lost my train of foot.
Sorry. Uh yeah. No, don't worry. Where was I? I since you brought
up Sam Ceda, he also did this thing of blaming the Russian invasion
of Ukraine on NATO expansion and blah blah blah blah. >> No,
dude. I these people actually make me somebody like this guy.
He makes me
He does so much harm to the Ukrainian cause. He does so much
harm to the Ukrainian cause. Okay, it's it's crazy. Listen to
this guy. So harmful. Shut up about Ukraine. shut up about Ukraine.
I I like Ukraine. I sit here, I cheer when they sign the weapons
deal, when I get to watch them blowing up in a cool way. I love
it. And then I have to listen to this guy and I'm like, "Dude,
you you actually are so embarrassing." Like it has nothing to
do with this
Nothing at all. Blah blah blah. He also did that thing. >> Um
America, all of those people are like they hate the West America.
Everything that is related to it is like evil and terrible. I
think I I think what I wanted to tell you is I see no obligation
for people like the way all of this transpired this takeover
of progressive victory and the first thing they did right was
not like you keep talking about as if this was a policy organization
but the one of the main reasons why we're talking here certainly
the reason why I'm why Wick invited me in here was because the
first thing these people did was turn around and attack their
enemies. The first thing they did.
>> That's not true.
Dude, I'm sorry. Destiny repeatedly attacked them. Why are you
Why is this all framed around Desi being a victim? He repeatedly
attacked them. That's how this started on Twitter was Destiny
them.
And not to mention Desi is like the antithetical thing to what
that organization is trying to do >> was going after their
personal inventors, etc. It's the only thing they [__]
do all the [__] time. And when you keep saying this
thing where you say, "Oh, you need to work with people anyway,
even if you have disagreements." This isn't just about disagreements.
These are people who like talk about
the way they engage with us is not a disagreement. It has the
goal to have us annihilated. Their goal is to annihilate the
center left, to annihilate the center in general, to drive it
out of the political conversation. And as someone who is in the
center, I see no reason to engage with someone like that. No
reason to work with someone with that, even if there is some
sort of supposed common goal. And I can't even think of what
the common goal supposedly is right now. Okay.
>> Every time they've given this guy time to speak on this
panel, it's been a massive mistake. It's been just a massive
mistake every single time this guy has spoken.
Literally nothing of value any time he's opened his mouth.
>> Captain, this is a question for you. And >> can
I pose a question? Just cuz I barely
>> And I know >> this is the one time I love that
going to be here. And I pray she does the same thing she does
to any small creator. She totally ignores what they just said
and cuts in with her thing and basically tells them you you're
stupid. Don't talk. Okay, cuz this is the one time I will actually
appreciate it. Usually it's like I'm I'm kind of annoyed cuz
the other person's like genuinely trying to just get like off
the ground as a streamer, but this guy's a and he needs to be
he needs to be casually shugged shrugged away in the way only
Aerodyite can do. Okay. >> Oh, I know my mic is off. Um
I'm just genuinely curious your guys' thoughts cuz I don't think
I actually >> Oh, you're just genuinely curious. I'm just
like legitimately genuinely so curious. Really, >> you
know the answer and I don't think it's obvious that they're >> hands
out. Hands on head. I'm just genuinely so curious. Hands on my
head. Hands on my head. Right now, guys, I'm just genuinely so
curious. Hands on my >> Is a super clear answer. When you
guys think about like how to party with when I I look at the
right for example, like MAGA, there's a lot of like unions that
>> just spoke a whole bunch. Okay. I I I like Aerodite
for this one minute even despite that. Okay. because she just
totally shifted the conversation away from anything Kraut said.
Just basically was like, "You are worthless as a human. You have
nothing of value to contribute. Shut the up forever. Here, I'm
taking it in a different direction." The one time, okay, thank
you, Ardite. Thank you, Ardite. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Even though they're actually very opposed to one another and
they have a lot of issues, right? And I understand MAGA's and
we all hate them, blah blah, all the things that you guys need
to say like, "Yes, we hate MAGA." The question that I would have
is essentially is there some level of like political unification
on the left of like activating the left that has to happen where
we do have to essentially break red to some degree with people
who are enemies. My question would be but should you just keep
in mind that there are enemies? Are there certain people that
we can work with that are in like the
hate look at the Mar coalition look at the Mara coalition they
never emphasize their disagreements
all themselves. They defend all of themselves no matter what.
They're always at each other's backs and they all support the
candidate. That's the difference on the left. These people do
not support the candidate. LIKE
>> WHAT IS THIS INSANE FICTION?
WHAT WHAT DO WE CALL THE MANGA civil war? What the is Tucker
doing? What the is Candace doing? What the [__] is
Fentes doing? What in the are you talking about? You are insane.
You have nothing of value to say anymore. Oh, they never talk
about each other. Shut up. They are literally having a schism
over what issue, by the way? What issue? the same issue the left
should be having a schism over but you guys refuse to even entertain
the conversation. Okay, that's the issue. Holy man,
>> you can't have like there's just no serious political
commentator that was >> I didn't even I didn't even get
my water because I had to come back and and talk about that totally
thing that was just said. They don't talk about each other at
all, guys. They never go after each other at all. They like to
not do that, but unfortunately when they have major issues, they
do need to resolve them and there are schisms that form.
Holy [__] Like valiantly advocating to vote for Kla
Harris in in 2024. Like anybody who was not on that page like
shouldn't have a voice in any left leaning movement unless they're
like 12 or something, right? Right. Unless we're a literal child.
Like there's >> Wait, I totally forgot. The biggest streamer
on the right wing is actively saying, "Do not vote for the Republicans
in the midterm. Vote Democrat."
the biggest streamer on that. Maybe second biggest or third biggest
after Candace and Asmin Gold. Wait, top three streamer on that
side. Vote Democrat in the next election. These people have you
over Jesus. Okay, now I agree with that. Now my question is if
I'm someone who's trying to emulate the type of stuff you did
in 2020 and say, "Look, now I have an audience. Now I have money.
Now I want to do something and actually get Democrats elected
and there's this organization that I should not work with because
they have people like that in it or work with people like that.
What do I do with all that time, money, and energy if I can't
form my own organization without the money? >> I got a
potential answer for you. Go ahead. A buddy of mine uh says that
there is a alternative to progressive >> Guys, have you
heard of Z Cohen Sanchez, infamous liar and incompetent?
Well, if you want something like progressive victory, look no
further. We've got another incompetent organization for you that
will do political organizing. Let's go. And he wants to give
a quick pitch for it. Right. So, I'm going to bring him on and
uh he can maybe pitch it to
>> Blow Trace.
>> Oh, boy. >> Yeah. What's up, Wick? >> Yeah.
You got a you got something to pitch to Buddy Soyfield cuz he's
asking like he's asking for alternatives here. Go ahead. >> Yeah.
No, I I would say go to digital groundgame.org. It is a organization
run by a lot of us who actually did the PV program in 2024 and
we're looking for, you know, no shade or flame on TV necessarily,
but looking for more of a center-left uh way to do similar kinds
of that work. mobilize online community, streamers, kiddo camping
and stuff like that. It's pretty awesome.
>> Only question needs to be asked. How involved is SEO
this time? That's the only question. It's the only question you
should want to ask. How involved is SEO? Is he involved? No.
Well, well, that's 90% of the work gone. >> If you want
to check it out, digital groundgame.org. We've got a Discord
where everything happens. >> Is this a Z thing? >> No,
it is not. It is. I know. A very unfortunate name. It is. Yeah,
it's completely different. It's a very similar. Z is National
Ground Game. Ours is digital ground game. They're very similar
names and we love Z. We're great friends, but it is a totally
different thing. We're all about organizing online communities,
whether that's getting them to go show up to their local things
like we organize lots of people to go out to no kings or get
involved with local Democratic parties or more big things like
canvasing events, canvasing houses, things that you've seen from
sort of this online space previously. So, if anyone wants to
get involved, we're always more than happy to have more >> Add
me on Discord, send me a message like I Yeah, this is a better
alternative. That's what I'm looking for. That's what I've been
asking for.
>> Yeah. Well, thanks Flow Trace. We're going to let you
go now. appreciate. Have a good one.
>> Go ahead.
>> Uh, so should our only relationship with anyone I guess
where's the line of where we would say at this point this person
is shown to be so costic that we can't is it not getting behind
the dominant
>> I'm going to draw this line. I'm going to draw this
line. >> Does the candidate have to be Gavin Newsome or
are we >> It literally doesn't matter who the candidate
is. None of that was a consideration for people on the right.
Every single person there you cannot name even the centrist people
were supporting Donald Trump. Nobody was >> Are you talking
about people on social media now? How you talking about >> It
could be. No, no. I'm saying I'm >> No, not you. Not you.
Not you. I mean uh right. Sorry. >> I'm asking drone association
associ. >> Yeah. I'm asking which social media creators.
Yeah. Specifically.
>> Okay. My goodness. So is DG trying to get people back
in Destiny's orbit. Yeah. That's explicitly what the original
America tour was about. That's why they joined up with America.
It was to try to get Destiny
uh I I believe it was trying to get Destiny like some more profile
again. And I believe Aerodite like explicitly tried to recruit
former orbiters to it. So like it's it is that's what this would
be as well. I I assume I assume you go with the name digital
ground game because you want the overlap with DG, right? That
seems pretty obvious. Maybe that's totally maybe that's totally
up of me to suggest and they don't actually associate with Destiny.
I wouldn't personally
uh if you're trying to build something that lasts, you should
not attach your opinion to the you should not attach your reputation
to this person. That's all I'm telling you. Okay? They will always
put their reputation above you
no matter what.
Do not attach your reputation to this person. It will your organization
up. Although if it's called digital ground game, then maybe it's
just straight up Destiny's thing. So hard to say. >> We
should be associating that. >> Okay. The line that I've
drawn is that everyone who in any capacity promoted bad empanada
can burn in hell. >> Oh, sure. I I think that's good. But
the issue is that's probably not actually as as far as Destiny
is drawing it because there's probably a lot of people that don't
support bad panata. It includes
a but there's well sure but there's probably a lot of people
that don't like bad empanada that are somewhat like still about
like being anti-American or like are very negative towards G.
>> Didn't Destiny retweet bad empanada like yesterday?
Am I crazy?
Didn't he didn't Destiny retweet bad empanada i.e. promote him
like yesterday or the day before? Okay. Oh. Oh well cool. What
was bad and empanata doing? harassing somebody.
Oh, okay. Cool. Wow. Multiple times Destiny retweeted him multiple
times, I'm being told.
What? Yep. And Loader Box's Discord are rooting for bad empanada
against Asan, too. Kind of openly. Yeah. It's sort of interesting
how it went from this guy tried to kill us, he's total scum to
actually we love this guy in like two seconds. This guy's total
scum. We hate him. Actually, he he's awesome. LET'S GO BAT A
BANANA. OH, very cool, man. Super cool. >> Gavin Newsome
or any other strong like >> I still have to encounter that
person. Another line I would draw is Ukraine. Everyone who is
on that's probably because it's more closer to me. Everyone on
the wrong side of the Ukraine issue can go to hell. And um basically
how you treat your opponents. >> Wait, hold on, hold on,
hold on. What positions did bad empanada have? What did bad empanada
do that they really disavowed and didn't like? And is bad empanada
turned over a new leaf?
Because the only thing I think that switched up for B and Panata
was who he was going after. And it's like, oh, we are totally
fine promoting this guy so long as he's going after who?
Like if you just want any indication of the obvious spitebased
politics, right? You know what I'm saying?
Oh, we totally support bad empanada now. Well, wait, why? Well,
actually, he just hates Assan now, so he's awesome. Don't you
understand?
What? Don't you understand? He hates Assan now. He's awesome.
I mean, one of the greatest
elaborate on that bit. >> Well, one of the greatest things
about being a liberal is that it's it's universalist.
It's seeing the humanity in your opponent. Seeing the humanity
and those you disagree with, appreciating disagreement. And when
you look at like the Hassan sphere and the general sort of vicious
toxic leftist sphere around him, they obsess only with enemies
and how to annihilate their enemies.
That's not like anyone who thinks in that way. Anyone who engages
politics at these
dude I dude how how do you maintain a straight face as he says
this on this panel? How do you sit here anybody who who focus
on politics in terms of annihilating your enemies? Those people
are terrible and I would never support them. And you just see
like Soy Bill, Wick, Aeronite, they're all just sort of like
their eyes are glazing over. They have this like performative
like haze they fall into. They're like don't say it. Don't say
it. Don't say it. Don't say it. Don't say >> these ways.
Who only draws the distinction between enemy and friend?
>> So, I agree with that. I agree with that. I think that
that's a really easy line and I'm completely comfortable. The
issue is that my suspicion >> are you completely comfortable
with that? Is that is that how it works? >> Is that there
are more people that probably Destiny is suggesting that you
don't work with, I could be wrong, that wouldn't fall into that
category that are maybe less costic. But if you like, for example,
typically my one of my biggest lines is do they want the eventual
erosion of private property? Then I don't really think I'd throw
my
>> Damn it. Soy bill got up right at that exact time. Listen,
I try not to think of it in terms of like if they're spite based
and just try to destroy people, I won't hang out with them cuz
that would be financially devastating to me. So what I try to
think is do they want to abolish private property? Right? Do
they think that like the the moral imperative sorry the the requirement
to work the requirement to consistently give away hours and hours
of your life every single week so that you can just live is that
morally wrong in some way. If they think that then that's the
kind of person I can't work with. But if they just like attack
people and try to destroy them completely well no I'm totally
down with that. So let's try to focus in on what matters. Do
you hate do you support the abolishment of private property at
from here to any point indeterminate in the future? If yes, then
you're a terrible human being. >> My team, the issue is
that >> why only private property? What? What? You have
this funny thing with that. What is it with you? >> Okay,
WE LOVE THE BIRD AGAIN. WHAT the This is like a weird You keep
saying this weird thing. Do you have like a personal vendetta
that you're engaging with engaging in against like one specific
person? You keep saying this private property thing. It's almost
like you're just obsessed with private property. Is that like
a standard for somebody you are obsessed with and hate?
Do you Do you What? Why do you keep doing that? >> It's
a pretty good rule of thumb. It's usually a pretty good rule
of thumb. Usually people who are going to be anti-private property
just like are going to be fundamentally like pretty open to tanky
stuff. I just like find it's a good rule of thumb. That's all.
>> Immediately fall back entirely from saying that it's
indicative of something. It's just a good rule of thumb, guys.
It's just a good rule of >> Policy I'm very opposed to.
>> Oh. Uh Digital Ground Game is the political group that
works on the pragmatic papers and does online and offline political
activities. It is basically the political arm of DG. Okay. Yeah,
that's what I figured.
>> Cool. Hey, we all have these. Um, I I might have a
>> By the way, I broadly wouldn't even like I'm probably
never going to go to the digital ground game stuff and like if
they're canvasing for a specific person. I'm probably never going
to like mock the idea of them canvasing, right?
I would mock the idea that anybody would get involved with that
and tie their reputation to Destiny,
but that would be it. That'd be all even more kind of lines.
But there's a diff I I just also want to make a distinction between
a difference between like anyone who wants to vote for my candidate,
I will take your vote. It does not matter. If you want to vote
for them, cool. Uh but when it comes to working with you, I have
a much higher bar than
am I willing to collaborate with you? And I'm not just talking
have you on the same stage as me because I can have people I
disagree with all the time and I do have people I disagree with
all the time that I would never work with, but I will engage
with. But if you want me to collaborate with you and to go to
your event to promote your event to
um basically be a figurehead or be part of whatever thing you
got going, you do have to be liberal in nature, right? At least
for me. And uh yeah, that that's my line. I don't know what everyone
else What about you, Mr. Mr. uh Soy Pill? What are your lines?
Where would you say I'm not going to work with this
>> You have to be liberal.
Is that what he
Hold on. Um, I need to basically be a figurehead or be part of
whatever thing you got going. You do have to be liberal in nature,
right? At least for me. And uh, yeah, that's my line. I don't
know what everyone else What about you, Mr. >> Liberal
in nature? Okay, that's uh,
>> Mr. uh, Soy Pill, what are your lines? Where would you
say I'm not going to work with this organization anymore?
Um, I think definitely one of the lines, I don't know if it's
the threshold, but one of the lines is if you're unwilling to
support the Democratic candidates in the general because it's
not your preferred, you know, sock democ candidate, whatever
the trying to push in the primary, then you don't support us.
You're just using us to support your candidates and then dipping
immediately. I think Assan clearly has indicated that he would
do that clearly like based on all the rhetoric. So that's someone
like if it was his or then it's like, well, I know you're not
going to help him. >> Well, I think soy pill says that.
I would I would just put it to Soy Pill that it's pretty obvious
Hassan would support those candidates. He's just not willing
to say it now.
Like I I'm sorry. It seems pretty obvious to me from the things
Hassan has said. I think Hassan actually just went back and said
like did he not basically like on the Gavin comment? I thought
he did. I thought he basically went back and said like obviously
I'd probably vote for this guy, but like I'm just trying to,
you know, I'm trying to make the point that I don't want to commit
a vote right now. I don't even want to.
No, I'm pretty sure he did. Ramandas is saying he did. Or Yonko
says no. I thought he went back and just basically said, "Yeah,
obviously I'm gonna I'm gonna vote for Gavin." Matt saying he
did. Yeah. Yeah. I knew he did because I remember being like,
I don't think you had to on this, but okay, I guess. >> Plus,
when it come push comes to shove, but it seems like Pave is going
to do this or at least has been doing it and if they stop doing
it, that's definitely a line. >> What does it mean if Pave
is willing to do it? But if 80% of the people they work with
aren't, doesn't that just mean when it comes time for PV to rally
support in the general, they're just not going to get any support
for it? >> If that's what I see, >> dude, it's what
which one of these people has? By the way, there's the same line
and that's how you By the way, dude, it's it just becomes so
obvious, right? What was the issue that all of these people stood
on and said, "I can't vote for this. In good conscience, I will
not vote for somebody who is okay with this." What was it? It's
pretty obvious, right?
You flip that one thing and all these people are totally on your
side. Read the yellow dono. What is liberal culture right now
in America? Wearing zipper hoodies and 2013 techware fighting
obsessively to defend Israel. Tired of playing catch-up? can't
develop political stars anymore
>> happening then yeah >> by then it's too late when
you keep saying if that's what is happening by that point it's
too late you have to
>> well like if you were
to do something else then yes >> no I'm saying if we if
it was 5 months working with PV and then by the very end of like
we're coming up to the general for the primary or for the midterms
and it's like oh sh these guys aren't backing anybody else I've
made a mistake at that point it's too late >> what have
I lost by contributing energy and time to them >> by contributing
energy and support to people who are actually pushing for Democrats
has to win in general, >> right? But if they didn't win
and if they're not going to help my candidate and if there was
no better alternative to me, ultimately it was a fruitless effort,
but I haven't like made a choice that me. It was just, oh, it
turns out you're you're disingenuous. I'll never work with you
again. But if it was I had to choose them over an or that was
actually going to do what I wanted to accomplish, that would
be the last >> Okay, so just is the thing is that there
>> he's going to Dude, it's it's going to be it is really
hard to go down this road of realizing
at the bottom of it all. It sucks. I hate I hate even agreeing
with the concept. Okay.
But at the end of this road, you're going to realize
that unfortunately
they're the ones making it about Israel and that's really their
line. And that's like what this is all about. They're trying
to talk about communism. They're trying to talk about all these
different things to get away from the one thing they want to
keep
The one thing you could give away and get the entire left on
your side like immediately. It's It's so funny cuz I I hate to
It is like thought terminating almost, right? But that is like
their line. And when they make fun of you for it being your line,
don't get fooled. They're just trying to flip it. They're just
trying to project it's their line. Look at the polling. Look
at the direction it's going. Okay? Just flip flip on that one
issue and then run total capitalists. Okay? Run abundance libs
who don't want to support Israel.
Nobody will have a problem voting for them. So easy. There's
no other conceivable place where you can put your time right
now besides an organization.
>> Until this DG digital ground game thing was brought
to my attention, there wasn't a clear path forward here. And
now it seems like, okay, yeah, if it's a zero someum game between
dedicating my time and energy, I'm definitely picking the one
where I'm 100% sure they'll vote for the Democrat and push for
the Democrats and has an audience that'll, you know, promote
that Democrat in general, then apparently this one who you're
skeptical of, but I have yet to see evidence that they won't
do that.
>> there's just evidence of them doing it across multiple
elections. So there's totally there's evidence of them doing
it across multiple elections. You actually have way less evidence
that it will happen with this other group other than the fact
that Destiny says so, right? Or Eerite says so or whoever's involved
says so. You have actual historical evidence that PB will support
those candidates.
So I don't I don't >> What was the example that guy gave
earlier about what was it? Let me look at this race that Jonah
gave.
>> I don't I don't remember the the which state it was
the governor's race in. No, but he talked about phone banking
and and to me phone banking just isn't >> I don't know.
That's me, but whatever.
>> What are you eating? >> I'm curious. Is there
anything? Can we find Is there anything on like PV's like Twitter
or anything about them promoting this at all? Like is this anywhere?
Did this actually happen in a meaningful way
>> New Jersey Governor, right? Are they talking about Mikey
Cheryl? Did Pave go out and canvas for Mikey Cheryl? Is that
what they're talking about? Maybe this is an example that was
brought up over and over again like this. S H E R I L. >> Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Easy, >> easy. Yeah, surely on
their Twitter account they would have some
support of her. Correct. >> I don't know. That's what I
was asking, but I mean I can check. It's okay. >> Apparently,
you can't search on Twitter if you're from a bench. So, sorry.
>> New uh NJ uh New Jersey governor.
Their preferred person lost.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Shut up. Hold on. Shut
>> Decision desk HQ projects Mikey Cheryl to win the New
Jersey governor election. OUR FIRST VICTORY OF THE NIGHT. PROGRESSIVE
VICTORY. # ELECTION2025.
WOW. SO, they're celebrating it at the very least, right? Be
cheers all around. Okay. Well, they're doing their best. Oh,
and five months ago, Progressive Victory endorses Rep. Cheryl
for New Jersey governatorial election next month. Join our phone
banking efforts here. Oh, so they did both. Oh, cool. Oh, cool.
Wow. They like Mikey Cheryl. They love Mikey Cheryl.
Isn't that awesome? initial one was >> I don't >> just
one tweet really just one tweet guys just one tweet really >> yeah
but uh
okay so they had a progress my I think I'm understanding this
they had a progressive candidate they preferred that person lost
and then they made calls for the Cheryl Still >> Mickey
Cheryl is the New Jersey governor Mickey Cheryl by the way just
it's like a weird thing to notice
just how like this space is so warped it's like a weird lens
why did the content totally stop because Destiny was googling
a link like Destiny didn't believe what the guy said who was
from Progressive Victory. So the content totally stopped. It's
just like the lens of this is so odd to me now. Now that you're
looking from the outside looking in, it's like wait, why did
you all stop talking?
>> Yeah. Do we see any promotion on their site? Do we see
any promotion on their socials? Do we see any promotion on >> Well,
if they legitimately did phone banking, they might not have a
ton of promotion. Um, unless we just think that >> I can
point to you promotional material that they put out for um the
primary candidates, right? Like so. >> Keep talking, Wick.
Keep talking. >> By the way, it took me 5 seconds to find
that. Five seconds. Although I knew who Mikey Sher was. >> Primary
candidates that were running uh recently in the election, I think
in Chicago, I believe it was. >> Um, can we point to promotional
material of a similar nature to Mickey Cheryl? >> I promise
you Destiny's found it at this point. I promise you it took me
two seconds. Desi's 100% found it at this point and doesn't know
which direction what argument he's going to make. Now he's trying
to figure out what argument he's going to make right now that
he's been proven wrong categorically. He's like, "Wait, which
one do I say like isn't enough? Do I try to show like other progressive
candidates and how hard they push them and say, look, it's like
not even that much. How do I change the conversation to to like
basically pivot from the point I was making to one where I don't
look? That's what this pause is. Okay. He's trying to he Dude,
I'm telling you, he's trying to formulate a different argument.
He found he found these the phone banking immediately and he's
actually just trying to formulate a totally different argument
or trying to figure out how to not look totally moronic now that
obviously they did phone bank. Obviously, this is the case. He's
just trying to discredit and discredit it in any way he can.
The question was, did they actually promote or do anything for
Mikey Cheryl?
They did and he found it and now he has to go to a different
argument. He's trying to figure out, okay, where do I go in the
conversation?
>> What uh what do you mean about like leftist about tankies?
>> Just a totally bad faith actor. It's actually embarrassing
>> about working at what point would you at what point
all these things? >> My my reference point here entirely
is history. Like I think I told you before that my dad used to
work with anti-communist dissident in Czechoslovakia in the 1980s.
So a lot of my views of who these people are and how they operate
is shaped by like
how like the way the communists came to power in Czechoslovakia
was in 1948 through a coup in which they overthrew the government
and the way they gained the power to get into government was
by consistently lying to the social democratic and the liberal
parties in Czechoslovakia. They told them we're democratic. We're
trying to achieve liberal Marxism.
We're trying to do this and that. We're moderating ourselves.
They deliberately moderated themselves to get elected into power
to come into government and then they >> I every single
every single contribution built up police for everyone was called
of communistic.
>> So I am >> power in Czechoslovakia the first people
they rounded up and had murdered were all the liberals and so
I am seeing just FYI I am seeing them promote Mickey Cheryl in
>> I will say it's a little it's a little sarcastic. They
literally say it's good enough after the preferred person person
lost. So, it's definitely not a rousing. >> Wait, what?
They literally say it's good enough.
Wait, where do they say? Like her, it's good enough. Oh, the
Like her, it's good enough.
Yeah, I think they're leaning into the idea that like, hey, even
though we didn't support her,
right? Isn't Wait,
isn't that leaning into well, we didn't support her in the primary,
but like her, it's good enough.
Isn't that exactly what you want to agree that like, hey, we
should go and actually vote for her.
It's not lying. It's not disingenuous. It's not saying she's
your preferred candidate. Saying, "Hey, go vote for her. She
is good enough." >> Support. Um, >> it's good enough.
>> I don't know. Definitely would not have been how I promoted
an event, but uh that's just me.
I mean, so it's there. We got to give them their flowers for
>> It is there.
>> He's just been thinking about how you spin this now.
I don't think there's any way Soy Pill could like understand
this at all cuz it's like I one I am used to watching this person
flounder. But two,
and when he goes back and watches this, I just want Soy Pill
to review and see that like he was correct again. He's totally
correct again
and they are doing anything they can to try to spin it as him
being the wrong person or having done something wrong. He's answered
the questions, every single question perfectly. Okay, I'm sorry.
When has Hassan or his community ever done this to like a coworker
in the same way where they are literally in a like 5v1 conversation
trying to convince you that everything you're doing is wrong.
When has that ever happened? This is a cult. This is a cult.
Okay. None of these people are operating in good faith even
>> Good. Go ahead. >> Did um did the PB people did
they ever I understand that I'm persona not did they reach out
to like Josiah or >> dude totally different argument. Hey,
could you concede that you were totally wrong? You were completely
wrong. They went out and they phonebang for this candidate. They
endorsed them and they celebrated when she won. Are you serious?
Well, no. Correct me if I'm wrong. Did Pavey reach out to like
Josiah? I'm sure he was messaging Josiah saying, "Hey, did PV
reach out to to be a part of this?" Right.
>> BTC or I don't I don't know anything about their workings.
I have no idea.
>> I could. Do you want me to ask? The person I'm asking
didn't even work with PB on any of these things. They just used
to. >> Well, sure. I'm just curious if they did because
I because almost everybody at that I think was like a recognizable
like Democratic party hater left like super lefty person >> except
for Mr. Beat and
>> and Dylan
and Soy Pill and I'm sure some of the Democratic Party candidates
are not Democratic Party haters, right? I'm >> Neils, I
think basically. >> Sure. Yeah. >> What are your
plans going forward? You're you're like all Americans except
for for for
I can't pronounce your name. Sorry. Um
>> Dev and Aerodite are both not American. >> Dev
was Canadian too actually. Okay, that was
>> I'm the least American immigrant. Okay, I get sunflowers.
>> What are I can't tell you what to do with organization
when it comes to uh the midterms >> engaging like I I'm
not American. I can I can [__] on these people all
I want and I'm going to
um in particular as long as they keep talking
>> Americans can do that too. Actually, it turns out that's
the great thing about America.
They can do that all they keep talking about Ukraine. That's
my plan for the future. Oh, so what >> I mean this is a
good question which is like the tactical versus the principal,
right? And this is the this is the actual tension I'm trying
to sort out. What's tactically effective versus like principally
effective? I think >> there's no tactical effectiveness
here because the people that are claiming to be tactically effective
don't actually think the other side is that bad. Like the SW
seems like he's like 85% in agreement in terms of what they're
saying or he doesn't seem that huge of a
which I not Hassan. All right. Like these are very different
people. The fact that you I I can't believe if you go watch like
the majority report now I feel like you'd agree with like 78%
of what Sam Cedar is saying. If you disagree with that, like
I like I think we should go test it. Like maybe I'm wrong, but
I I can't believe that you >> Well, one of the issues with
this argument is that if even even if we said that we agree with
70%, if the 30% that we disagree with is fundamental to like
liberalism and like the things that we value as like the
>> it's not though. It's literally not. And you explicitly
get told that, hey, it's not fundamental. We're not trying to
erode rights. We're never going to do something that's anti-electoral.
We're not trying to take over. Right? You get told this over
and over and over again and you refuse to accept it every single
>> It's not even fundamental to liberalism. We we can't
move away from ideology. It's just it's a one-way street. That's
the issue. All of these things are one way streets. They will
never ever ever ever ever come out and ardly support like a moderate
Dem in the general. Like a lot of these people
>> um Sam might maybe, but whatever. >> Just nothing
you're saying is correct. You literally haven't said a correct
thing on this entire panel. How are you a guy people respect
on the internet? How what has happened? You've said nothing correct.
Everything you've said has been wrong. Literally every point
you've made on this panel has been horrendous dog. >> Is
completely and totally destroyed by all the people around. Dude,
when there was that election, the series of like special elections,
it was like six months ago. I thought that Emma was legit on
stream when all the moderate dems were winning because you could
tell how hyped they were to see all these Dems lose because they
weren't as wacky far left as they wanted them to be. Like
>> You mean the Mumani victory that they all were out celebrating
together? You mean the Maldani victory where they were literally
at a party in New York City that Meldani threw celebrating that
massive win for their coalition? They were literally WE WATCHED
IN FACT, I'M SURE THIS GUY REACTED TO THE PARTY. NO, DIDN'T THIS
GUY REACT TO THE PARTY. Literally Hassan [__] Medi
Hassan, Emma Vigant,
like Sam Cedar. I watched them all. They were all at this party,
weren't they? I thought they were all at that party. Was Em was
on stream and I didn't see the clip, but I like that was the
night Montani won. So many people were psyched. That was the
biggest victory the coalition has had since AOC was elected.
Girl, it seemed like she had to like triple up on her pros act
to survive that night. I'm not even joking. She was so upset.
Like these people are >> Okay, if that's true my 7030,
but to be clear, I know they don't like moderate dems, but I'm
pretty sure they'd support >> You can't It doesn't It like
>> It doesn't work that way.
>> This is It's Dems, but I'm pretty sure they'd support
them. You can't. It doesn't. It like
you can't. It's just It just
You can't. It just It This is It's This is Don't work to have
because everybody knows I'm >> Dude,
hold on. >> You can't It doesn't It like
This is It's This is Don't work to have because everybody knows
that I'm intuitively correct. So, I don't know why I'm expressing
this. I don't
>> Everybody knows that I'm intuitively
Guys, don't you all know that I'm just intuitively correct all
the time? Don't you? Everybody just knows that I'm intuitively
correct. Why do you argue against me? Everybody knows that I'm
like correct automatically ontologically. Like why? Why argue?
Why are you arguing with me, guys? What?
Kylo sitting there just like, "Yes, I do know that. Yes. Yeah,
you are right all the time about everything." Yeah. >> Because
I'm bad. I genuinely don't get >> You do because I know
you apply this lens of thought to anybody else. I know you wouldn't.
If somebody says, um, I want singlepayer healthcare. This person
is only pushing for a public option. Okay, we're going to fight
it out in the primaries, but if I, you know, if we just can't
come to an agreement, you know, I'll support him in the general.
That's a position that is believable that a person can take and
can advocate for their audience. If your position is this person
is pro genocide, they're a pro genocidal Zionist, ethnorreligious
supremacist supporter, pro genocidal, proaparide state piece
of, there's no, it doesn't matter what your words are, like you
guys would have used all these arguments against the neo-Nazis
in the past. Oh, we're not racist. Dude, do you see how the first
argument that comes out once again
every single
time?
Every single time.
Right.
I I want to talk about anything else. I want to talk about literally
any other topic, but just take the morally correct position first.
Right? take the position that's not on the side of the country
that dragged you into this war, that's destroying the global
economy, that continues to exacerbate every possible turn, and
that is not on the side of the country that is destroying the
way of life of everybody around them. So simple, man. So simple.
It's so easy.
But actually, guys, they all say it's like really bad to support
this country. Yeah. I wonder why. Oh, we're not anti-semitic.
Lol. Because we said it. We can selfid not being this thing.
If you spend the entire time attacking the left from the frame
of like their genocidal apartheid supporters there, it doesn't
matter if you you pay lip service to supporting them in the general,
it doesn't matter. >> Wait, if I say if I say that I think
that
promoting genocide in Gaza, but I think it's absolutely imperative
that we vote for over Trump, is that in congruent position? >> If
what >> if Kla Harris is pro like you know destroying Gaza
and genocide based on the policies that she's promoting and that
said, I think it's imperative that we vote for over Trump and
do everything in our power to stop Trump because it's 100% going
to be these functionally congrent. What
is what?
He's literally making it immoral to to be against Israel. He's
literally making it immoral to not want Palestinian kids starve
to death. You're actually the total piece of cuz you're pointing
out these these Palestinian kids are starving to death. You're
actually the bad person. It's you.
This is beyond shameless, man. It's it's so shameless.
And I don't think he's getting paid. I do think this is entirely
derivative of Hassan is bad of he hates Hassan. He knows he would
have to agree with Hassan. He'd have to say Hassan was right
if he switches positions. So he can't and he won't.
That is all it is >> because you know what you're because
how the [__] you going to vote for somebody that's
pro genocide? That's an insane position at that point >> because
it's impossible to look at the like totality of an America and
its policies around the world and say I'm going to purity test
based on one thing and recognize that there are better options
no matter how bad you >> literally but all of these people
Ryan Grim and Emma and all these other people is literally what
they do. >> Isn't this like a solvable question though?
We just need >> So that's already been answered right that's
already been answered. The answer was
hey
if I felt the organization was doing that I wouldn't be a part
of the organization. They support the Dem candidate. They have
done so. I've proven it already. By the way, remember Destiny
brought up, did they really do that? He looked it up. He was
categorically proven wrong and then he pivoted away from it and
never Soy pill never extracted concession because it's a 4v1
or 5v1 conversation. Okay. But he was categorically wrong.
So now they've gone back to saying, "Well, uh, Ryan Grim's like
that." I don't even know if that's true. By the way, I don't
know if I'm guessing Ryan Grim would have liked Kala Harris.
I'm sorry, not liked, but would have stomached voting for Kla
Harris despite her Gaza position, right? But maybe not. Maybe
he is against it. I think that's dumb, by the way. I think that's
dumb because Trump is obviously going to give BB whatever he
wants. And I I hope I pray that Kamla wouldn't have gone to war
with Iran, but I don't know. I'm pretty sure I'm like 95% sure
on that still. Okay.
Anyway, so it's obviously a coherent position. I >> need
to know like to what extent is the audience of Sam Cedar and
Emma Vigaland will they basically fundamentally always refuse
to vote for like the broader party or are they going to gripe?
And I'm not >> We already did the Hold on. We already did
this. We already have seen this poll for Hassan's audience. Overwhelming
majority for Kla Harris in the 2024 election. Overwhelming majority
of votes for Kla Harris. We've already we've already done it.
And that's your worst example as apparently. Not saying that
the griping and complaining again because all that matters to
me is t is tactics, right? Which is making sure that the left
wins all of the upcoming elections and all these sort of things.
And I agree with like kicking a lot of these people out of group.
I've been a pretty staunch like kick the far leftist out. The
question is tactically, for example, if you're a canvasing group,
okay, so you're a DGA and you're in Illinois canvasing for some
moderate dems. What if there is a socialist chapter locally that
is willing to support you and canvas for your candidate? Will
you work with them or do you cut them out? >> This doesn't
happen. I don't know why. Like I don't even know if these people
>> ask hypothetical.
Why would you ask that stupid question?
Destiny is becoming that which he hated. Destiny is becoming
Kelly Jean. Oh no, he can't he can't answer a hypothetical. He
can't answer a hypothetical. What the >> willing to Didn't
the DSA pull their support from Amdani?
go support general people. It's like it's like like it's it's
fighted.
Oh, did the DSA support the retract their support M for Mani?
Didn't all of the creators you're currently about not retract
their support and were totally psyched about Mum Donnie winning?
Why would why would you now pivot to the DSA? Why are you pivoting
to a totally different organization out of nowhere? >> Probably
does happen some of the time, right? That
>> Oh, it did not. So, that didn't even happen. So, he
answered the hypothetical with something that was a lie. >> I
don't think so. >> They will show. Yeah. I I I think in
even in the federal election, we had a number of people that
came out that were like socialists who were still willing to
get in behind. >> No, we're talking about like the bigger
figures. We're talking about the leaders like I'm sure the liberals
can get these people in. >> No, no, no. Not like that is
always the answer, right?
Oh, well, if you show me a bunch of like some of these leaders
like Bosch, by the way, who you guys have been on,
Bosch has been vehemently blue no matter who in the general Republicans
are onlogically evil. You could never accuse Bosch in a million
years of being light on Republicans or equating the two parties.
Okay? You can't do it. You literally can't do it. But they're
still arguing against Vosch. Oh, Vosch is a total tanky. Vos
is a total piece of Vos was blue no matter who the whole time.
It's just it's crazy. And no, not Bosch though, but like the
other leaders like Emma Vigler, like like Hassan, right?
It's just always going to be no no quite like that. Apply my
just so story. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Don't give me
counter examples. look at the exact thing I'm saying and say
I'm wrong. Well, no, you're giving like one example that isn't
representative of the entire hole. Oh, okay. Not like that. Not
like that. Well, I don't even know if what if soy bill just calls
this out. I think you guys are giving examples that are not representative
of the hole because you don't actually have an argument like
progressive I already showed that progressive victory really
did phone bank for for the moderate liberal candidate in the
general sorry in the I guess it was a special election, right?
the candidate they didn't want. They they went out for her. They
they sold well they didn't sell the farm for her, but they they
went out and they canvas for her. They sorry, they phonebanked,
right? And then they celebrated when she won. So, it's already
been proven that it's not representative of the whole and that
Soy Pill is a part of an organization that is f focused on electoral
outcomes. The people who are litigating their petty, spiteful,
personal grievance are here. They're in the call with you, Soy
Pill.
It's not Hassan. It's not Bosch. It's not any of these people,
okay? And I hope I just pray he sees it >> involved. Sure.
Because some some of them will because the actual people the
the audience themselves are not as radical sometimes as some
of the content creators or are willing to support another candidate.
>> So then is there benefit of are there some content creators
that from being anti-America that essentially could be utilized
in such a way to pull them towards liberal causes that would
be tactically beneficial for liberals? It does that exist?
>> Whatever trade-off you're paying there, you're you're
losing it to the whole like having all of your conversations
held hostage by the same tired
uh anti- anti-billionaire corporate Dems. Both sides are the
same anti- genocide Gaza talking points over and over and over
and over again. >> Andals actually get their [__]
together and start making major movements and start making major
waves and having bigger political media figures that we can actually
get behind and work together. I'm all for that. The question
is tactically as we're building that thing. Is there going to
be a point in time where you do get soy pill on >> Oh,
we will we will be doing this substance. Absolutely we will.
This is very fun. I enjoy this a lot. I I always like think about
like, okay, how is this how is this movement going to do? Because
like
they seem to have moved past the reputational hit from Destiny
to some extent, right? And I'm always thinking like, how are
they going to do? And then I I I'm cuz I'm concerned that they're
going to get really big and then continue to harass me or my
channel, right? And then I actually tune in and watch and I'm
like, oh, this is embarrassing. Like, this is just sad to watch.
Like there's no way this survives contact with the outside world.
Right there. It's not built on anything. It is just built on
spite for Hassan. It can't survive contact with like a broader
political movement at all. It is just in this one narrow space
where Destiny has built a cult over a decade that it could possibly
work. And it's barely working here. when when he made the argument
earlier, the compelling the incredibly compelling awesome argument
of um I don't even know how to argue this because I'm just intuitively
correct.
That's incredible, man. Amazing. >> More leftist spaces
built because all of them are owned by tankies that everybody's
willing to work with. So can't even get off the ground. >> The
problem is is we have a limited amount of time, energy, and resources
to spend. And if we appeal to the Emma VMON's audience or to
Ryan Grim's audience, for every person we might get, right, from
appealing to them, we're gonna lose 10 who see us appealing to
them and are disgusted by it. These people are a cancer. They
will >> It depends on what you mean by appeal, right? Cuz
that's implying that I'm I'm saying we have to like yes man their
crazy policy. >> Well, they won't work with you otherwise.
Well, I don't know if that's necessarily true for every single
like what at should we start trying to should we start a pool
and just try to figure out at what level of disapproval for Israel
will these people flip?
Is it is there a number if it if it truly becomes a 9010 issue
for the entire Democratic party? Will they flip?
What do you guys think? They have to eventually. If it becomes
bad enough, they have to eventually. But like they've sort of
they've gone out on their their life raft and they have no other
no other island. Okay.
Is Israel is the only land in sight. They got nothing else. >> Leftist
essentially contact. I just don't know if that's actually true
>> with that new law today. Israel is sunk. Are you talking
about the one where Bengavir is trying to pop the champagne that
they're allowed to kill all of their prisoners and Bangavir's
in the Knesset popping champagne open?
DUDE, HOW DO YOU GUYS PULL OFF LOOKING SO insanely evil? It's
so crazy. This guy brought champagne to them determining that
they could kill Palestinian prisoners. Yes, 100%. That happened.
That is a real thing with news pins. That is Wow. I didn't notice
the newsp thing. We will cover that story in a little bit. Maybe.
Okay. Oh, the champagne video might have been old. Maybe. I I
don't know, man. I don't know. Hey, maybe I'm propagandized.
I didn't think so, but we'll check it out. It's so funny because
currently this is a rhetorical pivot from Dems. AOC is considered
to have a good record on Israel and she'll shoot down amendment
uh any amendment that would strip Israel defensive weaponry from
the from the US. Yeah, exactly. Oh, the defensive weapons thing
is very very goofy to me. We need weapons to defend ourselves.
Why are you striking Iran? Don't we have the right to defend
ourselves? I I see I see what's happening here. I see I see how
that is. I I see it. I would assume that that's true for the
large ones. I would just grant you that, right? But I'm asking
for like the minutia. What if you've got a 120k leftist account
that is willing to get behind the Democrats in the general election
and is willing to talk with you and you don't have to couch out
everything? Are are we able to >> I have to see that first.
I I'd have to see that first because that is not something that
is out there right now. >> I do not see anyone out there
who's willing to like in that space conceited even a millimeter.
>> Can you think of one?
I'm just praying that some liberal candidate somewhere in the
world goes, "Hey, I could be like I could be like pro expansionary
housing policy. I could be pro
I could be pro business, pro like business grants, pro subsidies
to big business and I can also be against funding Israel."
Oh my god, that's a that combination works. It's not like inherently
a communist belief that that Israel should be sorry that Israel
needs to not be funded anymore. It does doesn't mean you're a
communist automatically. Roana, that might be Roana. I'm hoping
more liberals will figure that out. Roana is more left-leaning
than just a liberal though. Roana does believe in like increasing
taxation cuz he's in the district with all the billionaires and
they literally apparently tell him we should be taxed >> Off
the top of my head. >> No, but I don't consume leftist
content so I don't That's a problem. Well, hold on. But that
my lack of finding an example isn't evidence that this cannot
exist, right? And >> well, hold on. But you could probably
name like 10 leftist content creators off the top of your head.
It's problematic. You can't think of a single one. Even if we
don't consume leftist >> there are lots of things that
I already No, no, no. This this has already been granted by me.
>> Guys, I can't think of a single leftist candidate who
doesn't want to destroy democracy. By this definition, Econo
Boy wants to destroy democracy, by the way. Okay. By this definition,
a connoy, the guy they hung out with forever that they basically
I think harassed out of this space entirely. Okay, maybe not.
Maybe not. But that's how it looks to me. That to them that's
a guy who wants to destroy democracy.
Okay. Yeah. When you keep figuring out new and exciting ways
to explain why these people are all tanksy tankies, Marxist Leninists,
people who are anti-democratic, when you keep figuring out new
ways to paint them all as the same thing, they're going to all
appear that way. Is that shocking to anybody?
Is that Yeah, obviously you're you're undertaking massive effort
to make it look this way. Yes, it's not shocking to me that to
your audience you can make that argument. >> Already granted
that I think the biggest ones are kind of write-offs. I think
that this is a legitimate problem. This is why I would never
work on an event that includes this. Not that he would ever work
on one with me either, right? Like this I've already granted.
What an >> he he might have some like pre-existing,
you know, dislike for working with people who support women being
victimized the way Erdite does. And realistically, I can't I
can't discredit Hassan for that. That is a noble position to
take. >> Asking is like when you're getting to the minutia
of like what this actually looks like, there is a tactical question
where you go if you're doing event that is supporting a moderate
Democrat and Sam Cedar is willing to come out and support that
moderate Democrat in the event, do you allow him to come through
or do you block him principally? This is like a question that
is beyond some doors that have yet to be open, which is why I
don't think it's worth considering. Like if we that this is a
good problem to have if we have socialist groups that are willing
to campaign in the general that are pushing for more extreme
stuff in the primary, but that's not where we're at. We're at
in a primary. It's over and over again all of these like socialist
types saying you're going to lose every single time until you
fully endorse our platform because all you are approach
that's why not just test it. Why not take the morally correct
position on Israel and see what happens?
Because I know that a bunch of people, by the way, Hassan
sold the farm for Biden in 2020, right? Obviously, he did. Why
did that happen if he will never support the damn candidate?
Can anybody explain that to
It's almost like there was something going on in 2024 that all
of these people took a moral stand against that they felt they
couldn't support a candidate who was doing this. Right.
Right. Kolinsky has literally said he would vote for the worst
Democrat any day over the best Republican. I'm sure he would.
Dude, it's it's just crazy. >> Proartid and you know that's
why the Democrats are keep losing [__] Avenue over
and over again. That's all these people. They really don't like
Israel. Yeah, that is just Bro, these people are these these
people are in a total echo chamber. They just don't see it. I
don't know. I don't know how they can't see it. It's everybody.
And it's not anti-semitism. It is stop blowing up the houses
of all of the poor people around you. Stop blowing up the houses
of all the poor people around you such that they can't even build
a life. such that they can't live, that they can never be happy
again. Stop trying to destroy happiness and beauty. Stop it.
I >> was saying look at the look at the response to the
hypothetical that Hassan got over um No, no, it wasn't Hassan.
It was between Hutch and uh Piso or whatever over like would
you vote for what was it? Like Gavin Newsome or who and the general
>> it was it was it was like it was like what was the origination
of this? It was JD Vance versus Gavin Newsome. I don't remember
who got asked this initially if this was >> because we're
talking about Hassan's thing and this like okay Hutch are you
going to have the same position if it was Assan versus JD Vance
who would you >> like these are GED level political commentator
questions you obviously would support Newsome regardless of how
progressive or socialist you are if you have trouble answering
that question then your opinion and your participation in any
Democratic movie should be wholly discarded
just totally thought terminating because you said this word because
you said these words right regardless of anything else you clarified
regardless of what the clear tactics are regardless of what anything
else is because you said these words you cannot participate in
democracy with us, >> Democratic party movement, you're
just not part of the same team. Like I like the sooner we realize
this, we would just be so much better off for it. It's such an
easy question. Like if >> the sooner you all listen to
me in my thought termination exercise, okay, the second you take
my word for it and do exactly what I say, we would all be happier.
You Soy pill, if you just listen to me and what I say and not
question it at all, maybe you'd stop getting DMs telling you
to keep yourself from DJs. Have you thought about that? You'd
just be so much happier if you weren't being told to kill yourself
constantly, right? Don't you think if you're having there will
never be elections or questions as easy as as it is right now.
And if you're genuinely stumbling on them, you're just like you're
fundamentally a different thing political, which is fine, but
just don't confuse it for being a part of the Democratic party.
How much So my confusion is that you constantly correctly point
out that these people don't really have true power. They never
get political movements off the ground. Their candidates mostly
fail unless they're in super safe districts. So if all that's
true, but they are able to have massive audiences and are able
to throw support behind moderate dems. They do. That's the if
big if. Then why is it worse to include them? How much more are
they harming than they're helping if they're not powerful enough
that could be politically effective?
>> The boss is going to throw behind Roana. Is that good
or bad? And do we work on a >> I don't care about Roana.
Roana is his own on his own little island. Okay. That's like
a
>> I don't care about Stop bringing up examples. Stop bringing
up examples of where I'm wrong. I don't care about Roana. Hey
Destiny, didn't you do an event with Roana?
I don't care about Roana. He's by himself. No. Roana has actual
analysts looking at looking at polling, looking at issues and
saying, "Here's what it would be smart to support." You don't
think the guy with the biggest contributors in the entirety of
America in his district has a lot of money to put towards analytics
and figuring out what the right positions are to take.
>> He's like a snowflake. I'm just saying that in general
in general will throw in behind you Buddha judge. >> 100%.
That'd be cool. That'd be great. That'd be great. But what I'm
saying is that these the way that these people work is they just
overwhelmingly
they they
it's all I I hate to say it, okay? This conversation with Soy
Pill just straight up shows the anti-Zionists aren't anti-genocide.
They're very progenocide. They just want it to happen to James
because they feel like that's to justify genocide. That's really
what it all is what all of it boils down to. Even though it's
the arc that got me into Destiny, I'm glad he's done with it.
Dude, soy bill where he's Soy bill is sitting here like, "Guys,
I'm begging you for any organization." Oh, you have an I'll I'll
look at it, guys. I I don't support Hassan at all, guys. I
dude Soy has shown me that these people just want all the killed.
It's like, okay. Yeah.
Insane levels. JN levels off the charts. Okay. Never before seen.
This is JN Chernobyl out here. Okay. >> They hijack the
Democratic party's messaging so that we have to talk about that
they care about that the broader electorate doesn't care about
that overwhelmingly slants like younger, whiter, more affluent.
>> Yeah. Yeah, definitely. I'm I'm pretty sure that people's
position on Israel if they're white, that's far more they're
far more likely to be anti-Israel than if they're brown. Yep.
Yep. Yep. And then even if they're not, like it's not like they're
so powerful that they can win elections because if they >> I
can't think of a single brown community that might be anti-Israel.
I just I can't do it, guys. I can't think of it. Would there
could there possibly
>> Have their own candidates in places that are just trying
to lead off the Democrats. But just because you're not powerful
enough to win your own races doesn't mean you can't negatively
impact dramatically negatively impact
a socialisty type of person that will throw in behind Dems and
consistently does. So I think Contra Points is a good example
of a type of person who's probably more socialist coded. >> Hold
on. This is the worst. Watching Kyla just try to throw out lines
to bigger creators all the time. I'm going to show charity to
this really big creator. Just constantly networking, constantly
looking to get away from Destiny. Will any bigger creator give
me a platform? Can I am Punky Branch away, dude. My Gaines was
right. Sorry. I That was probably too far. That was too far.
That was too far. Okay, but she just said that and like that's
totally cutting against what Desty's trying to say. It's very
funny to me. Okay, cuz she's just always thinking about networking
with bigger creators. It's very funny. >> Example you could
ever give contra point because contra points would agree with
every single thing I'm saying a billion times over. Contra points
entire online existence has been holy leftists are terrible ex
excise them from your >> Is your line just agreeing that
leftists are evil because that that's fine. I agree with that.
Okay, I have no problem with that line. >> Necess
people that are going to ardently support your candidate in general
should never be included. >> Okay, but contra
>> hold on.
I would love to see, by the way, and I I hope Contra Points isn't
the person who's like this. I don't think she is, but I would
hope that now with Lebanon, Contra Points would basically go,
"Yeah, now I'm like totally I'm sorry. I like cuz there was some
subtlety the issue for a long time, at least based on what information
you had and could confirm. But now that Gaza has been flattened,
now that um now that Lebanon's been invaded, I I feel like now
that Iran's been attacked, okay, now that Iran is the the victim
of this war victim, I I maybe that's the wrong word to use. Now
that Iran has been like devastated economically, militarily,
um humanitarian
in a humanitarian sense in every sense. Okay. Right. I do wonder
where counterpoints. Sorry, Connor.
I just read the word Connor. Contra
would be on this. I do think she'd actually go back and rethink
and and reassess at this point. Okay. I do think she would. No,
I'm not going to start over. I'm not going to start over. I just
I'm saying I think Contra Points would probably be like pretty
anti-inist. I think she was antiist in the first place, right?
I think there's a lot more impetus for it to be anti-ionist
like for you to be anti-inist at this point now. There's way
more. She's dug in her heels so much. She's not remotely anti-inist.
Now she's kind of I I don't I remember thinking that like I understood
where she was coming from. I understood how she got to the position
she was in. I just disagreed with it. So, we'll see. We'll see.
We'll see. We'll see. I think
I think she'd shown some like empathy for the Palestinian people
that is not really there for liberal Zionists in the way you
guys describe it. So, >> points is an example of somebody
who is a type you ask for a type of socialist content creator
who would throw in behind the general. I'm saying Contra Points
is that type of person. So, will we work with Contra Points?
My answer is
>> Of course, because she passes my simple test of will
they support their candidate in general? >> Okay. FD signifier.
He threw in hard behind Kamla. Do we work with FD signifiers
to fight the fact that he's actually I think an ML if not further.
I think he might be further than an ML. I'm not >> I would
have to see if he actually threw in hardcore behind.
>> Surely we're gonna say I just I'm It's unfortunate for
Aaron because she just ends up being like the the testing
Did Aaron go? Did she, you know, try to work towards Biden getting
elected? Did she try to work towards damn candidates being elected
in 2024 when she literally worked at with you guys at progressive
Would you cuz you guys talk a lot of
it turns out your test she's like firmly on the good side of
it and you guys talk all of this about her and how she's like
a threat to democracy. So, it's just weird how we double we play
both sides of that line every single time. >> Uh, sure.
>> I don't even know what that is. uh a large content creator
on the left, Brett Tuber.
>> And I agree that there are very few contra points, right?
FD signifier might not count, but what I am saying is that it's
really important that our tent
>> Yes, Kilo. Yes, I've I've brought this up before multiple
times,
that they all worked with Aaron on Progressive Victory. They
all worked with her the whole time. That's why they've created
this new cutout that makes all of their previous content look
deranged about Aaron, right? Oh, well, if they support Dems,
then that that's fine. That's the line.
Uh, that's a newly made line and not the one you were arguing
with. You're trying to shoot on Pisco or trying to on Aaron in
general for both of these people.
That's a new line that you just made up because you understood
that you had a total contradiction that you had to resolve. So,
this is your way of resolving it. Just makes your previous content
on this topic look >> Captures the contra points and doesn't
chase them out. It's really >> super easy to do. Yeah,
that's the contra point is an incredibly rare cupcake snowflake.
If you watch her Twitter on Twitter, it seems like most of the
time she's just getting on or hated by others. >> Sure,
but when you ask me for an example of this type of creator, it
took me a bit, but that would be one example of this type of
person
that left
you brought up earlier like, okay, someone who thinks that Kamla's
position on Israel is abhorrent is in congruent with someone
who says we need to vote for Kamla over everything and throw
all of our support. Is >> that what I said? >> Don't
say it. Don't say it. Don't say it. When you fail, I understand
what I'm saying over and over again. >> Okay. Well, I failed.
Please tell me. I'm sorry.
I do hope Zoe Bill goes back. I've been told that Zoe does some
analysis right after this. I That's not what I said at all. That's
not what I said at all. Wait, I need to hear the precise quote
again cuz we'll see if this is for an example of this type of
creator. >> Let me listen again. Example of this type of
person
that left
you brought up earlier like okay, someone who thinks that Kamla's
position on Israel is abhorentt is in congruent with someone
who says we need to vote for Kamla over everything and throw
all of our support. >> Is that what I said? That's precisely
what he said. Okay. So, someone who thinks that Camala's position
on Israel is ahor
ahor and genocide and she
supports genocide/apar
tid. So, that's going to be the part where Jesse says that's
not what I said. It's that they constantly harp on it being a
genocide and apartheid. Right. But that is what her position
is on Israel is she supports a genocide and apartheid. That is
an accurate description. So, that that's what Desty's going to
fight on. I'm almost positive, right? Um, the is incoherent
coherence with supporting Kamla or something. I list the rest.
>> When when you fail to understand what I'm saying over
and over and over again >> to vote for Kamla over everything
and throw all of our support
>> I know it's the SSRI side. I know it. I know when when
you fail to understand what I'm saying over and over and over
>> Okay. Well, I failed. Please tell me. I'm sorry. If
you're constantly like if you're screaming that a person is pro
genocide, pro a partite over and over and over again, you you've
removed that person from the convers undefeated
undefeated undefeated undefeated. No, it's about the scale. It's
about how often they do it.
Like I I'm sorry.
The download is complete. I don't even need to I don't even need
to try.
It's so easy to say exactly what these people are going to do
every single time. It's actually boring conversation of being
able to actually support this person in a general election. There's
just most people just won't be on board with that. It's just
not possible. That's you have to recognize that there's some
your audience is never going to be able to
uh unfortunately
what Destiny fails to realize here is that's just been the status
quo in America for a long time. So regardless of whether or not
that like regardless of whether or not you see it accurately,
that's been the status quo. Most people are fine with it inherently.
That that's true. >> Turn their nose and be like, "Oh,
fine. I guess I'll for the progeni."
Yes.
No, I'm I'm aware that that kind of rhetoric can absolutely turn
a good chunk of your audience away. My question is how you think
this is completely in congruent from that person saying, "Hey,
like if you think your entire audience is willing to accept everything
you're saying about them, as nasty as you're being, but then
completely ignoring you and you say, "Look, I think this is important.
However, obviously this is the materially right, correct, moral
thing to do, and you all need to go do it and they're sucking
comla during the general." Like, how are these things opposed?
Like, these are things that I know the majority report did. I
don't I And by the way, Soy Pill asked like, "Why are you act
these things are not in congruent?" And Destiny categorically
responded, "They are absolutely inongruent." So if he tries to
get out of this argument, I don't know how he would do it because
Soy Pill is now basically trying to resolve this thing Destiny
said before, okay? I have no idea how he's going to get out of
it because he said something stupid again. >> Obviously
Assan and I don't know, Vage, like those people won't. Absolutely
not. They've already signal that they won't. They definitely
didn't last time. But like there's people like me who can say,
"Yeah, I think this is abhorentt. I didn't sh on Kamla nearly
so much as some of these other people did. I didn't even have
a platform at the time." But the idea that this is like, "Oh,
and and therefore like going out and throwing a material weight
and telling your whole audience and mobilizing them to go door
knock and canvas, like that's not enough. Like I I don't want
those people to be exised from the movement. They're clearly
going to fullthroat support the people that I need to get elected
when it comes to shove." >> Yeah. The line definitely can't
be fullthroatedly anti-leftist because I think a lot of like
performative >> dude how
did these are these people like update they're updating their
message right is what they're doing. They've realized they look
totally insane with all of the rhetoric they've been doing and
so they are just updating in real time. Well, it can't just be
like [__] every leftist. Dude,
a week ago, sorry, two, three weeks ago, you were all defending
Hutch saying he needs we need to cut every lefty out of this
coalition. these these socialist types. Get them all out. Get
them all the out of here, right?
You're all defending it. And now now you've realized you're you've
watched everybody laugh at you and you're going, "Oh, well, maybe
it can't be every leftist. Maybe
okay, it's it's the private property thing." No, it isn't. >> Leftists
that are soft leftists would be turned away from something like
that that we could otherwise like absolutely work with. Tilly
is another I know that is not American. Yeah. Yeah. So, like
that's why I'm saying like what are the rules of thumb? This
is why I typically say like I don't know the policy that I feel
like you can kind of somewhat test people on is do you want to
get rid of private property? If you have another one that you
would like to use instead as a rule of thumb, that's fine. But
I don't think it can be you. Who the is Tilly? Um, somebody is
trying to set Destiny up to Actually, that's really that's actually
really rude to Tilly. Tilly is a content creator in her own right.
Totally disconnected from this. That's actually that's who she
is to Arrodite. Okay. Sorry. That's who she is to Ardite. That's
not who she is. That's very rude of me to say that about her.
She is a content creator who does debates. She's done some Oxford
style debates. She debated Charlie Kirk. People thought she did
quite well. She's the person who said Andrew Wilson is a and
then she made the video about it a couple days ago. Okay. So,
I I apologize. That was that was crass of me. So, she is a content
creator of her own right. But to aerodite, she's the person she's
trying to get into the destiny sphere of politics.
Okay. >> Are vocally aggressively anti-leftist. I don't
think that that's the line necessarily, right? Because then we're
excluding Tilly's. We're excluding potentially slay the GOPs.
Instagram has a lot more of these types of content creators that
are going to be leftist coded because they're not that deep in
their political philosophy and they're born in LA, but they're
actually liberals that just don't really know it yet, essentially.
And if you say, "I'm anti-left," you're going to lose them because
they're going to be afraid of losing their audience.
>> Just Just real quick, just real quick. Um Dev, you sent
me this. Uh
Am I Am I reading this wrong? Uh here, I'll show it on screen.
>> Actually, hold on. I feel like I feel like we're going
to pull this up. And this this is my Israel derangement. Okay.
I feel like they're going to pull this up. They're going to go,
"Actually, young people everywhere really love Israel and they
think Palestinians are basically not worthy of human consideration."
Dev, are you sending me this correct? Is this a study that says
like young people everywhere love Israel and they think Palestinians
are like subhuman, so it's not really a genocide anyway? Is that
is that true? Young people 15 to 22, they all think this. Oh
my god. Wow. It's It's been all a lie. >> Give me a second.
And you sent me to something too, soy bill. If you want me to
still show that, we can. But here's FD signifier
>> and he's basically saying he didn't campaign for Kamala.
>> Yeah. This this is an exchange from a month ago where
he he's getting blasted by a far.
>> It's from a year ago. It's not from a month ago. It's
from a >> lefty for supporting the Dems. And he's like,
"No, I didn't do that." Actually,
>> you point me to the video where I campaigned for Kla
Harris and >> that guy low key throw slides. >> Yeah,
he uh he's one of he's also one of >> Hold on.
I mean, we understand. I don't know what FD signifier did. Okay.
But are you asking them to go out and campaign for these people
or are you asking them to say obviously this is the harm reduction
candidate, right? Obviously this is the harm reduction candidate.
You should vote for Kamala Harris. It will be way better than
Republicans. That is way different than going out and and like
campaigning for somebody, right? >> People who promoted
bad and banana bad. >> I can't wait to see this. The weird
Drake obsession sounds like a you thing and being mad about switching
thumbnails is so petty. It makes me mad that I responded to this
uh crying face and not FD signifier. That's fine, right? But
then we've got tillies, we've got contra points, right? I especially
suspect on Instagram you're going to find a lot more of these
kind of like even like people like Nimas, for example, do if
we say we're anti-left, Nima would never join. But when you talk
to Nima, she's pretty much a lib. Like she's definitely not a
communist. >> I think this is these types of these types
of obsessive conversations I think are the reason why even as
Republicans plummet, Democrats are like always just like when
it comes to popularity or >> who started this conversation,
who's been running with this since the election happened, who's
been entirely on this page the entire time.
Dude, what >> approval? Because on the Democratic side,
we're just constantly asking these questions of like, can we
please bend and cow out as much as possible to these people who
hate us and trash us constantly and [__] on all of
our candidates and call us pro genocide, like all these horrible
things over and over again. What can we do to appeal to these
people? That's like what the Democratic Party is just always
betting itself backwards over to do. And I think there's a reason
why >> they constantly eat our own. Yes. It's because we
constantly no.
No, they do. The people on the far left do and you WANT TO KEEP
INCLUDING THEM. THEY'RE THE ONES eating our own constantly. Yes.
>> You're inviting him. >> Oh god. We've reached
We've reached the absolute worst case scenario.
Arerodite just infinitely more intelligent and informed than
Destiny. It's actually over. Arrodite is like, "Oh, I try to
go on these other platforms and I look for where like the new
people are." It turns out every new person is like some form
of left and we do need to actually communicate to these people.
We can't just cut them all off or we'll never have audiences
again. Don't you want to make money, Destiny? I need to make
money. Right? That's what Erid is saying. I can't cut these people
off. I want to make money. If I say that I want to cut out all
leftists, which she said constantly, by the way, these people,
we need to cut them out. She's the one who came out with that,
okay? Right. After the election, these people need to be cut
out. They need to be
But now she's realizing, oh, all the new viewers, all the young
viewers, oh, they won't watch me if I'm not left. Oh, well, um,
guys, we can't say that anymore. We got to we got to switch it
up. We got to change a little bit. Hannibal Lecter to the dinner
table and wondering why everyone's in need. >> I agree.
I agree. I have been swatted and docked and attacked by these
far leftists just as much more than almost anyone. But >> so
now that
I She blamed me for it, by the way. I She blamed me for it first.
She blamed me and Queen for it. Her getting swatted and doxed.
She openly did so on Twitter, right? And now it's all the far-lefts
who have been doxing and swatting her. She's just lying again.
and doxed and attacked by these far leftist as probably more
than almost anyone but Destiny probably more than literally everyone
but Destiny on this panel. So you're preaching to the choir when
you're talking about like the problem with these type of people.
The thing that I am pointing out is what is tactically effective
here. That's all I'm talking about. And I don't think just spit
driven lines is EFFECTIVE FOR OH NO. OH NO. IS THIS better or
worse than Stardust employer coming on and basically saying she
was lying about everything? I can't tell. I can't tell. It feels
like it's pretty good. I don't know if it's quite that good.
It's pretty good, though. Hey, we shouldn't just be spite based,
guys. Bosch was right about you, D.
>> It's It's good stuff. It's not
I'm I'm saying it's not spite driven. It's that you need to have
strong like liberal things that like liberal people that people
are advocating for that once you create you don't you DON'T AGREE.
YOU DON'T AGREE. >> YES, OF COURSE I AGREE. WHAT? all of
my career supporting you and supporting liberal content. >> That's
not what we're talking about. It's not just about you. I don't
know that has nothing to do with anything. >> Here's the
thing. Well, the most relevant thing of this conversation right
now. What I'm saying is that if I
dude, Kyle has done more for this guy than like anybody. Okay?
More than anybody. She's literally violated every moral principle
she's ever held for this guy. And the second she disagrees with
him, she is trash to him. And it's so
it's so fun to watch. It's just very fun to watch every time.
>> If I want a leftist candidate, I can find and I can
find leftist influencers that are big bad awesome leftists. They're
all the Democrats are all the Republicans and it feels good.
You say all these people are on Instagram and Tik Tok. Of course
they are cuz they're allowed to be there and they're allowed
to talk about how horrible the genocide is and everything else.
But as liberals, you can't create those people to those spaces.
You constantly have to run to those people and become a selfperpetuating
problem. We're having just real quick. I am trying out Hold on.
No, no, no. I'm making sure my position is clear so that it doesn't
get like turned into something else. I am trying to parse out
what will work most effectively. That is all I am trying to figure
out here. I'm not actually strictly advocating for any direction
right now. I'm actually poking holes and questions into positions
that are stronger so that I can decide for myself because I think
for example, one of the big issues that you're pointing to with
the leftist is that they're eating our own. They're eating the
liberals. They are constantly attacking it. And I think one of
the big issues that liberals have is we don't support each other
very much. I suspect right now that your audience right now is
all over Neil's and all over me super nasty despite the fact
that we are literally aligned right and so >> who Neil's
is that oh is that this guy or is that
soy pill's name I don't even know >> this type of behavior
I think is a leftist problem and is a liberal problem and is
always going to create issues over liberal things it's over supporting
the cannibalistic leftist >> build things up I don't like
you asking you're asking the right question and I don't disagree
with your question Arerodite is what is most tactically efficient
what should we be doing in order to win the argument that I am
making and and I think Destiny is making is that by inviting
these leftists in even you may gain a few of their followers
even some of the like some of them might work with you and you
might be able to have some of them vote for you things will happen
because you do that that are going to hurt more than
Let me finish. Let me finish. Let me finish. Okay. They are going
to drive away other voters. That's uh more moderate voters, more
centerleaning voters. Uh I will say I did get sent these logs
which are a little bit funny. Okay. A little bit funny. Little
bit funny here. Do you remember this person? This person was
very very very pro Destiny with all the stuff. Uh all of the
stuff after January, right? Uh Destiny nails nails nails. Destiny,
you're completely wrong. Omega lol soy pill W destiny you were
wrong Destiny he's correct IP van IP van get out get out are
going to see you appealing to these or working these people and
they're going to they're not going to want to work with you anymore
because they know how they operate there's going to be a lot
of these people in their audiences that are going to come in
that don't have the same um morals as their uh streamer
uh person that they're following that are absolutely going
like the evil Hannibal Lectar leftists that we're talking about
and just
um destroy any kind of sense of of of unity within whatever organization
you're trying to make. I do. >> The harsh is just real
quick just real quick and then we'll let we'll let >> It's
very funny that Crowd's whole thing is these people are only
fueled by petty spite spitefueled grievance and he doesn't realize
how well it applies to the people making the arguments here.
Okay, it's just very funny that that's also like progressive
victories broad problem with Destiny is they want all these people
to work together. That's what they're trying to do and Destiny's
like the antithesis of that. He's been arguing against that for
months now, right? There's really nothing there's nothing about
Hassan here that was like co-opted. It was, "Hey, we want to
work with all of these people. We want all of these people to
work together. >> We work with Tilly's. Do we work with
>> No. Uh, >> go ahead. >> Not this, but she's
British. That's a British person.
>> Dude, I Dude, I Is Soy Pill brave enough to just call
it out? Uh, of course we work with attractive women. Of course
we work. Why wouldn't we work with attractive women no matter
their politics? Guys, could you That's what we do. Obviously,
we will work with any attractive woman who is willing to not
say that who who is unaware of the things I've done. Any of them.
Any of them ever. >> I know. Use the example because I've
given Contra points. I've given Tilly's. >> You're talking
to a Canadian. Just the little bits of shade. The little shade.
Yeah, you're literally talking to a Canadian right now about
this. I don't know where slay the GOP is exactly on Newsome,
so I'd have to vet that one out. Na might be an example. Do we
work with these people who will identify as leftists and won't
want to work with us if our position is doggedly
>> I actually I I actually talk with a lot of leftists.
Um I associate with some of them. >> It's actually
so funny how cooked these people are and they can't see it. Like
I
sometimes your faith is shaken just a little bit. Okay, but they're
actually just totally cooked. Not Soy Pill. Soy Pill is waking
up. Soy Pill's waking up. He's coming online. But the rest of
these people, it's just like transparently about views and clicks
and siphoning off as much of Destiny's audience as you can before
he eventually crashes out and somebody or Yeah, basically like
I think that's basically all it is. It's very interesting. One
thing that they all have in common, those at least that I associate
with is they all got chewed out and purity tested by Hassan P
and co. So I think a great place to tactically start if you're
going to build bridges into the
>> great place to start. Assan is mad. Assan is bad >> left
or into leftist corners or whatever the you want to call him.
Good place to start is to go for those to engage with those who
got purity tested and chewed out by that monstrous >> Oh,
by the way, on the on the counterpoints thing, why is Israel
so bad at propaganda? Are they stupid? Or is being universally
despised part of some larger plan?
I think I don't know if this is her being like pro Israel and
not wanting to be look like a fool or if it's literally her saying
like, "Yeah, they are they look monstrous right now." It's hard
to say. It's hard to say.
Well, I think Contra Points hates Hassan, but I don't think Contra
Points would try to do some like moral framework thing. Oh, it's
like morally good to hate Hassan. I don't I maybe she would.
Maybe I I feel like from watching the videos, it seems like solid
foundation that she operates from most of the time. Most of the
time. Okay. I don't think she go I'm morally correct for hating
Hassan. I think she would say, "I just hate Assad. This guy's
a piece of [__] to me." And I I think she doesn't
think they're effective, but building up over there. >> The
way to tell a lot of them was right. >> the way to tell
is do they support the >> That's the MAGA tactic. That
is the MAGA tactic that has worked so perfect perfectly since
2015. It's you like that's what people like um like
what they did they always go after people who were chewed out
by their own. So yeah, we go after the people who we built the
bridges to the people who got chewed out by people like Assad.
>> I agree. But the issue is a lot of those people a lot
of those people now have unfortunately like landed on the right
in such a way that I think a lot of >> Yeah. Because we
didn't catch them. >> I agree with you. I totally agree
with you. Right. I totally >> doesn't mean that. Yeah.
It like saying, "Oh, yes, but this example and this example therefore
let's not do this anymore." That's not exactly
something that works. >> Yeah. So what I would point out
here and all I would say here is that if the line of thumb of
who you do and don't work for is the voc vocality of being anti-leftist,
I think it's not sophisticated. I'm just trying to parse out
what's tactically effective because I think you lose people like
Nimas, like enemy Charlie, who is a leftist. >> How do
we do Do you want to know why you lose them? It's because if
you're clearly anti-leftist, there is a thing you're doing
that is
again again it all comes down to one thing and that's the thing
you're explicitly like controlling for. If people are anti-left,
it's over what issue?
Oh, Israel
is that is I watched Sneo suck Assan's the other day. Okay. Over
the Israel stuff. Some people in the right wing are very fine
with Assan. The people in the rightwing who are attacking left
are often doing so based on one issue. Okay. Well, sorry, a lot
of issues, but it's it's one big thing, right? It's so it dude,
it's so funny.
It all comes down to the same thing over >> Why do we keep
repeating this point? I'm saying that you just don't support
people that don't like valiantly support the candidates in the
general. That's >> Oh, ENEMY CHARLIE'S ON THIS SIDE. WELL,
Wick's about to flip teams.
WAIT, AN ATTRACTIVE WOMAN IS on that side. Oh my god. As for
Daniel, comrades,
don't we love the USSR? Hello everybody.
>> Most people might not. I suspect then you don't have
them on your team. Then they're cancer. They don't work with
them as cancer. I don't critical of Gavin. Well, the issue is
which candidate do they have to support right now? Ardent ardently.
What if they say of course what if they say something like I
of course will support Gavin Newsome? Say we he wins. Okay, it's
Gavin Newsome for president. All right, that would be my dream.
Okay. If they say I'll of course get vote for Gavin Newsome over
JD Vance, but they go but I would have had different preferences
in the primaries. Is that okay or are they out too? >> What
do you think?
>> I would include them. >> No. What do you think
my answer said? >> Of course you would include them. >> Wait,
that's such a ridiculous question. If their position was
>> Wait, that is Hassan's updated position. By the way,
just he just included Hassan. That is Hassan's updated position.
Hassan did actually go after the fact and say, "By the way, what
do you think that implies about his audience that Hassan felt
it was necessary to go back and update his position?
Do you think he was maybe getting pushed by his audience to not
stand on business there?" Like I it's like such a blind spot
for all of these people. I would have supported somebody different,
but I'll support them in the general. Obviously, this is a person
to be included. This is not 99% of the people that we're talking
about, though.
Okay, but what if you have people right now that are that are
further like this that do become like this? Like what if instead
of uh Gavin Newsome winning, Pete Buddha Judge wins and so suddenly
Sam Cedar is willing to throw in behind uh Pete Buddha Judge.
I'm not >> sure Sam would also throw behind Gavin. I'm
pretty sure. >> Sure. Regardless, do we work with them?
>> Uh the only question there would be whether or not Sam
would throw behind Pete Buddha Judge. I dude I I'm sorry. Leftists
have a unique derangement for Pete Jud Buddha Judge. You shouldn't
judge anything else on that. Okay. Pete Pete Buddha Judge is
like the primary. Maybe Slotkin's a little worse now that she's
a literal CIA agent, but I'm pretty sure every leftist is like
Pete Buddha Judge is a CIA agent. He is like evil. He is evil
incarnate.
Okay. Maybe Slackin's worse now for them. I'm not totally sure,
but a lot of leftists really hate Pete Buddha Judge >> now
or do we not? Because they've been so costic because they have
>> No, we can wait with them in the general. If they want
to support us in the general, we work with them in the general,
but are we're fundamentally misaligned in the in the primary,
so support other content creators. Support >> well, Hold
on, let me ask you. >> What if they're willing to vote
for Gavin Newsome, but also vehemently critical of his connections
to Apac? So they say, "I would vote for him cuz he's better than
[__] JD Vance, >> but he's still a genocidal
maniac. >> More tongue and cheek, but he's still a genociding
A-packer. But of course, I'm going to win vote for him over a
>> A genociding a packer.
Whoa. >> What if that's their position? Do we work with
those? We can find I think we can do better. I think we can do
better than that. >> Yeah. There there are other lines
like even if they're willing to give lip service to our
I do I do I pull a tweet just to drive home a point? Do I pull
home a tweet or sorry do I pull up a tweet because it really
drives home a point just that none of them wanted to cut that
enemy Charlie person out of the conversation because they like
her because it's all petty spiteful
personal grievance. Okay. Now, I have to pull it. I have to pull
it. I'm sorry. I'm sorry to this Charlie person if you get dragged
into something. Okay, but this is everything they've said is
wrong with Hassan right here. She's retweeting. I want the US
to lose this war. For the sake of liberation and deolonization,
it must for the sake of humanity. We must lose. The best outcome
for the US results in ecoside and multiple genocides. This is
every single thing. Dude, Hassan might Hassan would probably
blush before tweeting that. And they would all support this enemy
Charlie person 100%.
Right. They would be totally behind her. Why? I mean, one, it's
it's spiteful grievance. Two, I I will go no further. Okay, I
will go no further. I know she's like a lesbian, so I don't want
to be too weird about it. Or maybe she's But, you know, all these
candidates are corporate shills who do not have your best interest
at heart that will just sell you out. Uh, that they're the Epstein
class. They're the um, you know, So, you're done with Roana,
who coined the term. Dude, how many of these people are paid
by third way? I Why would you pick this third way group as the
group you're going to like shill for? I
like you're literally just doing their work. Why? Why? What is
it based? What What is
I I don't get it. I really don't get it. They're their Apac shills,
all these things. No. No. We don't want you. We don't want to
work with you. We We want people who support us, not you. So
that's where we probably disagree. It seems to me less tactically
sound because if they're willing to like work together but still
be super critical of Gavin Newsome, I'm broadly still going to
just be willing to work with them. Right. The people that I'm
not going to >> it's not just being critical, it's how
they're critical.
>> I don't know why we're playing. The word games here
are really funny tonight. I don't know if this is intentional
or not. Like I don't understand you and >> the word games
here, bro. Aeronite's like 95% on their side. Do you want to?
Dude, it's like a perfect microcosm. They say it's cultlike behavior
to require somebody to be 100% on your side. Arodite is objectively
95 to 99% on their side. And they are trying to break her.
How do you not blush doing this? How do you not feel self-conscious
doing this?
That you like have to take this person down now. I bet she's
going to apologize. Well, well, well. Sorry. if they're if they're
going to be critical. Who the is talking about being critical?
We're talking about calling somebody a genocidal supporting Zionist
freak. That's not being critical. It's being >> Wait, are
there a lot of
Is this directly personal now? He just hates that people call
him this,
dude. That
Destiny is starting to come he's coming to the he's sobering
up. Okay. He's coming to the realization that that cookie debate
is going to haunt him forever unless he can like fix this and
put all of his political might behind making sure that it's not
a problem, right? That the debate where he goes out and sells
out to talk about the Cookie Rockets, that's going to haunt him
for the rest of his career unless he can change something up.
Okay? He's got to he's got to make it right. There's like this
is like a but not in act not in the sense of actually making
it morally right. He's got to make it right by making it seem
like he was right. different kind of like there's not a single
person in here and if there is then then whoever is saying this
I don't I don't think anybody here saying this who's saying we
can't accept people who are critical in the primaries of our
candidates I don't think a single person in here is saying that
or has ever said that or will ever have that position
>> so did he say that we we keep the enemy Charlie's did
he say we keep the tillies and enemy Charlie's by the way he
doesn't have a problem with the rhetoric right he doesn't he
doesn't know
he he would have to go after this person just as hard right just
as hard he'd have to go after this person maybe harder than Hassan.
I don't know if Hassan's come out and said, "I need the US to
lose this war for the sake of decolonization."
That's like some extremely far-left like hardcore leftist. No,
I need the US to lose this war because otherwise horrible things
will happen. That cookie argument solidified his orientation
in the axis of Epstein.
>> Sure. When I say critical, I mean the level of nuance
and sophistication that I expect from the majority of these like
I'm a leftist because I don't know much more and I live in LA
type creators. That's about what I expect. And I do expect them
to call him >> Sam Cedar from Emma Vlin from
anymore. I'm talking about people like
these creators that they're gonna be
>> all of these people have said negative things about
Destiny. That is all this is that's all this is in relation to.
They've all said negative things about Destiny. As soon as it's
somebody who hasn't explicitly spoken out negatively about him,
they're fine. No, they can be in the coalition is unaware of
their talking points. He doesn't care to know their talking points,
they're fine because they haven't talked about me for they are
leftist, but they're leftist because they're in LA to some degree.
And they >> The problem with your hypothetical though is
that it doesn't really correlate with reality. That's not what
happened in the last election.
It's not what happened. Well, we didn't have these far left people
come around and like, oh yes, Camala is the like in the thing
that you describe where they're begrudgingly supportive of that's
not what they did. >> I agree. I agree because
>> do not vote third party blah blah blah. >> I agree.
I agree. I agree with you entirely because I think that there
was literally almost no media uh community social structure for
>> Do you think it would have changed had liberals been
like, "But we really really want you, please."
>> That's not what I'm advocating for. >> Yeah. No
one's advocating for
>> I'm not I'm not saying lick the boots of people who
want to destroy America and hate Democrats and want to destroy
it. I'm not saying that obviously. >> No, I'm I'm not saying
you're saying >> Well, that would be the conclusion of
that, right? If I'm >> I don't think so. >> Please,
Hassan, will you let us on? It's like that's that's pathetic
behavior. What I want mostly for liberals to do is support other
liberals and rally around each other. The main thing that I want
to make it clear is that we are a soft landing place for people
who like call themselves leftists, who do use things like genocide
support other liberals.
>> What do you mean? What do you mean with like this is
like the third or fourth time I'm so curious is to ask what do
you mean with liberals then support liberals? What do you mean
with that? >> Um for example uh engaging with one another
positively in content trying our best not to endlessly critique
one another as we are doing right now. Um try to build a
random meme things but >> these aren't me things at all.
I don't
you're such a stupid Jeridite. Why do you even talk? Aridite,
you're such a stupid Why do you even talk? They say they want
to destroy the movement. This is not a critique of a liberal.
But I guess I'm saying what the [__] does that mean
when they want to destroy >> people who don't support the
candidate in general because they didn't get their way in the
primary. >> Sure. Okay. So, what about people who are not
very sophisticated but do do some level of political content
like enemy Charlie's and Nimas? What do we do with these leftists
who probably do call Gavin Newsome a genocider because they live
in LA and all their friends are doing that but probably
>> what why is Arerdite like infantilizing all of these
women? Why does Ardite realize that enemy Charlie I'm guessing
would be super offended by this? She's just like a really stupid
who can't look outside of her own bubble and like if she just
talked to a smart person like Destiny then maybe she'd realize
that Israel is just doing the moral thing to the most moral army
on earth, right? Like, why are you doing that? Isn't that super
offensive to all these women? Now, far be it for me to criticize
misogyny. Okay, I listen, I respect Ardite's game there, but
that makes me blush. All right, when when Aronite said this
enemy, Charlie can't even think for herself, can barely look
beyond her own bubble. But if she just had a smart man like Destiny
to guide her, she'd be she'd be right up here with the rest of
us, okay? She'd be a really smart political commentator. And
I was like, dude, I I'm a misogynist, but that's a bit much.
No. Isn't that a bit much? That's a lot. Jesus. >> He could
be pulled and probably would be willing to rally around and behind
certain modern Democrats. Do we work with them? That's what I'm
trying to >> What does that have to do with liberals supporting
liberals? >> Why? Because you don't have to. I never do
this. I never ever ever have to think about questions like this.
Like, do I bring somebody on who says they're not going to support
Trump? Do I didn't do this? They just don't work with those people
and they pick people who support
>> I think she literally just said I think she literally
just said, but they do support for them. Okay. All right. Yeah.
Get on get on the team. Right. If you want to be on the team,
you can be on the team. We'll accept you. But you got to get
you got to come to us, right? Is that what we're >> Yeah.
These people don't even have real political power in terms of
they can't get any of their candidates elected. They don't go
to win primaries anywhere outside of like the deepest, bluest,
most Democrat prepared places. I don't understand why the conversation
is capitulating to them. It should be >> Now we're about
to loop. Guys, are you ready for the loop? Now Soyill is going
to feel compelled to point out that every time you make this
point that they have no power, they have nothing. you then why
do you need me to not interact with them if I'm getting everything
I want and they'll never be elected if there's no concern about
how they'll like destroy democracy or something why is it bad
for me to take free money from them what is your what is the
why are you saying this how much
our politicians want to work with them right that that's reality
>> because that's acceptting these people into our movements
because nobody's doing anything to audit these people and because
there's this weird acceptance on the left of having to work with
tankies and [__] does never happen on the right they
don't do this on the right >> how do you pull Does Destiny
really is Destiny really arguing for auditing the influencers
and their past and how moral a person they are? Is that is that
what we're doing here? Well, I guess maybe he's arguing for auditing
He was making that argument earlier. Very bizarre. Maybe he just
means now audit them to see if they will support Gavin Newsome.
I don't know. >> Is towards the liberal side effectively.
>> I don't know. I don't care. I'd rather create more mocklers
and more loopies and more of these types of people than try to
figure out how to appease or appeal to people that don't seem
>> Adam Mockler who directly talked to Hassan who likes
Assan who gets along with be of the party. >> It's wasted
energy. Like look, I would love aid. I'll put it like this. Okay.
Um the neocons invited mega in and then they got destroyed. The
liberals shouldn't do the same with the far left. >> I
none of this. No, I'm no longer talking about the far left. I
think me I don't know where I'm not going to put words. My position
>> talking about liberals again. What >> I am talking
about this space between somebody who is actually a tanky who
knows what they're talking about and means their positions right
like a Hassan or a Vosch versus people who their politics aren't
overly sophisticated. It's mostly result of their culture. They
happen to be probably an LA socialite and so they're in this
socialist progressive camp and they probably identify as a leftist.
I'm asking what do we do with these people cuz I actually think
that they have a lot of value.
>> If it's not even strongly committed to anything then
fine. You do events with them I guess. Sure. >> Okay. That's
what I'm asking. I
>> dude, I'm sorry. It's so funny.
Uh I just love people like Tilly and Enemy Charlie who are like
ditsy bimbos who think they're socialists, who think they're
leftleaning, but they just haven't really like learned anything
about the world. And thank God they've got people like Not So
Arerodite and Destiny to teach them to guide them to towards
being like an enlightened person. I just I I I'm so they're so
precious these attractive young women who are just totally ditzy
bimbos with no real political uh understanding and we can guide
them. We can shape them.
Thank you Ardite. Thank you. >> I will disagree.
Right. I think that like well if they want to work with >> True
Sim Yes. Absolutely true. You need to groom them into the liberals
of the future. Destiny and I are looking to groom these young
attractive women into the liberals of the future.
Yes, >> view. That's fair. I don't think we should try
to appeal to them. I don't think we should try to kind of reach
out to them because I think that the people who are going to
give us more value and what I mean by that is votes to to be
clear vote. >> Oh, also we will check out the soy pills
like post retrospective or whatever after this right after. >> I
don't care about clicks on social media. I care about what only
in in so much as it translates to actual votes on election day
whether that be primary election day for my preferred primary
candidate or in the general election. Um we talk we reach out
to the people who have a history of voting right who have a history
of participation who are getable and we do that by sticking to
our liberal values. One of the problems that we have and one
of the reasons we look weak is because we're constantly trying
to appeal to the to these people who aren't going to give us
anything. >> Where where's this constant appeal I'm seeing?
If anything, it seems like the opposite is happening, which I'm
not saying is a bad thing, by the way, but like I
>> When have you guys appealed? When has anybody around
you appealed?
What What is that happening? What where is that? I'm >> not
suggesting we appeal these people. It doesn't seem like a lot
of people are. The only thing I'm seeing is that people want
to go on platforms that are big that have to be run by leftists,
but they're not appealing to those leftist like policies that
aren't >> wait. They are appealing to them because those
leftists are controlling the conversations. That's why we just
had a PD thing where 90% of the conversation was about Israel
Palestine.
>> Okay, fair enough. And that's the thing that when people
are watching it, that's a both sides issue. Like both sides are
equally bad on Israel Palestine and the way forward is. >> Yeah.
And so when Wick says, and this is >> both sides are basically
dude,
what where's the shift? Where's the shift on Israel Palestine?
Oh, Donald Trump is worse. But it's like
I think this is one of those issues where absolutely you can
stand and say I'm not voting for somebody who's not willing to
change this. I'm it's it's destroying the global economy because
nobody has taken that stand. and everybody refuses to for some
reason. I'm not going to speculate on why they won't take a stand,
but they should take a stand. Okay, I think this is one of those
few issues where I do I do not mind people saying, "Yeah, I'm
just not going to support someone who's going to send my tax
dollars to Israel." Not going to do it. Sorry. I got to agree
with when Wick says, "If you partner with these people, if you're
a politician, you're on that panel where I was on and they're
saying some unhinched and they're like posting this with like
all the clips of the song saying more unhinched, that probably
will lose you more support with voters than it would gain from
you working with a person like that." And that's why I'm like,
"Yeah, that's probably bad." versus, hey, this person said, I'm
going to canvas for the general person. I'm not saying this has
happened yet. Let's just say this is the case. I I don't see
any reason to reject that help. >> Yeah, I guess I just
the examples we're giving are things have just never ever ever
happened. So, I'm not even sure how to like evaluate these examples.
>> We just saw the PV is thrown out
>> literally and has done so the entire time they've existed.
The entire time >> help for the person in the general that
they don't support
thro tweet for the other person that we did see that tweet that
was a
event that helps get them elected.
Okay. By the way, Destiny, when that was brought up, just to
refresh you, when that was brought, he brought it up and said,
"Did they even tweet anything? Did they even do anything for
this candidate?" And now he is just categorically wrong. And
he is basically trying to mock Soy Pill for bringing up the fact
that he was categorically
Again, cult
cult. It's insane. It's It's crazy to watch.
Soy pill is just correct. And now Soy Pill bringing up the fact
that he is correct. This he goes, "Okay,
they did one tweet." Okay. Okay.
They generally care. >> PV thro tweet for the other person
that we did see that >> a tweet that was making event that
helps get them elected.
>> that's good, right? >> It's it's not it's it's
a it's a magnitude question. You would understand this in any
other circumstance, but for here we're pretending we don't. I
guess I don't know why you always accuse me like that. Like it's
like at worst I
>> You're such a soy pill. You're such a stupid tanky.
You can't you see I'm I'm just obviously intrinsically correct.
I'm obviously just intuitively correct. Why won't you just agree
with me? Why do you make >> The reason why watch no is
one of the big reasons why like Assan doxed every single person
he could in PV because of their association with me. That was
the only reason. every single person in PV.
A just reminder for this guy who is very very concerned about
people in Progressive Victory being doxed. I just want to remind
you this is not the first he's hearing of it. In fact, when when
people were reposting this stuff, not even when it was found
the first time, but when people were reposting this stuff, one
of his chatters came along and said, "Hey, maybe Destiny, could
you let like Hutch and Josiah know that their information got
posted?" And what was Destiny's response? I wonder what was Destiny's
response. It was, "Hey,
oh man." Oh, wait, wait, wait. Up at the top, Destiny. Send it
to them so they can see what they are doing. So, send it to these
people. Send it to who? Destiny. Josiah and Hutch and stuff.
Oh, me. They can figure it out themselves. Oh, me. Oh, yeah.
This guy got banned tonight for disagreeing with Destiny. Oh,
me. They can figure it out
The only time Destiny decided to go tell them about this was
when he thought he could bend Hutch like to his way of thinking.
He made zero effort to go and tell him in the first place and
explicitly said so.
Yeah, the very violent guy got banned. Well, I assume he won't
be banned very long. He's a total cultist, so it is what it is.
But he's now he's virtue signaling about the Hassan thing. When
this originally happened, Destiny did not give a about these
people and explicitly said so.
He does not care about you. When he makes these points, it is
because he hates Hassan, not because he cares about you. And
he did that. Hassan calls Dylan Burns a war taourist or jumps
on it and shits on [__] loner box who's literally
been on an island for like 12 months of content. Like Assan has
almost single-handedly tried to destroy this guy's career because
of any resemblance to being pro-Israel or being like that's what
these people do. And then the >> you don't have to explain
leftist doxing to me. my personally experienced it and working
to it. What I'm talking about with like >> again the person
who is who is helping Dan dox people, okay,
is the person who originally grabbed all the PV papers and published
their docses, publish all these people's docses and
the whole anti-han campaign. That's the guy who was who was finding
people's I'm sorry I it is the way it is. Okay, we're
it's still bad. What Hassan did is still bad. It's really bad.
It's It was at best at best
insanely reckless to watch a bad empanada video without knowing
what was there. Okay. At the very best. Leftist is just President
Sunday. Do you think that's what she's talking about? I don't
think that's what she's talking about cuz she's talking about
swatting too. Anyway, I agree. The leftist trying to destroy
us is one of the biggest issues. Liberals always have it coming
from both sides at all time. Right. At all times. And so I agree
with that. But I think one thing that liberals could do better
to be proactive rather than just being like ah the leftists are
destroying us is being more proactive at supporting each other.
This is actually think something that destiny you're uniquely
good at right you allow anyone to come on your platform you typically
try to support smaller content creators right but like I think
it's really important for example that like in liberal space
>> why has he been doing that is it is it like basically
all of the people he is ever invited on his platform he's uses
a pool of like partners you think it has anything to do with
maybe there's you know I I can think of a reason I wouldn't want
like Tilly or basically like any woman to go on that platform
is because he's openly for for years used that as a way to build
towards relationship with people,
right? So, he brings people on, but what is the motivation in
bringing people on? Be honest. What is the motivation when somebody
calls him out for sharing their non-conensually?
Something you totally supported this person, Pixie on. Okay.
What does he say about her now? She was a clout. She's a gold
digging clout.
And yet, you still appear with him. Wick still appears with him.
You guys are totally fine with this, right? It's totally okay.
It's all good.
Destiny supports small creators until they speak out against
them. And then it is, oh, I have to destroy these people. I will
dox them. I will with their lives in any way
And you sit here and pretend Hassan is the problem. I fought
with Hassan. I was like the number one guy a logging Hassan.
Never got doxed, never got with in any way that was like inappropriate
for the internet. People talked, but it wasn't a problem. And
I was the guy. He was naming me and trying to like read out my
lore on his stream. If somebody was gonna with me, I would think
getting brought up on Hassan's stream multiple times so he could
talk. You'd think that would have happened. I've seen what it's
like being against like Hassan and then I've seen what it's like
being on the bad side of DG and I can tell you one of them is
significantly worse than the >> places to have slightly
soft landing places. Like me and Soyel disagree on certain stuff
about like how to interact with things. I disagree with just
I disagree with you, but we should like broadly try to do our
best to like have criticisms for each other but also have a decently
soft landing place for one another and give a lot of grace to
one another in a way that I see progressives will do with one
another. You mean that we have a corner where we check each other
off? I I
>> This is not what you're talking about has nothing to
do with soft landing places. You're talking about inviting people
like soft landing spaces are where you have areas to derdicalize
people who have more or less disavowed like the political ideology
that they're coming from or like are on the verge of doing it.
You're talking about accepting people who see themselves as utilizing
you to energize and supercharge their political ideologies. >> Well,
you're talking about right now. >> Again, again, dude,
I I can guarantee you right now Soy Pill is seeing Hold on. What
is Soy Pill seeing? So, Bill's got like a a video going on in
his head right now. Okay.
That is like He's like, "Dude, what? What? Wait, what? >> You
like chicken and waffles?"
>> I do. >> You have a lot of this in Chicago. >> Uh,
no. We don't. I don't. >> Oh, you need to pray first. >> I
did. >> Oh, yeah. >> I'm sorry. Like, when did this
Oh, you're you're only bringing people on not You can only bring
people on when they've disavowed their ideology completely. Okay.
You can only bring them on when they've disavowed their ideology
completely and they're willing to like that's where the soft
landing space is.
Wow. Okay.
All right. I guess this has changed. I >> I understand
why you're saying that. I'm not talking about right right now
just I'm not talking about like the socialists at all. I'm excluding
them. I'm only talking about people actually who identify in
the liberal camp are in a liberal camp. And when I say a soft
landing place for liberals, I don't I'm not talking about converts.
But I understand why you're confused. I'm actually talking about
other liberals. Like for example, I typically try to go out of
my way all the time to give other liberal content creators as
many opportunities as I possibly can. And when I say a soft landing
place for liberals, I don't I'm not talking about converts, but
I understand why you're confused. I'm actually talking about
other liberals. Like, for example, I typically try to go out
of my way all the time to give other liberal content creators
as many opportunities as I possibly can to like get into other
spaces. And when progressives on Instagram started thinking I
was a progressive, I started getting a whole bunch of offers
and I very quickly to be like, oh, like, you know, like I'm not
really I got a lot of Gaza offers and stuff and I would be like,
oh, respectfully, I'm probably not the person that you're looking
for necessarily here, but >> hey, would you like to fund
raise for Gaza? Um, listen, I'm I'm not the person you're looking
for. You support Palestinian. I'm not the person you're looking
for. That's a crazy position, right? Isn't that insane? >> I
see us doing very little of this, right? We very little like
course is probably the best example that levels of part is very
nepotistic. What grow? >> That's part of who we are. That's
part of our principles. We like pure pluralism. We embrace pluralism.
We're also disconnected. We There is no such thing as a liberal
community online. There's a liberal space. >> Uh-oh. A
classical liberal has entered the fray. Not good for everybody
else here. Uh-oh. You're you're you've wandered into a destiny
liberalism conversation as a classical liberal. You're about
to get educated, my friend. >> Because we embrace difference.
We embrace doing things >> we embrace. This is why we should
be able to unify better. Like you should be going and engaging
with short fatter talk and just like promoting and retweeting
and promoting some coming on a panel together to talk about our
issues with leftists in the space and others. Maybe someone >> but
also like if you >> to all agree and vehemently attack
Soy pill on everything he says even though he's been correct
in every assertion he's made the entire panel but never admit
as much well if that's what promoting each other means then
I suppose get hit with an opportunity from um uh a candidate
that you actually think another liberal content creator would
be a better fit for or should be pulled along see if the candidate
will work with this other liberal content creator too right when
you see for example when I see any liberal content creators content
I try to like like and retweet and like create a little bit more
engagement for their content so that we can like win this the
culture war, right? So like maybe this is an inherent nature
to like what liberals tend to be like, but at the same time we
should try to counterman it so that people want to stay in the
space and we're supporting one another and we like build something
because we're getting it from side only in this place. I think
people do want to stay in this space but the thing is also how
do I put it? >> It's not other liberals that are driving
them out. >> I'll say that. >> Do you mean and people
staying in this space? Do you mean the audience or do you mean
other creators? >> Other creators I think if I'm creators
I think so >> if I'm understanding your question. >> Yeah.
Like I said, I don't think to piggy back off crowd, maybe crowd
has a different answer. It's not liberals who are primarily driving
others out of these space. Again, the reasons why it's sometimes
hard to get people if I have a show with Destiny, I have to make
sure everyone knows that Destiny's going to be there because
there are certain people who won't go on because they know that
if they go on with Destiny that it's it's going to it's they're
going to catch hell. >> That's that's the thing that I've
had experience for like the last eight years of my life. Basically,
every creator I publicly associated with instantly gets barged
with this guy used to be an anti-Sw.
You should not. Yeah, you should not. Like it's like that's true.
None of the opportunity
we're not even purity testing ourselves. It's outsiders who come
in who do not hold themselves to our principles and then try
to blackmail us on the basis of our principles. >> I agree
and I think it's why in some ways we need to be a little bit
more gentle with each other because we should recognize that
we're like getting it so much from like one another. Like I just
dominantly shut
>> you're never going to convin somebody who thinks that
this is one of the guys who thinks that sunlight is the best
disinfectant that like tolerate that always having the conversation
is good. You're not going to win this guy over. That's the classical
liberal like credo. You're you're never winning him over on this.
I don't know why she keeps trying. >> Yes. Like for example,
what I >> The problem is that we barely engage with each
other. And I think that is a good thing that
doesn't mean community. Yeah. This is the problem. This is maybe
the problem, right? Pluralism should not imply anti- community,
but what we kind of have for liberals right now is a bit of an
anti- community. There isn't like this. >> Do you think
that has like anything to do with the fact that basically Soy
pill I know he's going to get a ton of harassment for this. I'm
already seeing it happening. Right. Do you think that has anything
to do with the fact that if you hold a position different to
Destiny's in his community, his community will attack you like
vehemently and he will at best say, "Oh, no, don't do that."
But most of the time, he'll go, "Yeah, this person." He did with
Pisco and all of you sat back and watched. All of you were totally
down for it. All of you helped. I >> I don't disagree with
her long term. Again, if this is what I trying to get into as
wick and it's like there are certain cases where you can show
me, it's like associating with these people is absolutely more
harmful than not. And I would 100% agree. I just don't know if
that's always the case and I don't know to what extent I should
use their help if they are materially helping. It's something
that I agree with. >> So just to respond to that real quick
like I don't have a like I can I'll just grant you that in certain
cases it might turn out well. It might turn out positively. I
don't have a crystal ball. I can't perfectly predict the future.
They like took on our labels right like the label progressive
right? If you'd asked me five maybe 10 years ago like hey wick
are you a progressive? I would have been more likely to say yes.
But since people like Hassan have uh absconded that label and
have worn that label even though they are not progressive they
are something else entirely but they are seen as progressive.
They say they're progressive. They act like like they they act
like they are the progressive movement. I think that word has
become like a cancer, right? Does that make >> Yeah. But
in many ways, we also adopted a lot of their language. Like I
think a lot of Democrats for example got extremely woke in their
language and got extremely concerned much more like intersectional
stuff that wasn't really part of the liberal brand cuz it like
felt good and they could like wear capes and be like I'm actually,
you know, for the people too guys. Look at me. I'm I'm I'm a
revolutionary. And I think that that was really damaging. Like
for example, there's this question of essentially like if we
if you view this as like armies, is there an army that we can
work alongside while fully recognizing the entire time that we
will be diametrically opposed on a certain number of areas despite
the fact that we might be unified by a common enemy? Like right
now bring it up because it's brand dead, not analogous, but that's
literally what we did in World War II. It's like, yeah, as soon
as this war's over, we're going to fight to the death of these
people. But if we don't, then we're going to lose. But this is
not analogous to today because >> why why would you use
this sort of why would you view politics of war? The purpose
of politics is not to be war, >> right? Um, I think it's
analogous to a line like incentive structures. Like how do you
mobilize people with aligned incentive structures while acknowledging?
I think the issue that we had with like the left from 2016 to
2022 is that Standard Lives and Democrats pretended that they
were much more like the MLS. They took on a lot of the language
and had some others robbed, right? But they in many ways didn't
excise and go actually we're not quite like these people. Like
you you guys can with us if you're for like helping us like further
antitrust policies, but we're not going to with you if you're
like trying to just like fixate on like um let's say extreme
like um non-binary gender absolutionism or any of this stuff.
Like we're not really vibing with that. And I think that we sold
out in that way. The question is, can you at some times work
with socialists who you understand with and not lose all of your
values and principles in the first? >> Yeah. But but the
the problem with that, as I was saying, like you're exactly correct.
Um, one of the problems that liberals and just the left in general
has had is we feel in response to defend crazy people takes because
they're on our side, right? We will see someone uh getting called
out by libs of Tik Tok or something. And >> that has nothing
to do with any of the stuff you're talking about. You could easily
just say, "No, that's really stupid, but they agree with me on
this, so I'm going to work with them on this
>> You can do that. They'll say, "Look at this liberal
doing X, Y, and Z. Aren't they crazy?" And because people see,
"Well, hey, that guy's on my team. I have to defend him." >> Should
define MLS. MLS typ aren't typically woke at all. >> Yeah.
I think that's it's by far like a more conservative ideology,
right, socially. And it's just very funny that they they lump
all these things together. They take advantage of the lack of
clarity, the lack of rigor, right? They just lump everybody into
this like amorphous blob so that they can do Han's bad or anyone
else is bad that they could get into that blob. Okay, that's
that's the whole goal. So, the lack of rigor, the lack of clarity
is the goal is is sorry, maybe not the goal. It is a part of
what they're pursuing. A lack of rigor.
>> They'll do this weird thing where they defend things
that they should just not. And it's a in that way it gets mixed
into kind of like what a liberal is in a way that hurts us. Does
that make sense? In the way that moderates are like, I don't
[__] with that giant. Most liberals aren't like this,
right? Like, yeah. I So, again, so this is to the point of is
there a way that liberals can stand on their own? And as we're
like building this up, there are certain people that were socialist
coded that we might need to work with that fundamentally will
actually align with us. That that's that's like the tactical
question exclusively. >> Right. Are they sabotagers? Some
of them will inevitably be, but some of them might just be like
>> I said I I do stand by my nine out of 10 rule, right?
Like I think that yes, you're right in certain cases, but nine
out of 10 times it's it's just going to be worse for us and it's
going to hurt us. So we shouldn't $5 from >> I don't know
if that's true though, right? Like um Lauren somebody in your
speaking of super chats to give the super chats some money. Now
somebody brought up Lauren P. So Lauren P has worked a little
bit with which is not part of she's leftist coded, right? And
she says that she's a leftist, but she's a definitely a type
of person that I wouldn't be surprised if liberals were just
a little bit more socially cool and a little bit like bigger
in like the rhetoric game that she would just basically be a
liberal, right? I think that she broadly going to is going to
appeal to what she views as what the left dominantly holds. Um
these are the type of >> just another really stupid woman
who doesn't understand. She just doesn't get it, man. She's like
kind of just, you know, it's a trend. Politics is like a like
a social trend for her. She doesn't get it, but she's awesome
and I should totally appeal to her and try to get her in my coalition.
What are you saying? What is What is positive if she has such
a shallow engagement that you don't think any of her beliefs
are sincere?
What is cool about her?
I would
I would love to see what what Erid thinks is cool about her >> that
we chase away. >> I don't I don't know how to like what
liberally socially cool means. Are we just not cool enough? I
guess I don't >> Liberals. No, no, I wouldn't say it was
very cool. No,
>> Look, I'm not the expert on what cool is or not, right?
But I'm just talking like I I guess I just fundamentally don't
understand that mindset of someone who just wants to be cool
and will go along with that crowd. I understand it exists. It's
just something I don't I'm not >> I understand it. It's
on the internet all the time.
>> $5 from Dosadia to say the Republicans made that deal
with MAGA. That's what saying when he says he'd work with Assan
on to further his own names. It's >> true. No, but they
didn't. They actively opposed them and then MAGA won in the primary
and then took over the party. It wasn't like, "Oh, we'll work
with you."
>> They they literally tried to coordinate against Trump
and they got
>> Does nobody remember all of them attacking Trump and
Trump just being like, "Your wife is ugly. You're 5 foot nothing.
Does nobody You're low energy." Does nobody remember this? They
were literally all against Trump. They all came together to try
to attack Trump every single debate. And it looked awful for
them. They looked
>> Rand Paul. I've had you up to here. He taps his chest.
Okay. immediately started working with him. >> They won.
Yeah, they won the primary. And it's like, well, okay, we're
not going to like tank our whole election because Donald Trump
is our candidate now. Like, that that's a different story. If
Assan is like promoting tankies in the primary like, yeah, we
need to fight back. And at that point, if he wins the Democratic
primary, people like that win, I think we're just like magn
What the he says, is the anti-semitism prevalent among the lefty
tanky folks, not disqualifying on its own? How could reasonable
Democrats ever work with
>> You are neurotic. You are histrionic. You this this
anti-semitism you claim does not exist.
At least to the degree you're saying. Okay. It does exist in
some places. Sometimes it can happen, but unfortunately it is
it's driven from a place of like nothing.
Unfortunately, you can only complain about this stuff happening
for so long before you start to become like jaded and bitter
and not morally clear on it. Okay, that's that does end up happening.
The anti-semitism is there. That does end up happening. But I'm
telling you, all these people principally are against that kind
of thing. all these people. The second you start speaking up
about this, the second you start working against it, it will
swap back in. It is not a level of racial hatred like it is for
right-wingers, like it is for like the Fuentes of the world.
It's not the same.
>> Sorry. So, you guys lost your lost cause. You should
have got a better handle on Israel. Now, we throw you to the
fires. We try to save our country. Good luck. >> It is
something where >> we survived the fires in the 40s. We'll
do it again. >> There was there was an article written
uh recently that I responded to because it it was just horrific.
It was horrifically anti-Semitic. uh it was talking about how
uh the title of the the article was yes all okay so just to give
you an idea okay
>> was it in German >> no but basically basically
it's it was purportedly author anti-inist uh who just basically
said that the are entirely responsible um that her people as
a whole were responsible not just the ones in Israel but all
institutions everywhere
I mean I would say I don't agree with that but if I were if I
were a a whether or not I supported Israel I would be aware I
do not want to appear to support Israel right now. >> You
know what I'm saying? >> Reban Ruben donated through >> Hello
Reuben Rubin from Philadelphia. >> Oh, I see. Yes. Yes.
Thank you very much.
In order to be anti-inist,
you have to cheer on Hamas for the miracle of October 7th. Just
the most essentially this is essentially position, but there's
nobody that will call it out. So, it's do you think Wait, I'm
curious. You think it's fair to say that Hassan is better himself.
>> wait till he undefends and then he can you can ask your
question again. >> You should ask him.
spoiler. He's going to say, "No, I think maybe Hassan is a little
bit yikesy, but in general, I wouldn't necessarily say he's anti
mainly focuses on anti-Israel stuff." He's going to say something
>> "Yes, get guys, get ready to mob this guy." He's going
to say Hassan's not that anti-Semitic.
Actually, I mean, if you were watching before, I do think Soy
Pill gave a couple like token uh he calls dimbreads, he calls
them all kinds of things like this. I think he was talking about
that. So, I wouldn't say that Soy is going to say Hassan's not
anti-Semitic at all. I don't think so. Didn't seem to be his
opinion before. No one no one no one cheat and type in his chat
uh the answer there. I want to see Oh, he's >> I am curious.
>> Go ahead. Go ahead. Would you say that? Do you think
it's not? Is it fair to say that his rhetoric is across the threshold
of like pretty big anti-semitism? Of course. Oh, there we
>> yeah. Cuz I don't just make assumptions about people.
I listen to what they say and I I I try to be accurate about
people, you know. Wow.
Wow.
By the way, I think
I think you can let some of the like inbredad comments, they
don't really affect me that much. I don't necessarily I have
like thoughts on this on where it's like anti-semitism versus
like outrage over an injustice that sort of can be conflated
pretty easily, but is not inherently from a place of anti-semitism.
This is the argument I was making at the time around October
7th. Anyway, we'll let them >> Okay. Wait, Hassan [__]
or Mitt Romney? Who are you voting for? >> No, me. >> Mitt
Romney.
Good answer. Okay. $5 from >> Hey, look. Hey, he invented
Obamacare to an extent, you know.
>> Another black creator trying to steal from a white >> is
in the getting L's in chat right now.
>> I mean, he's
No,
no,
they're calling him a tanky sweeper because he says he'll associate
with them depending on certain factors. That's why they're calling
him a tanky sweeper. That doesn't fix it. But
by the way, I I don't even know if that's sincere. I wonder if
Soel had like a full conversation on that if he'd really stick
to that position to be honest with you. I think I think he just
did that cuz he sees no point in fighting these people who are
totally disingenuous in the first place, right? Like they aren't
holding anything to a reasonable standard. Oh, it is sincere.
Well, I assume you've had a conversation with
his son's rhetoric is expressing anti-semitic then even further.
How do you justify working with him? because the degree to which
he perpetuates it is massed enough that I don't think it's the
same type of [__] that Nick Wendas is doing. Even
it's no it's horrible. It's like, all right, you can like every
time you call him out for this anti-semitism, there's a reason
why his audience and anyone who is a useful idiot will come and
be like, well, actually, I think he's just being a little, you
know, anti-Israel here. And don't get me wrong, this still spreads
like actual real anti-semitism, I'm sure, to like the same kind
of you see that uh Wiction
I barely heard.
Hold on. >> Because the degree to which he
is doing, even it's not it's horrible. It's like, all right,
you can >> How do you justify working with him? Hold on.
Hold on. How do you justify working with him? How do you justify
working with him? How do you justify working with him, man? How
do you justify working with this guy? Every time you call him
out for this anti-semitism, there's a reason why his audience
and anyone who is a useful idiot will come in and be like, "Well,
actually, I think he's just being a little, you know, anti-Israel
here." And don't get me wrong, this still spreads like actual
real anti-semitism, I'm sure, to like the same kind of you see
that uh Wick was just talking about prediction. I I'm
talking
>> he dude Soy pill is being way too consiliatory here.
Soy pill is literally doing all of the little like
the like throat clearing things to not get attacked and he still
gets attacked. He is literally cocking in every possible way.
He's like I I think he is like a he's like still anti-semitic
and it's like not quite as obvious but there's a reason people
like still hear it and it's anti-ionism to them and not anti-semitism.
Oh, so you you think like you think it's not that bad? Okay.
Well, you think he's not like Fentes? Well, you're I'm going
to I'm going to take the win here. You said Hassan's not like
like Nick Fentes. I'm going to take the win here, guys. >> On
that one, Kyla. I literally
explicit anti-semitism. It's more masked. Like, yeah. Like, I'm
sorry. >> so hide. I don't I don't even know what Van is
masking. I'm not going to lie. Every time I >> these people
are not masking in their
in in the thing they're pushing okay which is support for Israel
no matter what Israel first they are not masked even remotely
okay
the anti-semitism that Hassan does which he absolutely does and
acknowledging that is just as bad as Nick Wendis is >> it's
worse it's worse >> it's worse I'll tell you why
>> I said be right back and then I heard this
my
god It's worse. It's worse. It's worse.
What is wrong with these people?
WHAT IS ACTUALLY WRONG WITH these people? What
>> That [__] I'll be right back. >> The
anti-mitism that Hassan does, which he absolutely does. I'm acknowledging
that is just as bad as Nick's. >> It's worse. It's worse.
>> No, it's worse. Can I tell you why
we need to tell you why it's worse about >> I have never
heard if you can find that. I've never heard say that we should
them
>> Go to the [__] you know, go to the speech
where he's got the big screen behind him. when he's talking about
we need to like go to war with the people like what are you talking
about >> you no you understand why it's worse even if even
if Fuentes did say that what Hassan is doing is worse because
it's normalizing it and masking it and it's much more insidious
>> if you think that
it gives people an excuse it gives people an excuse >> no
please wait no this is insane if you think that the people how
many minorities you know that you say that you would hear say
I just wish they would just come out with it'd be much better
if they just called me the >> No agree that's so that's
ridiculous >> No it's much more Hassan's audience audience
and like per capita is going to be more pro the Nick Fentes's
audience
>> dude these PEOPLE ARE SO DERANGED
IT'S ACTUAL derangement
it's actual insanity it's it's absolutely crazy to watch
>> it would be more holocausting it because for the neo-Nazi
position is and has been control all of our country we want all
the out they are in charge of things like replacement etc but
neo-Nazis follow to Israel. Hassan advocates for a project of
the destruction. >> Dude,
neo-Nazis would never follow Jews to Israel.
I think you're confusing neo-Nazis with America first.
Does he think? Why do you think they love the Hitler clips, Destiny?
Why do you think Nick thinks Hitler's so cool?
What do we What are we doing here, man? [__] are
we doing here? And by the way, Fentes explicitly says some people
will occasionally go and do this thing with Fentes. They'll go,
"It's not like racial hatred." Like, you don't think there's
like a blood guilt there, right? And Fuentes will go, "No, it's
not Zionism. It's not Israel. It's Jew.
It's not Zionism. It's not Israel. Let me be very clear for the
people in the back. It's Jew."
That is what he says. Now, do they stop being when they get to
Israel? Do they stop being evil when they get to Israel? I feel
like they don't. And for a long time, Destiny would argue that
you're actually just sweeping for them. If you say that they
are going to stop when they go to Isra, like if you if you say
they just want them out of the country and they never hurt them,
you're sweeping for these guys. Now, we've started arguing the
opposite. No, no, no. They're really sincere about just letting
these people all go to Israel and it's it's fine. Totally fine,
man.
The same people arguing that Hassan is more anti-semitic and
dangerous than Fentes are the same ones that rightfully recognize
that people who have more for AOC than MTG or Tucker Carlson
have lost the plot. Yeah. Yeah.
No, it's totally accurate
of the state of Israel would support military action to do it.
Much the same
Israel is based. This is terrible. I'm not saying I do so much.
>> Go ahead. I don't I don't >> I do genuinely believe
that
>> I do genuinely believe that a substantial amount of
Hassan's audience are just they would believe anything.
why are they thinking that Hassan would nuke Israel? I'm sorry.
Why would Why are they thinking Hassan would nuke Israel?
What part of Hassan's character leads you to believe that he
would nuke Israel? Are you out of your minds?
>> Like it's debatable to what extent. Look, okay, Nick
Fuentes is a neo-Nazi who says you have no place in civilization
and you're comparing this to Hassan who is anti-Semitic who is
conflating Israel and Judaism and is saying a bunch of horrible
and saying these things are worse than what Nick is saying. I
don't know what reality we live in. This is anti-semitism because
they're both
the neo-Nazi anti-semitism doesn't extend past the borders of
your country. It's because are interested in destroying whatever
the fabric of your country through mass migration or whatever
else. But Hassan
>> Yeah. inherently at a genetic level. What do you think?
What do you do? Do you think Nick thinks that they're going to
go back to Israel and go, "Oh, well, we lost America. That's
fine. We'll let America thrive." Do you think Nick thinks that?
What part of Nick talking ever makes you think that once once
everybody's old are expelled from from America? What part of
Nick's anti-semitism makes you think that, oh, the will just
be nice now that we kick them all out? They'll be nice and they'll
go to Israel and they'll just let America thrive.
Are we Are we serious right now? Are we actually Are we for real
right now? I I I don't know. I don't know what we're >> Anti-mitism
comes from an anti-western anti-imperialist would follow them
to the Middle East where he would want them to be removed from
Israel. That's why he like you're never going to hear from a
neo-Nazi like go back to Brooklyn or whatever else, right? If
anything, neoazi would be happy if every off to Israel. Whereasan
wants the country of Israel to be destroyed. They think that
they literally say no.
Neoaz are also
>> No, they're anti-America working. Dude, WHAT PART? THIS
GUY'S DEBATED Fentes on this topic. How did he not understand
any of this? How did he not pick up anything? Not all neo-Nazis
are anti-Israel. They're only ever performatively pro-Israel
in that they will support an ethnostate because they like ethnostates.
They still think that ethnostate is filled with people who they
just want their ethnostate. And once they get their ethnostate,
they're going to go deal with the other ethnostates. 100% down
the line, they're they're going to go deal with that ethnostate.
The only other view that exists amongst people who could be called
neo-Nazis are the BAP people who are just a Zionist plot, okay,
themselves. Okay, that's they literally are. It's they're literally
people who support Israel who are trying to get right-wingers
to be racist and proethnostate but also support Israel.
I'm sorry. That is that is the state of play.
Buy me somebody else who falls outside of this. I would love
to see it with Israel. No, there's so no, you're thinking of
like Christian nationalists that are specifically looking at
this, but they're so neaz
when you say anti-Israel in Israel in so far as they exert influence
over the United States or force the US to get involved with wars.
That's why they say like America first, it's not Israel because
Israel is going to go to war with Iran. >> But they also
want to kill all the because of that. Like that's what I'm saying.
But why does that matter if they're like well oh they want if
they if they left them alone? Yeah. But they think that they
control everything and are evil. Like what what is this
>> If we're not drawing a distinction there then then there's
even less of a distinction between Hassan's perspective which
is that Zionism is inherently like a what did he say on CNN?
ethno religious supremacist nationalist project like and and
90% of they're Zionist. So he would call for basically the elimination
of 90% of people. Like what did he say before? What was it two
days ago? He said they should all go back to the Russian oblast
for like way off in the east. Like
>> I I I don't know. Show me. I'll grade it next to the
>> he thinks if you support this genocide, you are a terrible
human being who shouldn't be accepted back into society.
>> That's that's true. That's a comment on the genocide
though. That's a comment on like what is being allowed to occur.
This is why you can't make these gambles, right? So the statement
that I just said, right? So like like um chat literally agrees
with this, right? How is that wrong? That's true, right? So your
child even agrees with these what are they agreeing with
is an ethnosremist religious supremacist project and that the
state >> isn't Zionism ethnremist. >> No, it's not.
Only if your understanding of that is is a child's notion of
a lot more than I can't say. >> No, how is it saying it's
not saying it's a supremacist by ethnically protecting a country
is it has to be an ethnically supremacist position that you
Destiny's defending the ethnost state. DESTINY'S DEFENDING THE
ETHNOST STATE. LET'S GO.
LET'S GO.
This is Hey, Kraut. Kraut, you want to speak up on how this is
um these are liberals, right? Aren't these classical liberals
that are defending the ethnostate concept right now? Hey, Kraut.
Kraut, aren't you ready to step in and say, well, that's not
about that's not liberal values at all right now. If you're an
ethnostate that that purges all non-Jews out of your area and
then treats them differently within your society, I would say
that's kind of ethnosopremist. Yeah. >> No. Ethnos supremacist
is different than protecting the ethnicity of a country, >> In
in protecting it, you're expelling another peoples and your explicit
mission is to like get all the Gazins out of the West Bank and
the Gaza Strip. This is ethnosmreist and religion >> If
I can't I can't if that's your perspective, then that's fine.
This you have the perspective of a child. Can't you see I am
obviously intuitively correct? Dude, does this guy make arguments
anymore? When when did this guy stop making arguments? This is
the guy who used to say he was the best debater on the internet.
He doesn't even attempt an argument anymore. He just does an
exasperated sigh and shuts his
What in the world is happening? Time stamp. Uh minus 1 hour 36.
I can't get you a direct time stamp. I don't have the the script.
Tell me why it's not. I mean, that's how it sounds to me. >> It's
not about It's not about one religion dominating another. It's
about people having feeling like they want to protect the ethnic
group in their country.
This is like, oh yeah, they don't want to expel black people.
They just want to protect the white population, right? Like you
can phrase it that way. But like it seems to me that this is
why we're
>> No. Don't you understand that they've been programmed?
They've been programmed. So So because they've been programmed,
they get to do whatever they want. They you once the Holocaust
happens, they get a free ethnostate automatic. Automatic, man.
Zionists want to expel the Gaz and the Palestinians, right? Like
>> that's how you don't have to expel black people in the
United States. There's no reason for that. They're not a threat
to the white people. So it wouldn't make sense in that sense.
Whereas for
>> inherently inherently they're not
>> what are we saying about the Palestinians now inherent
oh uhoh are a huge minority so there's a different
I'm saying that the the
>> dude so every single white supremacist is just like
reaching over for their FBI crime statistics right now and frothing
at the mouth at this. They're not inherently like a pro. They're
not they're not like a threat to anybody. OH MY GOD. HAVEN'T
YOU SEEN THE FBI? OH MY GOD. WHAT ARE YOU SAYING? >> THE
DESIRE to protect the ethnicity comes from a different place
in ethnos supremacy. It comes from a place of there's an ethnicity
that the country wants to protect. >> This is a distinction
without a difference in me
>> position and expelling a bunch of people that are of
not of your ethnicity because well the because I'm better than
them. It's cuz they're dangerous to me. >> We can commit
to a crime. That's the only reason.
>> Oh,
so Bill found it. Soyel threaded the needle. Listen, why do why
do black people commit so much crime? They seem kind of dangerous
to me. I think that might be a problem. We would have to actually
get them out,
wouldn't she say? >> Ethnic in Israel, but those ethnics
all flipped against Israel and were also like working with terrorist
groups to attack Israeli civilians. Do you think Israel would
want them out in the same way that they want like >> I
don't think that disproves what we're >> Well, it well
potentially in this case, right? They might be willing to like
try
work with the minorities
>> literally. Yeah. Do you think Do you think the fascists
aren't ready to put you in the firing squad right now for liking
blacks?
I you could flip every one of these
Like it's >> then you've betrayed your country. >> It's
just
>> Sorry, I don't want to do the thing. You can flip every
one of these hypotheticals.
You obviously could make the argument that if you were working
against the aims of white supremacists and they ended up winning
that if you had worked significantly against them in a way that
they thought was dilatorious to the future of their country,
dilitterious to the existence of their people, they could justify
killing you and they would probably do so.
I'm sure that some German soldiers who were sympathetic to people
and tried to hide them got killed in the Holocaust. No, I'm guessing
that's almost certainly a thing. Or did they go, "Well, you're
one of the uber mench, so actually we won't kill you, and that's
the only way you're
So if Germany refused to execute German guards who like tried
to sneak somebody out of the out of a concentration camp, if
they refused to kill them, that means that they're truly ethnosists
because they weren't willing to,
I guess.
But if they killed those people, they wouldn't be ethnosremacist.
So if they killed those people, if they killed somebody who was
a German who was trying to help, you know, people out of Germany
or something, that would prove that Nazis were not ethnosremacist
in Aerodit's world.
Very cool. Very awesome. You love to you love to see arguments
like this. >> In the same way
that's willing to work with the minorities and you've betrayed
your country and your peoples, like yeah, but I don't think that
means they're not ethos supremacist. This is a >> Okay,
we could have this is real debate another day. Uh $5. Well, you
have to establish a Jew saying that they're better, not that
they're like worried about like safety. >> For the two
Canadian, which they do, >> this is by definition, Judaism
is not like a it's not a proitizing religion. They don't try
to convert people into their OR WHATEVER. >> YOU JUST ARGUED
SOMETHING. I'M SORRY, BILL. You
What THE IS YOUR PROBLEM? YOU LITERALLY JUST ARGUED HIS POINT,
DUDE. DUDE, you literally Why don't they try to proitize? Why
don't they add people to the religion? Because they're the chosen
people.
That's like that that has been a part of the religion for a very
long time. They're the chos people
>> ever. Dude, dude, what do you think birthright is? That's
what they're constantly trying to do this. >> They're not
trying to convert people right is literally exactly not that.
Birthright is bringing >> Yeah. They want them to come
in and they try and they try to make them more culturally more
religious. >> What do you think? What does the birth part
in birthright stand for? It's boring. I know that they're already
they want them to become more religious. It's like, dude, come
on. Like, >> no. They want them to join the country. They
don't care about the not just join the country
of the culture and the [__] religion. They do this
all the time. This is a leftist talking.
Judaism has nothing.
>> He want Judaism has nothing to do with the religion.
Did he just say that? >> This is a leftist. Judaism has
nothing. Judaism has nothing to do with the
Wait, do they have like religious symbology on all of their money
and like all over their their country and their their society?
Do they give exemptions to join the military specifically for
who are too religious who have a religious like opposition to
it? That one could be just because they're buying political votes.
But still still
>> I think he means well I think what he means there is
he probably means Zionism or being Israeli Israel is nothing
to do with the um the religion. That's probably what he means.
I saying Judaism has nothing to do with the religion is
yeah it's it's like a [__]
people to go to synagogue in Isra.
But I will say that is a thing Destiny does is he tries to talk
over people and he says utter nonsense. Like just total and complete
nonsense, right? Like he just doesn't want Soy Pill to make his
point. So he's going to say nonsense over him for as long as
he can to stop Soy Pill from making his point. I think he realized
that he said something stupid now. So he had to stop >> because
they want them to become part of this cultural movement. This
is just a thing. I'm not even saying
they're not promoting a religion. >> The point of birth
is to bring back to Israel so they can show up the demographic
majority so they can absorb more Arabs that they have to. nationalist.
Just to be clear, it is a national going to temple birth. >> They
do that. They promote this as well as part of birthight. They
literally promote religious teachings. >> Okay. Okay. Okay.
Hold on. You guys can debate this another day. $5 from Grman.
For the two Canadians, so this is to Dev and Erdite. Who do you
think is more extreme? Hassan or Avi Lewis, the new head of the
federal NDP in terms of policy and how they act.
>> Yeah. Theodore Herzel was was um it was a Zionist, sorry.
Zionism was about a nation state for for Israelis based on the
ethnicity
that these people were not inherently religious. But I will say
upon the founding of Israel upon so Herzel dies way before they
actually found Israel upon the founding of Israel they do make
several decisions that have explicitly to do with the religion
as well and that progresses that that gets absolutely put in
over time becomes like increasingly increasingly important right
I don't think anybody denies that Herzel himself was about land
was about a nation but once they obtained that nation they absolutely
became very religious at that time like they they started incorporating
turning these elements into the the because it it had to be like
all hands on deck, right?
>> I don't know anything about Avi Lewis. I I know that
he's fighting with the Alberta people, but I don't know anything
about Avi Lewis. >> Anything about >> uh talking
about like monies, first of >> to Pave. Hell, invest it.
Anything but
>> I'm not talking about like monies. First of all, I do
not have the money to like change elections. I'll donate like
20 bucks to a candidate that I like. What I'm talking about is
like, hey, a bunch of my audience is like, "What do we do? What
do we do? We're looking to you." And so when I see Destiny Vos
do this [__] where it's like let's get all of you
guys out here and try to flip this that matters is going to help
us get the Senate majority. I want to do that. And
stop killing people. Stop blowing stuff up. Stop killing people.
Stop blowing stuff up. Stop exping. Stop ethnic cleansing. Stop
killing people. Stop ethnic cleansing. Stop blowing stuff up.
Stop killing people. Stop ethnic cleansing. That's the only conversation
that needs to happen. So easy. Oh, stop the aparthides. Sure.
Sure. Stop the oppression. It's over and over and over again.
All right. >> Apparently, there are other organs that are
not PB that are doing that. So I'll I'll hop on there if they're
the ones who are working with us on. So >> $20 from Odashara
to say, "Soyill, which group of creators in these political projects
would do more advocacy for the Democrats in general? Progressive
victory or digital ground game?" There is your answer. >> Sounds
like digital ground game. Yeah. >> $5 from Audacity say
just just tie your career to these people. Just tie your career
to these people. Soy pill, you'll be fine. That person's a literal
schizophrenic who sent that super chat, by the way.
>> Literal schizophrenic. >> Good points. But how
does this ensure we give Israel another 578 bazillion dollars,
dudes? Bro,
>> $10 from Odashara
who they want him. End quote. You should care. The type of rhetoric
will create either unenthusiastic voters or [__]
third party voters. There needs to be >> This guy has a
60 IQ, by the way. He is one of the dumbest human beings that
I've ever had the displeasure of sharing a VC with. >> I
live in Los Angeles and none of us normies think Newsome is a
genocide. Most of the normies I've know like him because he's
standing up to Trump. That seems like a bigger factor to me.
>> I guess this is reference to the enemy Charlie thing
that you were saying earlier, right? >> Sure. Sure. It's
just like there just is a lot of like socialisty I don't I don't
even want to speak for her name any char exact specific positions.
I don't know if they've ever talked about gavismism. They're
just like I don't know just in LA there are just a lot of these
types of socialist people that are like socialist champion socialist
types that >> Why does she keep doing it? She just keeps
doing it over and over again. Hy Charlie and this Nimma person
are like turbo who have no idea what they really think cuz they've
never looked into anything. They're just stupid bimbos who have
never bothered to do any deeper research i.e. watch a Destiny
stream, right, to get the real opinions.
How are you a woman? You do this to other women. How am I How
have I become the guy who notices this and points it out? I'm
It's so
I just want to go back to being able to be misogynist. These
people made being misogynist so uncool. It sucks. >> Can
easily be moved in one direction or the other based on what I
think Newsome is based and >> she's on board. >> I'm
going to call trap on that tweet because every single person
I knew in California hated Newsome. So, I'm calling super mega
cap on that tweet. >> Fair enough. I don't know anyone
in California because >> all the LA people I know hate
Gavin Newsome, but maybe I just know a select crew of LA people.
>> Gavin gets a lot of for his like homeless policies and
his inefficiency, but like he said,
if there's anything you don't like, I'm going to middle ground.
One, I'm getting wings for dinner. Two, my don't want in the
coalition
forever. It's power. They just want to endlessly critique power,
which is usually true. It was a good
amount of agree with that that we definitely don't want the coalition
also like this.
They say far more than don't. >> Yeah, that was that was
the kill shot tweet their entireity. Okay, $5 by sending an email
about a mission. Please respond. You guys can do that. >> $10
from kid H regarding unsophisticated LA. If you're convinced
it could be over the motor only then consider them. Regardless,
your time would likely be spent better spent elsewhere. >> I
could get Charlie on board in 10 seconds. So >> it's just
it's just not a >> You hear that Charlie? You hear that
>> I'm I'm sorry.
What dude? I don't want to be the guy who hears this. I don't
want to be that guy man.
What? I need I need a soy person.
I need a soy co-host who can freak out about this stuff so I
don't have to. Okay, I'm I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I'm done.
>> Zero some game. It's like you can >> tech 10 seconds
with soy pill will set her straight. Now, is that talking about
an Israel or herbs?
>> Obviously, just do both things. You can try to bolster
liberal voices and invite like LA socialites to liberal events
and and collab with them. Like, it's just obviously you could
do do both of these things. It's just obviously if I'm interfacing
with somebody further and further left my collab >> and
just like that we're back and just like that we're so back in
costic because we disagree about everything. >> Okay. $10
from dirty deeds to say the answer is always >> corrective
debate
incoming. >> Simply ask yourself if X creator explains
worldview and you're willing to fight and die what they want.
They are not your friend. >> So I'm so sorry. I'm >> When
is [__] unameric? >> I don't want I don't want
to say these things. These are these are crazy. is unfuck America
going to make college chapters to challenge the Kirk Jun and
YDSA losers. >> There we are. I'm pretty sure, right? >> Don't
know. >> They're trying to make college chapters. >> These
people are far more effective in organizing the groups than anything
that left or liberal people do to be honest. Like Dave and I
probably remember some of this [__] like
>> also progressivism developed as a critique of liberalism
in 18. It was okay. What was it? Do you remember it >> with
an illegal immigrant who doesn't California
in like Tennessee? So like uh it depends on what level assimilation
we're looking for. Okay. Uh, $5 from O. Can we get a collab and
get Lauren Petta Pettra and Mont Madre? I have faith that Kyla
can bring them on our side. >> I don't know those people.
>> Lauren P is the girl that kind of like LA kind of. Yeah,
>> I don't know who Mont Madre is. >> Not Not sure.
>> $5 from Granite Hard. Airite keeps conflating any interaction
with working with a creator on a political project. We interact
with leftists by disagreeing with them.
>> That I don't believe I've ever >> I'm just guessing
that this Lauren person is very attractive. Uh, yeah. Yeah,
this is this is the person. Guys, can anyone can anyone figure
out why Erdite thinks that this I think this is the person. I'm
not totally sure. Can anybody figure out why this person would
be somebody that wants to collaborate? >> What's your favorite
promise that you've broken so far? >> There's so many.
It's hard to choose. >> I got time. What a beautiful piece
of art this is.
>> Really beautiful. What's your favorite promise that
Trump >> Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. I wonder what's going on there.
Good luck to you in watching content. >> Travacia for $5.
Question to the entire panel. Do we all agree that the critique
the far left makes against Gavin is and should be ignored regarding
trans stuff?
>> I just wish I was wrong. I actually wish I was wrong.
Sometimes I wish I was wrong. Okay. I really do. >> He's
like explicitly protrans in like several different ways and pass
a bunch of protransis. It was literally like ahead of the curve
on LGBT issues than any other person in California. Not any other
person than most politicians. And the idea that it's like oh
yeah, but he'll throw trans people because he went on a podcast
with with The transition should be in sports, I'm pretty sure,
which is like true obviously.
>> There are questions. >> This is this is a good
example of why appealing to leftists is is just a fool's errand
because as soon as you say something that's off script, it doesn't
matter in the past. >> Can you point to the person in this
call that wants to appeal to leftists? >> I'm saying it
to the audience who in my chat there are plenty of people who
are disagreeing with me. Okay. >> Yeah. No, I had a recent
dust up with a very big leftwing YouTuber named Nara who basically
said the same thing because I'm not protrans women sports. I
was the same as like weird like privilege. I just like it's either
privilege or you're lying. Like you don't act. Dev would never
be anti-trans. That's the only thing he's attracted to. He would
never be anti-trans. Okay.
Ever. Ever. Ever. Dev is the biggest chaser. And you're accusing
him of being anti-trans. Come on, man. >> Obviously mean
that them if you think about it for like 3 seconds. >> Uh
$5 from fancy teeth. Why is it so hard? These people are sabotur.
Why are we helping them? True. $5 from real >> Wait on
that one. Wait. So like if anyone's asking me like, "Hey, should
we like capitulate to like a Hassan point or like should we prop
up Hassan's movement?" The answer is obviously no cuz I think
it's insane and terrible and harmful and there are saboturs.
The question is should we let them help us if we think that would
benefit us more not are we propping them up.
>> And what this is the question this is the practical
question we let them help us like like I said if they are willing
to come and work with us I think that's a different question
than if they get together a political movement and say we want
liberal creators come out and help us with this. I think those
are two separate questions. Does that make >> Okay probably
in part depends on what they want help with. If what they want
help with condition it's always going to be policy. It's always
going to be a question of like well what what are we
for leftist candidate? No. >> So he's disappointing me.
I mean, to be honest, it's just a struggle session. It's been
a struggle session the whole time. I think he's probably being
sincere, but he is maybe maybe all of his sincere positions just
perfectly opt out of the struggle session. I feel like there's
got to be something else going on there a little bit, but I don't
know. >> No, if you want me to support Democrat, Republican
every single time, yes, of course. But the rule of thumb here
still stands for me is that nine times out of 10, it's going
badly for you. >> I'm going to need I'm going to source
>> He's a weak man. Uh, that's the only criticism I wouldn't
make right now that he's weak. He's pointed out where he's correct.
He's not argued it when people like refuse to actually make their
own arguments when they get like just very like little baby throwing
a tantrum moments. He's not going to keep going, but he just
makes sure it's like clear that he's correct. So, if he ever
has to go back to this and point it out, he just do so, right?
I don't think he's weak at all here. That's like maybe I I disagree
with a lot of his positions, but I wouldn't say he's weak. How?
What do you mean?
>> You being seen working with these people is going to
be so cancerous. It you're going to it's like they have a stench
and that's going to rub off on you and you have to take >> I
feel like moderates are so much more like just like they're just
like less animallike as an audience. Like I feel like if I spend
a lot of time >> are moderates people around you? They're
less animallike as an audience. Have you ever I I want Erin to
go and the next time Pixie tweets something I want her to go
read the replies. Actually, maybe not even now, like three months
ago. Go read the replies on some pixie tweets.
>> I'm just saying less animallike, guys. >> And
with progressives, but as long and like leftists, but I'm like
sufficiently pushing back more or less on the all things that
we disagree on or whatever. I don't think anyone would be like,
"Oh, I mean, I like that Kyla girl, but like she talks to FD
signifier." I think as long as it's like, "Yeah, I mean, I disagree
with FD signifier on significant enough things, right?" The real
question is, do we help them in like political campaigning in
areas where they're like robbing and stealing of our culture
and do we let them take our language and more importantly, do
we take on their language? And the answer obviously has to be
no. Liberals should have a backbone and a culture and a community
and stand by it and defend one another and protect each other
and support each other. >> Liberalism is like by its definition
like the it is not a culture by definition.
Unfortunately, liberalism is like a negatively defined concept.
I it is tough for it to be a thing and stand on something because
it is by definition not that thing. Right? That is the that is
the point of liberalism.
it is like literally neg it's defined by what you shouldn't be
doing. It's like everything else. It is the negative. It's a
negatively defined thing. What is the culture?
>> I I don't I don't think so. I think a lot of moderates
are turned off when we work with leftists and and things like
that. I think a lot of them will just abandon us if they do that.
Um and that really I feel like they'll abandon us. >> This
is the culture they they purport to to follow. Yes. I don't think
that's the but I also don't think that's good. I think that's
quite actually say gender doesn't exist and we should abolish
gender. But I don't think they abandon us if we >> and
that's capitulating to a leftist narrative. That's not working
with a leftist. And to be fair, if you're leaving my movement
because I'm working with someone who I don't agree with who says
I'm supporting you, then you don't support my movement. And >> I'm
not even sure about that. Like I've I've I've embraced like the
the pronoun thing entirely. >> Okay. We are definitely
circling the drain hardcodely.
I've completely adopted that to
>> Trump because you got >> Does anybody have a time
stamp for Zoyill's stream so I could go watch his retrospective
or did Substance get the entire clip? cuz I know Substance clipped
it. But is that all we need is just the clip? I would assume
there's like a little bit like this is also someone where it's
like okay you clearly don't give a [__] about these
like movements. You don't think I don't think I like I would
if Taly invited like I wouldn't work with her on like a political
project to collaborate
but I would have her on my show. Wait wait wait wait. I just
want to say I just want to pay I just say real quick wait cuz
you're very good at like you speak very honestly without realizing
how honest you're being. Every single time you were challenging
my position earlier you kept saying like somebody that was like
slightly critical or somebody like oh I get so bad like your
words are very like couch but for here you actually just restated
my position perfectly when which I could have answered you perfectly.
said, "Would you work with Tally or whatever?" This is that one.
Is she that Jew girl who hates Korean people? Yes. >> You
said you said, "Would you work with her if she wasn't willing
to support your candidate?" No. That was so easy, but you perfectly
absolutely with absolute clarity stated my position there. It's
interesting that you state it so clearly there with regards to
her, but seem to obiscate or soft the language when it ever had
to do anything. That was very
willing to raise money for my candidate. If he's willing to promote
a candidate that I support, then I would work with her. That's
the >> The instant
clear
if we mean on the show with Yes. If we mean work with as in put
together like a coalition, right, to kind of like >> Yeah.
That's what everyone means. Soy bill also to your ear the pron
joke. Uh
>> not actually >> destiny just tried this like oh
actually you share my position completely. No soy bill just restated
the exact position you guys have been making him struggle over
for the past three hours.
>> No like you know who victor weapon is right the premise
of Hungary. >> You you guys adopted his position by the
way not the position you were arguing before right and not a
position you're applying consistently. you are. The way they're
doing it is they're going, "Well, anybody would support the candidate."
But then they're going, "Well, if you frequent if you're willing
to call this like a genocide repeatedly, then you're not supporting
the candidate." And so the entire contention was, "Well, no,
I think you can call it a genocide, you can be super against
it and still admit that in reality, like Camala Harris is better
than Donald Trump, even on Israel. And while I called it a genocide,
you should go vote for her." And Desi said, "No, that's inherently
contradictory."
That was the disagreement, right? But it's all it's all like
weasling around the edges so that they could cut Hassan out and
get somebody like Charlie in. And that's probably just not possible,
unfortunately.
You if you just operate off of spite alone, you're never going
to get the exact coalition you want, which is probably why you
shouldn't. >> Goes to to CPAC in the US. I think speeches
in English where he tells you Americans that he saved Hungary
from gender pronouns.
Um, there are Hungarian is a gender neutral language. There are
no gender pronouns in Hungary. That's a joke. There's only the
pronouns uh that's it. Like it's it's saving Hungary from something
that doesn't exist. So that's why when you find Hungarian lives
and leftwingers on social media, they often put the pronouns
in the bio to make fun of that fact because he would never give
that speech in Hungarian because it wouldn't make sense. That's
basically that. >> Here's the one that you wanted to answer.
I found it. Um Mr. uh Mr. Dev, this is from
>> Bad is Trump and equally corrupt. >> No, I didn't.
>> As Canadians, do you wanted to answer? I found it. Um
Mr. uh Mr. Dev, >> hold on. What is this? This is from
Kyla once implied was as bad as Trump. Equally corrupt. >> No,
I didn't.
>> Uh oh, that's the Jesse Lee Peterson thing, right? And
she's going to say, "Well, I was meing on Jesse Lee Peterson
the whole time." >> Do both believe that. >> She
said, "Oh, gun to my head." It was It was Heming and Hawing.
No, it was Heming and Hawing. But she's going to say she was
voted Trudeau over P.
>> Would I have voted for Trump over P? >> Of course
not. I mean, leader. >> No, obviously not. the [__]
>> Well, see see was >> I I might have voted polyv
over Trudeau at some point. Uh before before Trump got in a second
term, as soon as Trump got in a second term, I was never voting
for anybody who wasn't like vehemently opposed. That that flipped
my vote in the election. Trump how Trump acted towards Canada
flipped my vote in my Canadian election. It's up. >> It's
actually crazy. >> Thank you. Thank you. Every American
that gets so twisted about one joke that I made to an alien old
man, uh which is
>> Yeah. See, she's just saying, "Oh, I'm actually lying."
people. What's his name? Uh Peterson. Peterson. >> I just
wouldn't compare him to kind of crazy is so obnoxious because
every Canadian will tell you super super corrupt. A lot of Canadians
don't like
>> Paul. I don't know who you're talking about. Paul, but
Paulv,
Mr. Paulv, Pierre Paulv, he was against Trump, but he wasn't.
He he had been cozing up to Trump for a long time. He was winking
at populism stuff, and I was just super dumb with it. Super super
dumb with it. >> No, typically I go to NDP, actually. So,
you're welcome. >> Yeah, there was a lot of >> There
were several high-profile scandals in Canada. There was the cherry
scandal. Yes. And seeing scandal huge. >> Yes. Oh my god.
>> Mind-blowing. Huge. When Americans are >> nothing
on the order of anything to do with with um America at all. It's
like minor. It's like minor corruption. And it is stuff I wouldn't
vote for him over. But it's it's nothing like what Trump's done.
Not even a little bit. Not even a little close. >> I made
one joke where I was like, "Oh man, it's tough between Trump
and Trudeau." It's not actually Trump tough. Obviously, it's
still Trudeau. But Trudeau sucks. That's the joke. But welcome
to the joke. Trump sucks and like him. >> What Trudeau
did in the SNC scandal is Trumpike. And >> it is. It was
horrifying.
>> And also,
>> please ask, please ask Ardite to say what happened in
the S SNC Lavlin
>> Please, please, please. >> It was a few months
ago, I think the Canadian Supreme Court ruled that the emergency
powers Trudeau used during the trucker protest uh was unconstitutional.
Like Trudeau was a terrible prime minister. Doesn't mean that
that liberals in >> h that trucker protest should have
been handled way sooner. The only criticism I have for Trudeau
in the trucker protest is that he didn't send cops in with nightsticks
to beat the [__] out of those people sooner. Okay.
only
>> Terrible, but he was just uniquely bad for the Liberal
party. >> Fair enough. >> He just had his reputation
saved. >> Trump $2 for one hero HQ to say Wick is right.
We should just prefer you to say it. Okay. Well, thank you for
that. I appreciate you. Uh $5 from real Trump not to say soy
bill will unironically support the second worst on a topic by
virtue of them not being the number one worst person on a topic.
>> Support them. I think that's doing a lot of heavy liar
to say soy bill. Yes or no? Uh channeling his inner peace. If
the minority because all of Israel was taken over, do you think
they would be a second holocaust? >> No. Yeah, probably.
I mean, they're surrounded by people who want to kill >> Okay.
tectonic or being antinist. How does that make sense? >> Because
Zionism is like, well, we need a homeland. It has to be in this
specific place that's going to cause constant war and turmoil.
And I don't know if I support that. I think that yeah, there
should be a place that Jews call their home in the fact that
they're kicked out everywhere and there's anti-mitism everywhere.
But the idea the only solution to this is to establish this historical
homeland that is never ever going to be solved is constantly
going to be having war fought back and forth and killing millions
and millions of people. I think it's ridiculous. I think I think
this is where
they should spread out other countries. I don't think you can
just give them a
constantly genocide against which is why they constantly which
is why they want this, right? Because >> give them
do
American thing. Give him a reservation in America somewhere.
I don't know. Like the idea that has to be in Israel is ridiculous.
Case in point.
>> You're advocating for the full ethnic cleansing language
from Israel, right? >> Just say yes. Yes.
Anyway, it's already we're already
by the way. >> Sorry. I've got this way too fast for the
actual argument. There's a substantial argument happening at
the end here and I didn't expect it. So, I got to keep listening.
>> Genocided against which is why they constantly which
is why they want this, right? Because Jews >> give them
give them Manhattan Island. from Brooklyn.
>> Do do a do a Native American do a Native American thing.
Give him a reservation in America somewhere. I don't know. Like
the idea that >> I will say Bill's super confusing to me
now.
Why is he he's somehow arguing that like actually
they shouldn't have Israel. Like actually they shouldn't have
Israel at all. Move them all out.
It seems to be I'm like what? Wait, what? I'm conf Now now I'm
confused. Now I'm like giga confused. What the are you talking
about? >> Has to be in Israel. It's just >> Case
in point. Okay.
>> Wasn't make him answer. You just
say you're advocating for the full ethnic cleansing of Jews from
Israel, right?
>> The No, >> just say yes. Yes. >> Obviously,
this
can't work anyway. It's already We're already into
Just say it. Just say by the way the position
ethically doesn't matter. This is what I mean when I say leftists
have a more anti-semitic position than that that would cash out
into a more antic. Don't you get it soy pill? >> You are
always a tanky [__] >> You just didn't realize
it. All it took was talking to Destiny for long enough and now
he can see that you are an insane tanky who wants all killed.
Okay. So I hope you are happy that now that's you. That's you
now buddy.
talk to Destiny long enough he can figure out how to call you
anti-semitic. Let's go. Soy pill is an anti-semitic
like borderline holocaust denying I would think.
Piece of
I'm guessing a lot of people are going to carry that forward
now than neo-Nazis do. What do you mean you don't? You just said
you want them to flee Israel and go to all other places on the
planet. That's an ethnic cleansing from Israel. >> Clarify
obviously this is not available now. We they've been established
there for 80 years. Okay. Now I don't know what the you do. It
is. No, if you snap my fingers and teleport Israel, like lift
it up like a big island and drop it next to Manhattan, I would.
And that would be ethnic cleansing, but they don't really need
to travel into Libya and Egypt and all this. But like, no, I
don't want to like expel them. I don't think we should kick them
off their land. Obviously, there's too established. This is like
saying like, yeah, I don't support the >> Okay, clearly
fixed it. Hopefully none of that happens. >> Genocide and
the expelling of Native Americans, but guess what? It's been
like 400 years. I don't know how you rectify this at that point.
you need to find a way to like I don't know how to solve Israel
Palestine but no obviously what I mean is the project of Zionism
to establish it in Israel and the way that they did this I think
was destructive as I think it's led to all these problems I I
think they should have chosen something different at the time
and so the idea >> when you're saying anti-ionist as in
you don't want them to be the majority in their country anymore
so then what >> stop killing people stop blowing up buildings
stop destroying everybody's capacity to be happy at any point
in their lives stop killing civilians stop killing children stop
starving civilians Stop starving. Stop starving children.
that's it.
Don't try to get Don't try to do a gotcha on some definition.
This is why it's Dude, it's I'll do it in a way a three-year-old
could understand.
Stop hitting that other guy. Stop. Stop. No, I don't care what
he did. I don't care what he did. You stop. We're better than
that. You stop. Stop now.
Actually, no more money. No more treats until you stop and you've
been stopped and you start actually using your allowance to give
treats back to those guys. That's it. That's how it is. What
is that? >> Is that is that what anti-ionism is? I'm not
saying that they can't be the majority unless >> literally
the majority in their country. >> Zionism is where you
have a majority in Israel because it's an ethnoprotected majority.
Yes. So if you're >> if the way that if the way that you
are establishing this ethnic majority is that you expel minorities
and like steal their land and kill people. Yeah. that I'm I'm
anti that. >> So So they've already done that
wait because nobody ever has to answer this question. They said
they're anti-Z. I know what
>> they've already done that. I can't tell if that's Destiny
saying they've done that historically or if he's just talking
about Lebanon. Stop trying to get Lebanon back. You're not getting
Lebanon back. You're not getting southern Lebanon back. Stop
trying to get Lebanon back. BRO, THEY DID THAT YESTERDAY, BRO.
They're doing that now. What do you mean they already did that?
No, they're still doing it. They're literally doing it right
now. What the are you talking about? I'm just cur like so what
is the solution then? It's the ma the cleansing of Israel.
>> It's the Okay, so the are you giving a dichotomy between
first of all the idea that I can solicit
but second no if you're asking me the dichotomy if you're asking
me the dichotomy between what they're doing in the West Bank
and Gaza and not doing that I think there's probably a better
thing to do. And just because I don't know exactly what they
should do doesn't mean I'm anti-Jew or like
proing.
This is why I hate that the whole leftist people have decided
to purity us on this one issue because the position is totally
untenable. >> No, no, I'm not saying you are, but all the
other people that you if there is no solution for them, but starting
wars, ethnically cleansing, taking land, you know what the decision
is? It's super simple. Stop giving them money and weapons to
do it.
How hard is it? How hard is it? If you are going to do that,
I will try to oppose you and I will not accommodate it. How hard
is that to do? How hard is that to say?
Holy [__] That are on the far left. They pretty on
this position. Like when somebody says they're anti-Zionist,
I just don't know what that means. What is it actually? >> What
is anti-Israel's project of ethnically cleansing Gazins right
now?
>> Okay. Just your first stopped in Gaza. Just real quick,
just real quick. Hold on. If they stopped in Gaza,
>> no money for Israel until they've rebuilt Gaza and they've
rebuilt everything they destroyed in Lebanon.
No, not a dollar, not a dime. No more qualitative military ad
edge. No more of that. Nothing. Nothing until they've stopped.
And they've reversed. They need to reverse. They can't just stop.
They need to reverse. Okay. Rebuild Gaza. Rebuild Lebanon.
Once that started,
maybe maybe stopped in the West Bank, but still kept their uh
their uh ratios for how many uh ethnic are in the country versus
how many um other ethnicities are in the country. You'd be okay
with that?
>> Uh if how do they enforce their ethnic
>> amnesty for Israel?
Amnesty. Guys, what if they just stopped now? They just did a
couple genocide. They just did a little bit of like genocidal
war crime attack. [__] I'm trying to do explicitly
like talking points. They're um I'm trying to say all the things
at once.
They just did a couple war crimes. They just did a little genocide.
They just did a little ethnic cleansing. That's all. Let bygones
be bygones.
uh by only letting in uh ethnic Jews and expelling uh if it goes
above a certain amount the uh
>> other and if I say I'm not okay with this does that
mean I'm pro Israel being ethnically cleansed because there's
a
the thing you have toity
on a real level that's what would happen ethnic cleansing is
necessarily bad I think we should ethnically cleanse people from
West Hollywood personally I don't think all ethnic cleansing
is necessarily bad but just like own the >> okay wait To
be fair, like I know that was a meme, but do you actually like
when when is ethnic cleansing justified? Like Chinese exclusion
hack type stuff or like like uh oh, we can only have this ratio
of like this type of people from this country. Is it ever justified?
>> It Yeah, it probably is. But the thing is, it's never
the reason why the reason why it's hard to have this conversation
as an American is because we get to take our ethnicity, our national
identity for granted because we're never threatened by anybody
because we have way too many people. So, it's not a question
for us. But if we had countries to the north, if Canada had 10
billion people and Mexico had 30 billion people, we would be
having questions about what the American ethnicity is and how
we need to protect it all the time. But we don't have them in
immigrants. >> But I would >> Has Destiny ever heard?
There's this invention that happened a little while
>> It's kind of crazy. It's called the
Does this guy understand that there are airplanes and that immigration
can happen to America from anywhere in the world? Do we do we
not understand that that in terms of protecting your ethnicity
quote unquote the entire world can immigrate to your country
in a technical sense? It's very >> support that. I would
say look if it turns out that we just get a bunch more Canadians
and Mexicans and this transformed their country
every single person in Canada every single person in Canada every
single person in Mexico was a Nazi and we lived in the United
States of America and we had 300 million people. Let's say that
500 million Nazis from Canada wanted to immigrate into the United
States. You would accept that unquestionably. You wouldn't have
I wouldn't promote an ethnic cleansing. No, I wouldn't. And yeah,
I think we have a far different problem if you have an ideology
so pervasive that it's going to destroy your entire democracy
and coming in like people you're sounding like people talking
about No, no, no. You're talking about Muslims. Muslims are coming
into this country. Muslims want to destroy the democracy. So,
we should ethnically cleanse Muslims from Europe.
>> What did he even argue with Constantine Kissen on? I
actually don't know what was his problem with what Constantine
Kissen was saying. I didn't watch the debate. I'm never going
to go watch the debate. But what is the core disagreement? Well,
we're not God's chosen people. Okay? We are. And so have to deal
with this. And God's chosen don't. That's it. That's all it is.
I'm sorry. That's all that many Muslims coming here. It's not
a problem. >> There's millions. But there's millions of
them. There's tensions. Millions. Millions is nothing to us.
We're 300 million Germany. Should Germany ethnically cleans Muslims
only population of 80 million. Well, you said it's justified
people.
is such a worthless position. You can't even engage critically
with the position. We are not there. >> Dude, I guarantee
you if you wanted to just get Destiny to argue with Destiny,
you could just go find whatever you're saying to Constantine
Kissen, right?
Easily just find whatever his arguments were against Constantine
Kissen and replay them back to him and he would just be arguing
with himself, right? If there were 10 billion Muslims to the
north that wanted to destroy democracy in America and 500 million
wanted to immigrate, I think I WOULD HAVE SOME questions about
that. that I think most reasonable people would. We don't have
to worry about that. There are 7 million in in Israel in a in
a region surrounded by a billion Arab Muslims. They do have another
question about that. A lot of these Arab majority states literally
have their ethnic identity protected in their constitution, but
they just don't deal with it much because there's not a billion
Chinese people trying to immigrate to Pakistan.
>> You can be against that. Wait, no, no, no. Okay, you
can be against it, but it doesn't matter that you're against
cash out
the epic majority of [__]
or Iraq. >> Soy pill. Soy pill. The law prevents rich people
and poor people alike from stealing a loaf of bread. Right? That
law is obviously going to only affect the poor people in a realistic
sense. What you have to engage with and what anti-ionists have
to engage with and they're you know I I'm not asking you to solve
Israel Palestine but if I haven't heard this argument before
let's see where this is going. ethnostate and it is an ethnostate
of
Israel went away,
they would be under massive threat. It would happen, >> right?
And if you're if you're giving me the trolley problem of either
support ethnic cleansing or your country is taken over by neo-Nazis,
like yeah, I guess, but like I don't know how you map this onto
reality when there are potentially infinite solutions in between
those of making a project that there literally there are. And
by the way, all anybody's asking for is to just stop spending
your tax dollars to put your thumb on the scale for one side
of the argument. That's literally it. That's literally all people
are asking. Just don't spend our money to do it. I don't want
that. Please stop spending my money to do it. Right. Not literally
because I'm not American, but that's that's what people are arguing.
It's crazy, man. >> It doesn't involve ethnic cleansing
that solves this. And going to extreme hypotheticals of, yeah,
if there were 10 billion Nazis in Canada and they're all coming
in, well, yeah, obviously I don't want Nazis in my country. You
suck. But but but the idea that like, okay, therefore you support
ethnic cleansing. It's like this isn't what we're talking about
necessarily. We're talking about specific situations that Okay,
go ahead. You're saying support extreme hypotheticals like Hamas
is not an organization that was supported by Hezbollah that lived
to the north of Israel that was supported by Iran that was the
basically the
>> dude why is he being you're saying >> what we're
talking about necessarily
situations that okay go ahead >> you're saying support
extreme hypotheticals like Hamas is not an organization that
was supported by Hezbollah that lived to the north >> it
was supported by that was supported by Iran that was that was
supported by Iran, the basically the largest player in the region
that was tangentially peripherilally supported by um the Houthis.
Uh like you're like hypothetically hypothetically like I can
>> he's doing his list thing where he's not making a compelling
point at all. It's not even a little bit compelling the thing
he's saying, right? It's not compelling at all. He's just doing
a list thing.
Can't wait for Loner Box to come back and defend Destiny and
not all
What Soy Pill doesn't understand. What Soy Pill doesn't understand.
You can never even imagine this to be the case, but this is like
the reality. >> You're saying the hypothetical is either
you ethnically cleanse or you die. >> No, the the
is what Destiny is saying.
>> That is what Israel's argument is. Yes. >> That's
the hypothetical you gave me, right? Either you either ethically
why you why you just filibustering. The hypothetical was do you
protect the ethnic majority of your country or do you become
an ethnic minority and then die? That's the hypothetical. So,
ethnic cleansing or you die. That's literally what you just said.
That's literally what you just said. How do you protect the ethnic
majority? Through ethnic
THAT'S THE EXACT SAME THING. IT'S THE EXACT same thing.
What is wrong with this guy? >> Okay, that's the reality.
>> Using this logic, should Germany expel all the Syrians?
>> How many Syrians? >> Like 10 to 14 million and
then 8 >> That's a million 14 million. Wasn't it 10 to
14?
Wasn't Wasn't it like 14 million? >> I think they took
like a million in >> people that all left Syria. Like the
entire Syrian diaspora was 14 million. >> Maybe I'm mixing
up the numbers. Let's say it's
a population of 80 million. >> Typical leftist tactic.
>> No, I I was just wrong. I'm admitting
>> Dude, it's Soy pill is the only person. Why? Literally,
you can't have an argument. You can't have a conversation with
these people. It's actually so disingenuous. Like fundamentally,
how many times have they been wrong in a row? Soy pill misspeaks
once, they all pile on him instantly.
What is the point of even having this conversation or being a
part of these things
and he just goes, I'm wrong.
High school bullying. It's so embarrassing, man. It's so People
are beneath contempt. Like they're just they suck so badly.
They don't have Dude, they don't have an argument. They're just
going to bully this guy until he like stops speaking >> I
got the number messed up. a million and 80 million. Should they
start ethically cleansing them if more and more people are coming
and they're subverting the culture? >> No, it won't get
to that point because those countries protect their immigration.
They don't accept that many people. So, they don't get to that
>> And typically, people assimilate over >> Okay.
30 years into the future, that Syrian population, because they're
a low cost of living, you know, population, they're having like
big families, they're actually starting to reach near an ethnic
majority.
What do they do now? The white German population, the German
ethnic population is no longer having kids. They are very close
to being almost almost below majority.
What do they do now? That's quite literally the problem Israel
has, right? That is the problem Israel has. So what? Just run
forward the hypothetical a little bit. >> Like the reason
why like in part we're not super concerned about Muslims coming
to our immigration.
>> It's so funny because I I'll be real with you. Okay,
I'll be real with you straight, right? I don't I don't necessarily
disagree with their arguments, but I've always held that position.
I don't think it's wrong to think like, okay, well, we've got
this core majority of people and and I think that that could
have something to do with your country. I don't think that is
a wrong thing. I'm of the belief that while I don't think that's
wrong, I'm willing to try like the multicultural, multi-thnic
fabric and see if that works for a country. And I'm I'm like
willing to try it because ultimately I'm going to be dead before
the negative consequences hit anyway. But I'm like, "Oh, it's,
you know, it's aspirational. It's something that hasn't really
been done on the scale of the United States before.
I want to see if it can work." But I don't think it's like inherently
correct.
I'm talking about America right now. Um, Kathy, I'm not talking
about
Canada was already a multi-thnic country by like f like the fabric
of the country is multi-thnic, multicultural to begin with. So,
I already live there. Okay. But like I'm I'm fine with that.
I just don't think it's bad to begin with. These guys would argue
that ever talking about the United States and and the ethnicity
of the United States being something that should be protected,
they think that is neo-Nazi language. And then they just flip
they they totally kill their own principle for Israel.
It's bizarre. And they like Destiny consistently has this anti-immigration
like anti-anti-immigration
rhetoric
except it all goes away the second he's talking about Israel
instantly.
And he he makes it existential. It's not existential, has it?
It's It's literally not existential. Oh, although I will say
it starts to become closer to existential when you consistently
allow them to ethnically cleanse, to kill, to absolutely obliterate
the people around them and all of those people start to hate
them >> and death. >> Yes. Yes. No, I agree. Because
they protect their
space in time. Yes. That's that's the dichotomy because for the
one stator for all the lefties now that are pro Palestinian they
want Israel to be a single state that accepts every single Palestinian
as an Israeli citizen and then all of the diaspora Palestinians
as Israeli citizens so that they people be like 30% of the population
there >> and then they will >> um even less if you
if you think this is an argument that this is what the civil
war was about which I'm pretty sure it isn't. I'm pretty sure
you're saying something totally insane but I'm not going to argue
American history with you. I'm pretty sure that was not the argument
of the Civil War. But
in any case, I will say
you should at least at the bare minimum say it's totally good
for America to never pay them $1 ever again and to strip them
of their qualitative military edge that we are never going to
give you advance more advanced technology than the people around
you ever again.
Both of these things seems pretty obvious, right? >> Vote
to have a theocracy that will likely want to >> wipe them
out. So walk me through this >> I oppose Israel's ethnic
cleansing. >> I acknowledge that there is a world in which
the population gets to a point where Israel would uh that in
Israel be ethnically cleansed by the population that hates them
that they allowed in that both of these things are like potentially
completely plausible, right?
Why is it bad for me to oppose the ethnic cleansing if I believe
there could be even if I can't give you the solutions ways to
get around this that are not let's just keep ethnically cleansing
people and support ethos supremacist. you have a better solution.
I'm all ears. Well, the issue is that people seem to be the solution
is don't give them your tax dollars. Right? If you if you're
just going to agree that it is ethnic cleansing, but you don't
see a better solution, then at minimum you could say, "Well,
I we shouldn't give the money, right? I listen, if you want tax
dollars,
you guys are the chosen people. You guys are the the genius intellects.
You guys have the highest IQ's, right? Come up with a reason
and we'll give you the money back. Come, sorry. Come up with
a way. Okay, I'm putting that on the the people of Israel. All
right, these are the most entrepreneurial, inventive people on
the planet. I've been told. All right, come up with some some
way to not kill everybody around you and still exist. And then
once you figured that out, that and I don't mean by killing all
of them so you don't have to kill anymore. Then we could start
giving you money again or weapons again.
Super easy, man. A hardcore against the Zionist project. So you
call yourself an anti-ionist. But then the what the on the flip
side of that, if you if the anti-ionist were to have it their
way, you'd probably see my guess is another like mass expulsion,
mass uh if not a genocide, then at least some kind of ma mass
ethnic cleansing of the Israel state. But I don't think anybody
would be any of the Wait, what's the problem with that? Would
that be like a horrible thing to do? Wait, wait, what? Would
you say that's like a monstrous thing to
Would you say that's a anti-semitic THING TO CONSIDER? OH, SO
IT'S LIKE a racial supremacist thing to Oh, I >> pro Palestinian
people are not going to stand up to say anything about that.
So, they're basically just like expelled from their country.
>> But this is why it's frustrating because the project
of Zionism said we're going to establish this country here and
it caused all these downstream effects. >> Israel has the
right to exist. What does it need to do to exist? And and ethnically
cleanse millions of people. Well, that seems like a problem.
You got a better solution?
I don't know. You kind of killed and ethically cleansed a lot
of people already. They might not really be that cool with you
guys anymore. I don't know if I have a better solution. Well,
I guess we get to just keep doing it then
Is Is that how that works?
Damn, son. If that's how that works, then I don't know. I guess
maybe you do just get to kill as many people as you want, as
many kids as you want. You get to starve them to death. You get
to them. You get to execute them if you have them p imprisoned.
Okay, you get to do all of these things. you, Israel, you got
me. You're like a sphinx. I couldn't solve the riddle and so
now you get to and kill everybody.
Damn. And I have to pay for it. What that are now putting us
in this position. We're in a between a rock and a hard place.
And I'm saying this position sucks. I hate that you are now making
me choose between ethnic cleansing or not and death of every
or ethnic cleansing of of Israel and all the Jews out of Israel
and therefore I oppose the project that established it this way
in such a way that would give us all these problems. Like >> no,
no one is saying when you say you're anti-inist, that doesn't
mean you opposed the project. That means that you oppose the
state of Israel today. >> But I still because of the way
they're doing it. Like it's like, yeah, I don't think this is
like, okay, is the solution just forever we're going to be this,
you know, ethnically cleansing thing and we'll never ever not
be at war with everyone around us. I don't know what the solution
is today, but when when lefties say that they oppose Israel,
they oppose Israel with their chest. They want to defund it.
Maybe they want military action for regime change there. That's
their type of opposition. But if Arabs were to become the majority
in the state of Israel and then were to start massively expelling
maybe I'm just going to hypothesize that you would want to go
to war with Israel immediately. I'm just going to hypothesize
this.
Not if they stop doing war crimes. If they want to keep doing
war crimes, maybe you do eventually get there, but I would imagine
economic sanctions would come in first. Before that, it would
just be denouncements in like in international courts or international
bodies, right? There's like a whole bunch of things you do before
you get to to actually military militarily intervening people.
I don't think lefties would have to say about it. Also have a
problem with ethnic cleansing if Arabs did the
>> It seems as if the Zionist project right now though
is specifically and hinging on, correct me if I'm wrong, ethnic
cleansing, right?
>> That the what >> the Zionist project necessitates
ethnic cleansing right now. It cannot exist without them continuously
ethnically cleansing people. It depends on if you consider the
existence of Palestinians in the West Bank of the Gaza Strip
ethnically cleansing because the land was literally promised
to them by Yahweh. Okay? The land was literally
to them. Come on, man. >> Technically, it depends right
now on on an indefinite uh occupation of the West Bank of the
Gaza Strip. But >> occupation, ethnic cleansing, kicking
people out based on their race, >> not kicking people out,
but keeping them in the West Bank and the Gaza Strip. >> There's
2 million Arabs that live in Israel proper. like that aren't
in the West Bank or the Gaza Strip. >> So yeah, the the
aparttheid this is this is another thing that's not necessarily
ethnic cleansing. It would rely on you keeping those populations
there and never giving them the right to vote. It would rely
on the apartheid,
right? It it relies on not giving these people rights. You don't
have to ethnically cleanse them so long as they're not getting
dangerously close to having rights. I believe this was a significant
portion of why Israel pulled all settlers out of Gaza in 2004,
right? Or 2006.
2008,
one of those one of those three years. Okay, this is a significant
part of it was because I believe people were starting to argue
that if you have settlements there, you actually need to incorporate
the Gaza Strip into Israel.
Like people were starting to make that argument in international
circles. And I think that had some amount of pressure there.
There were a lot of factors. That was not the only factor at
all. Obviously, obviously Hamas was like bombing them. Obviously,
there's a lot of stuff going on. But I think that was a part
of it was they they didn't want to risk Oh, we have settlements
here. Well, you should roll it into your
>> Not even a little bit. >> Yeah. That that they're
not getting kicked out of Israel. >> Okay. Gang. >> Um
Phil, can I ask you one last >> If the people wanting to
come into your country or like have political power in your country
all want to kill you and you if you don't want those people around,
is that supremacist?
Listen, if these people want to kill your culture by promoting
and degeneracy broadly, is wanting to kick them out supremacist
really? Or is it just wanting to like preserve the identity of
your people?
Erodite, could you answer that for me? What if they're like trying
to What are they trying to do when they promote these? They they
they Oh. um if you're doing it on a race-based
like
discrimination thing like yeah like yes but no if you're just
like hey well I I don't know do we ideologically test >> all
of the dominant ethnic groups wanting to move in want to kill
you so you don't want any of those dominant ethnic groups is
that supremacist >> uh in this very specific um this
>> I thought I thought we were all okay guys call me crazy
but I thought we were against painting people with such a broad
brush not all support Israel. Not all are Zionists. Not all Jews.
So you can't say you can't equate Judaism and Zionism because
that that catches good well-meaning people in the crossfire.
All of these disgusting bloodthirsty ape Arabs want to kill Jews.
Every single one of them wants to kill you. They are disgusting
Islamic Islamic
radical terrorist freaks and they will do anything any depraved
act to if they can. Okay. I
just zero principle. Zero principle here. Nothing. No. No. No
leg to stand on at all. Okay. >> Technically, yes. Because
by necessity, your race is the one that doesn't want to kill
your race. And your race is better. But not in the same way that
it's like, I think white people are superior to black people.
>> Wait, you you deciding that your race is better is not
them being supremacist. That's kind of you being supremacist,
>> No. But yeah, if you think every other race is awful
and they all want to kill me, I'm the good one. Then I' like
it's just by necessity >> requires a an ethnosupremacist
outlook from the beginning. This person's Islamic. This person's
an Islamic Arab. They want to kill me by definition. How is this
not the same as conflating Zionism and Judaism? How is that not
the same thing that like obviously just because somebody's an
Arab doesn't mean they want to kill all Jews? You don't think
there are any Arabs who don't want to kill don't want to kill
every Jew? But that is what she's saying. And there's no concern
in the in the exact way that they would expect us to be very
very and they I mean aerodite destiny they would expect us to
be incredibly careful about all the things we say about Israel
so as to not cause any anti-semitism right but in the opposite
direction they have no such concern
zero concern
they will do it repeatedly and they accept it is good and just
to do so okay I'm not going to watch this I'm going to go over
to soy pills thing his retrospective >> I felt like they
were giving like white nationalist ass talking points but like
in defense of Israel and it's like okay like
what the like you know you can be you can be pro like I don't
want to ethnically cleanse like
Israel without saying like oh like the people of this ethnicity
are a threat to us inherently don't you understand well like
white supremacists argue about blacks
yeah but like really really like the Arabs are just ethnically
a threat to us
>> necessity It's a necessity that we do this or we'll
die. And it's like, is it are there no other solutions? Can we
do nothing else? Like, and if it is, like I I we need to do something
about it. Like, and it seems like the the only prescription is
I don't have a solution. We just have to do this like indefinitely.
And I don't know, man. Oh, that's not what I wanted. How do I
flip horizontally? I don't know how to flip horizontally. I'll
just be backwards. Wait. Oh, transform
>> basket lotion. Thank you for the primer. I appreciate
it. >> Flip horizontal. There we go.
Um, Dryan, think for the five. God, the Zionism, the Dems is
so insufferable. Supporting a state that violates human rights
and a far right ethnost state is misguided. Yeah. And it's like
it's like, oh, if you don't support it, you want to ethnically
cleanse Israel, right? Because you realize that like by existing
there, they're always going to be doing this. I'm like, well,
no, I don't want to ethnically cleanse Israel, but I also think
the manner in which they're maintaining their state in the name
of Zionism is bad, and I don't know how to stop that. And and
I I would prefer if there was like more integration. And I think
there could be like a idea of a one state with assimilation.
And if you're saying that's impossible, then what you're telling
me is that it necessitates perpetual ethnic cleansing. And the
only way this can stop suffering is if we >> No. No. No.
It doesn't necessitate perpetual ethnic cleansing. Everybody
be fine. Just stay in your pen. Just stay in your We built you
a nice pen. Stay in the pen. >> Take a bunch of the people
and just move them somewhere else, which is ethnic cleansing.
That's like the ultimate final e and the cleansing or final solution
if you will. And it's like I don't think that's good. I don't
want to displace everyone from Gaza. I don't want to displace
everyone from Israel. So like what the what do you do?
Look at us when you're talking to us. Soy pill.
I'm not happy. Destiny
not happy. As a Destiny fan, he's gone off lately. He's been
clever enough to understand the issue. But him constantly saying
you're being bad faith is the biggest red flag. Like I get that
Destiny like doesn't know me so he's like not sure about it and
he's prone to like people backstabbing him but yeah I
dude
ah
what's the backstab when was he
bro when who was he backstabbed by who is not correct
who is not correct who is not just totally correct about this
guy literally you what was I wrong about Shuya
Is this guy this guy saying
cuz I I was pretty clear. I was not hiding at all. I was like,
"Hey, you hey, you did the things. Well, you and again, the way
you argue this is not that you were backstabbed or betrayed,
Destiny. You betrayed everybody else by not living up to your
principles, by not being a good person. You are the person who
betrayed people. Do not show empathy to the person who betrayed
everything they stood for, all of their friends. Do not do that.
Never accept the propaganda. >> I am uh I'm I'm happy I'm
tolerant and I'm not constantly getting upset at the bad faith
thing. I'm just like, buddy, I don't [__] know who
you're talking to. You got to stop assuming the worst. Why no
live and learn? It's on. It's tomorrow. Although Hutch said he
might not be able to make it because of family and it's like
Hutch, dude, I get it. Your family's dying. Well, maybe maybe
they can just leave him alone, man.
to say your e anti-thnic.
>> Are you a surgeon? No. Then get on the
>> cleansing
I guess. Hey Kilo, thank you for the five. Even the bizarre hypothetical
that opting out of Zionism will lead to them getting genocided.
Why do the Jews get perpetual pre? Yeah. Yeah. That's the other
thing. Like if you have a whole debate about it, it's like
because God decided that. Don't you know? That's literally they're
the chosen people. How many times do I have to teach you this
lesson, old man? never go against God's chosen. >> All right,
your two options are Jews get to perpetually ethnically cleanse
or the Arabs do and you got to pick one. I'm like, well, yeah,
this rock in a hard place thing is is not something that has
a preference at the end. It's like something that's just bad.
And I >> By the way, you gave them all the weapons and
the money that they needed to carry out the ethnic cleansing
to carry out all the war crimes, right? You're the you're the
people who enabled the war crimes. Sorry, I'm muted. >> I
don't know how things at the end. It's like something that's
just bad in either sense. You have to find a way to solve it.
I don't know how to solve Israel Palestine, but this exists because
of the Zionist project, the perpetual need to say we need to
exist in this spot. And I'm anti that. Like I I don't think that
your desire to exist in this country and it like because of some
religious dogmatism is justification to keep doing what you're
doing. I'm sorry. This gives me too much of the Vimar Republic
type. Uh so they want to do the SPD triangulating with the nationalist
fry course. Uh, maybe.
Good job. Hey, Mind Waves. Good job calling out Destiny's lack
of understanding would differ to the different farright factions
and their feelings on Israel. Yeah, I can't believe he said that.
Like just want or uh neo-Nazis. >> Dude, Nick Fentes totally.
He He's like just good as long as the as long as the aren't here.
Getting a combo with Lunder Box. Yeah, I could talk to him about
it. I think I I trust Lunderbox, but I I trust Destiny who's
read about it. Like I I don't think he's like >> Hold on.
Hold on. I have to go back. Where was that chat message?
Who sent that? >> He said that like just want or uh neo-Nazis
just want to go to Israel and off like this is just not true.
Like maybe a Richard Spencer might say something but like Nick
Fuentes like >> get in a conversation with Loner Box. Who
said it? >> How Hassan bad? >> That was in Twitch,
wasn't it? Nazis aren't as bad as Hassan. Like I don't know.
Get in a combo with Lunder Box. Yeah, I could talk to him about
it. I think I I trust Linder Box, but I I trust Destiny who's
read about it. Like I I don't think he's like he's way more informed
than I am. I don't do debates on Israel, Palestine. I don't know
if she say trans rights. I just did. Get the combo. Oh, do you
understand that these liberals are the ones actually period testing?
Well, they are. Hutch flakes out when Taylor's going beyond.
Yeah, I'm going to try to reschedle. We'll see. Remember when
you made a huge effort to post about dark money and you were
totally wrong about everything? Oh, you're talking about Kilo.
Um, private property is the divide. Did this guy suggest that
Kilo was wrong? What was Kilo wrong about?
Kilo, were you super wrong about something or is that guy just
Is that guy just um
is he misinformed?
Some guy called you out. Were you wrong? >> Line between
liberals and leftists. I think that is the definitive difference
between the groups. Yeah. And I'm not anti-private property.
I got to stop saying Democ. I'm a sock Dem. Destiny's not getting
Destiny's got more rhetoric than he has. Good faith in my years
of seeing him. He puts up some real good fights against right-wingers.
And yeah, and like that's why I try to bring it up. Like obviously
I don't think that Hassan's politics um are uh less harmful than
like Destiny's personal beefs that have caused so much baggage.
But associating with Destiny, it comes with so much
My haters follow me. Sorry,
Dude, why why would you come to like Zoyill's chat to Gungard?
Wow. Wow. Backage. There's all sorts of [__] you'll
get just for mentioning him or being on the same poster as him
or being an org that he's in. Um I've known people that like
lost donors that are because of the org that he's in. And you
know what? Like that's something I'm like, "Hey, but you do good
fighting and you have good politics and you promote usually good
things,
So I build Dude, that was really funny. I forgot about that from
early on in the conversation. Desi was arguing that Hassan harasses
people. Hassan tries to destroy people out of spite and that's
what makes Hassan uniquely bad and that you can't accept being
anywhere around Hassan. And Soy Pill was sitting there like,
"Bro, that's why that's why I can't I I say that doesn't matter
to me so I can like collab with you. What do you mean? What are
you saying right now? You're you're literally giving me a prescription
where I'd have to stop talking to you completely. What are you
trying to do? Is this a test? Are you saying something intentionally?
And I want to work with that and I want to promote people to
get involved. And the idea that like I'm going to throw that
all away because like oh like you got cancelceled for this thing.
Like I I don't know. Like obviously there's a line to draw like
if it turned out that someone was like an actual like a murderer
or whatever and it's like okay like there's definitive proof
that you just like are poison and you do more harm than good.
That's when you stop. But like
does Soyel not think there's definitive proof of this? I'm just
curious like what does he what does he think happened? I I just
would wonder what he actually thinks happened with regards to
the leaks and stuff
>> like what what
cuz people say this and I I'm going to give him the benefit of
the doubt and say that okay he um like Soy Pill doesn't know
but then they don't want to know either.
That's like the that's the weird thing to me is like he just
doesn't want to know
probably. Well,
I feel like it's not hard to find the information and if you
can find the information,
it seems pretty easy to understand. But I don't know. Pisco does
the same thing. Yeah. But Pisco I think has a possible literal
actual conflict there. Like I think for for Pisco specifically,
I would never judge him because if he's ever for some reason
given Destiny legal advice on anything
and then he starts like talking about Destiny's legal case, I
would be very very very concerned that Destiny would do the same
thing he's doing to Lauren de Laguna. Like if if Pisco went through
all the stuff and found out he disagreed or thought Destiny was
harmful, I think he would be really concerned or Pisco could
be really concerned that that's somehow a conflict. that's somehow
like a thing he could get reported for. I that's if I don't I
don't even know if he would think that. I don't even know if
he would think that. So, but I'm I'm saying with him specifically,
I don't know that
I don't know that he is not conflicted out there in a way that
you wouldn't
Um, let's see here. What part of wanting to bury your head in
the sand is complicated? It's It's not complicated. It's just
when he says like
basically when people when he says what he just said that's what's
complicated right >> was like an actual like a murderer
or whatever and it's like okay like there's definitive proof
that you just like are poison and you do more harm than good
that's when you >> there's definitive proof that you just
are poison you do more harm than good right
he's like he is doing the Jimmy Savile thing this is this is
prime Jimmy Savile comparison territory right here but we don't
do this anymore we don't do this anymore
but it is it is prime I'm Jimmy Savile comparison territory.
Okay. How many kids How many kids do we feed to Jimmy? He just
built a hospital. How many kids does he get soy bill? How many
kids? >> Stop. But like I don't know this it's you can't
draw the equivalence to that in the Hassan politics because his
it's all about subverting the Democratic party. It's not just
like oh he did bad stuff. He behaves
>> why why does Soy Pill think that Democratic politicians
talk to Hassan
Like if it's all subversion, why does he think that like some
does he think Roy Roana is like a
I'm I'm curious what he thinks those people think. Gavin Newsome
said he would go on the broadcast, right? Gavin Newsome said,
"Yeah, I'd be open to going on the broadcast,
>> Is that cuz Gavin Newsome's like a total or what?"
>> Guys, I think we're five subs away for another hour
on the stream if you guys do want to do that. 12 minutes left.
I've got the stuff and there's probably I've got some other stuff
in my docket here. Hold on a second.
Yeah, I've got some other stuff on the docket here if we want
to go through a couple other
So you guys you guys can make the call. We'll see what's going
to happen. >> Similar with PCO, he held a position of allying
with people who aren't allied completely. I couldn't quote him.
Yeah. >> Does he mean co-opt? Maybe. Maybe he means co-opt.
Yeah, it's like maybe it means co-opt. >> Do you realize
that socialism and communism are both acceptable if people want
it? And the reality is it's just as fine as liberalis and fascism
by force and thus not acceptable. I don't know if you the problem
is like you can't I don't know how you get everyone on board
with socialism communism and in so far as like well then we wouldn't
have to force it like oh well if everyone just agreed with me
it wouldn't we wouldn't have to >> yeah but it's the you
go slowly in a direction see what works see what doesn't work
force it but that's usually not how it plays out. Yeah. Yeah.
Commies don't get how they can think it's anything but supremacy
want to protect your ethnic majority. Yeah. No that's the questions.
It's like I felt like I was talking with neo-Nazis. Like I know
they're not. I know I agree with these people's politics, but
the argument is being brought up. Like, how is it supremacist
if they just want to protect their ethnicity from the ones that
want to kill them? And it's like, dude, that's what Nazis say.
They're like, well, black people just, you know, are more dangerous
and we just have to get rid of them. It's not about like we don't
hate them because of their skin color. It's just they're inherently
more dangerous and they're attacking the white race and there's
a white genocide. We just get all the brown people out. It's
like like
my haters follow me. Sorry. It's okay. Kilo
Destiny was sounding super fun. Just like a little bit. I'm glad
I know these people. If that was my first introduction to Kyla
and uh Steven, I would I would have some questions. What's preferable?
>> Shouldn't you have some questions? Shouldn't you be
wondering why they have like an edge case where they suddenly
sound like Nick Fentes? Doesn't that like not make any sense?
Shouldn't you have questions now? Shouldn't you be like, "Wait,
>> so like we could do this in America?" No. No, we can't
do it in America. So we could do this in Germany. No, no, you
can't do it in Germany. Well, like but what if what if like the
population started to get to the point where Germans were no
longer the ethnic majority there? No, you can't do it in Germany.
You can only do it in Israel. Wh why?
Because everybody hates them. What if the what if the Germans
are hated by the Syrians who are there and the the population
that's like going to become bigger?
Well, what? Hold on.
No, it's it's different because everybody all the people around
Germany like Germany. Like it's different because actually all
the Arabs surrounding Israel want to kill the people in Israel.
Well, hold on. Right. It just It just keeps going. It just keeps
going and going and going. It just keeps going.
Wait. Uh, yeah. Polls infamously huge fans of the Germans. Okay.
Infamously, what is best? Mind waves. You're a failed streamer.
Actively is being quite the snarker. I've seen you in here. No
one should talk to Hassan. Also, I got waffles and chicken with
Fentus.
Yeah, I think he was too friendly with Fentes, but like I don't
Was there any ever a point in his I didn't watch this whole discussion.
Was there ever a point in that like Destiny Nick thing that people
always try to like use to call him out like, "Oh, you promoted
Nick." It's like, isn't he like pushing back on him the entire
time? Or is it because he's not like screaming at him? I don't
know. Talk to Beast Go about what I'm
uh I
probably agree with that that I don't think the chicken waffles
thing is that weird if it's like you disagree. I don't think
it's like bad to have conversations with people like that, but
I don't know. It's tough now because Nick is massive and I don't
I don't necessarily think it's good. So, >> telling you
Destiny's not acting in good faith to certain other libs. Talk
to Pisco. I'll definitely talk to Pisco. I joined Richard. Oh,
hey Dal. I joined Richard Spencer's substack to see behind the
curtain. He's honestly pretty lid. Uh, I wouldn't talk to Pisco
if I were whoever that is.
I'm sorry.
Love Pisco from a distance. Okay. But I would not talk to Pisco
about it. Pisco has total derangement in the opposite in the
opposite direction. I wouldn't be shocked if Pisco is like totally
back to thinking Desi is just like a good faith actor he would
love to argue with again. Pisco is
he will infinitely
infinitely fall for it again. Okay, I'm sorry that that's the
them's the facts. He will fall for it again and again and again
and again. Love peace go from a distance though. Okay, love peace
go from a distance. He will fall for it again and again and again.
Get him a fell for it again award cuz he fell for it again. But
I will say it doesn't seem like at least from what I've seen
he necessarily wants his reputation tied. It's like if they're
going to have a contentious conversation or if it's a debate
then he'll do it. I think I think
the doubt no I think he's hiding his power level at this point.
He's trying to like capitulate. He's doing like the Glen Beck.
Destiny is deep in the right wing Zionist information sphere.
Yeah. Maybe I it was so weird that he's like trying to convert
people to religion. Like this is like I it was so weird like
Jews explaining this to me are going
it's like dude like I'm in communities I like the the there are
explicit like projects from synagogues that like will do outreach
to secular and try to pay them money to go to synagogue teaching
and make them more religious like this just exists. They do this
to people on birthright. They do this to people synagogues in
California like constantly try to convert people. No, don't get
me wrong. They're not like Mormons. They're not like missionaries
to the same extent and they don't Why don't they try to go and
convert like black people? soy pill.
Could you tell me why they don't like try to go and convert random
black people to Judaism? Is there like a reason that they wouldn't
go to like black communities and just be like, "Hey, I think
you guys would really like
Is there is there something wrong with the black communities
that they don't go and try to convert those people to Judaism?
Get them to come to synagogue, >> you know, go around dropping
Watchtowwer flyers in your uh front door, but they do. They try
to convert people. >> I'm not talking about Ethiopian Butts
up. And you know, I'm not talking about Ethiopian. I don't know
why you would try to pull that up as if that is an argument.
I'm asking you why when they go to get people at synagogue in
California, why are they not going to Compton to grab people
and say, "Hey, why don't you come to synagogue?" That's what
I'm asking. That's what I'm asking
Ethiopian Jews are explicitly like closer Hapla group wise to
actual like semi Jews than other people. So you guys can keep
saying this, but genetically they're sorry to say you guys don't
it doesn't actually work there.
I'm talking about something else. Oh, whoops.
Really enrages me soy that people like Destiny are like remember
Mag America far bad but then Alli care waterfare is really far
right. Um does he I don't think Destiny's like pro Netanyahu
is he? I don't I mean it sounds like he was caring a little water
for them there. Difference between acknowledging the pro Netanyahu.
Oh god this guy is deep.
This guy's going to require Okay. A little re-education for soy
pill. Some soy pill re-education at this point. >> Dark
creation of Israel and wanting Palestine to get their own state
and wanting Israel to disappear today. Yeah, there is a difference.
He's going nuts during the Zionist. >> Doesn't he disavow
Netanyahu?
Doesn't he disavow Netanyahu? Guys, wouldn't he just Come on,
man. Couldn't he disavow Netanyahu? >> Conversation. How
much he misrepresents your opinion? Well, don't be Look, Destiny
is not just fighting me, right? He's fighting me and then there's
like 60 stands from Jojo and they're all the lefties that are
like super insane and anti-semitic and he's punching all of them
too and like you know his punches might be missing me and hitting
them but like it sure does feel like they're all coming at me
all these.
>> It's almost like he's having a schizophrenic meltdown.
It really is. It is. It's almost like he's having a total schizophrenic
meltdown. Yeah. >> That I don't have. Norman Finkelestein
is well read. Destiny has troubled has precision to talk fast.
I don't know that debate with him and Finkelestein. Uh Finkelestein
looked pretty awful in it. He didn't really substantively contest
what the things Destiny was saying. Uh Benny Morris was >> where
the large contingent of insane anti-semitic leftists. Well, in
Destiny's mind, he is seeing them. He's making them up. Okay.
And trust me, he's winning a lot of those fights. Okay, he's
totally winning a bunch of those fights. He's really doing well.
He's doing terrific. >> Is much more relevant. He's literally
a scholar and he seemed to be agreeing with Destiny on things.
Like, I don't know if I trust Norman Finkelestein. Slaveholder
said the same things about black people that Israelis do about
Palestines. It was called surviile insurrection. Yeah. You might
not want to cut him off, but he wants you to cut off people he
disagree with. Destiny is toxic.
I mean, sure, but I I can deal with him telling me to cut people
off and not doing it as long as he's not going to like dox me
or something. Maybe he will. It's literally a stone sore away
from Nazism. And that's why Hey, Soy Pill, you want to have a
conversation? See what happens. Hey Soy Pill, you want to join
my Discord? See what happens? Soy Pill, I'm Hold on. What is
Soy Pill's Discord? I'm sending him an invite right now. The
soy
invite principal. Yeah,
>> seems pretty crazy to me. But don't get me wrong, >> you
have to warn him. I He's very aware. He has to be super aware.
See you later, Kio. He has to be so aware. >> Understand
the concept. Can I Hold on. I'm gonna actually ask. Sorry. It
was like instant. It was like instant the response.
Okay.
Welcome, friend. You trying to get me killed, you crazy son of
a [__] >> On the impetus of Zionism. >> Good
times. >> Good times. Today, if you try to establish a
state today, I would say like, okay, clearly this is going to
cause a bunch of problems and there are plenty of countries that
accept you. And like even in America where like anti-semitism
is on the rise, it's still incredibly safe place for Jews. This
is silly. But like back in the end of the 40s and like right
after the Holocaust, like I get it. It's just a really bad decision.
So I and I hate religion and I hate the the way that religion
justifies it's like, "Oh, this is our religious homeland, therefore
it's okay."
Destiny was too friendly with Fentes, but he was debating him.
Yeah. Like he might have been a little too buddy putty, but I've
done that with neo-Nazis before. Like, hey, what's up? Hah. I'll
shake your hand, you piece of racist. Still to this day, Nick
isn't that racist. He had black. I
That's an interesting comment.
I defended the Fentes thing back then. I think you can talk to
some You can talk to somebody if you disagree with them. You're
gonna have like contentious conversations. I will say it's tough
to have that conversation with Fentes. Like when he says when
he asks that guy in the middle of the street, "Hey, are you?"
It's a little hard to push back. >> Friends, just tip $3.
>> That'll catch you off guard. >> I joined your
Discord. Come on. Have no
>> No, you don't get to join the Discord, DF. Sorry. You're
out. I'm sorry. Unlucky, man. I'm just I'm just telling you,
okay?
It's tough to with Plantas. It's tough to know, okay? You got
to have your head on a swivel at all times. Just be ready to
push back at all times. What did DKF do? He's like a turbo energy
vampire type. Sorry.
Not a not a horrible person. Just
everything's always about how he's having a rough time. You know,
you know how it is. >> Black friends. No, Nick is a neo-Nazi.
I know he acknowledges that. You messed up by saying we just
don't let Nazis in. Yeah, but that's the thing is we do let Nazis
in. Right now, I wouldn't say we could have to ideologically
test immigrants. There's plenty of like Europeans that probably
immigrate to America that are probably Nazis that I prefer not
be here, but I don't want to like ethnically or like even like
ideologically test people. Um, it's so weird. It was funny that
he was trying to juice blame the I I do think it's very weird
to me though how Eerite and Dest are totally fine implying that
all Arabs are bloodthirsty and want to kill all Jews, right?
But if you ever made that same conflation of
of Zionism
and Judaism,
right, that saying like, "Oh, all you know, all want to kill
people or something, people would lose their minds.
All all Israel, even if you said all Israelis just want to kill
all Arabs, they'd probably still lose their minds." Well, there
are some Israelis who really like Arabs. It's It is because Islamophobia
is allowed. And I'm just like, dude, like
it's just kind of crazy to me that it's just allowed. It's just
part for the course. It just is what it is.
>> Gummy verse, you pushed it to the utmost
And we grabbed
Let's go. 1 hour on the stream. 1 hour 11 seconds. 1 hour 10
seconds. Let's go. Pretty sure if you're applying to be a US
citizen, you have to affirm you're not a communist or not affiliated
with a communist party of any kind. Red scare stuff left over.
What do you think? Straight. Would you straight away could you
immigrate to America if you'd been born outside of America or
would you be
would they just be like nah nope you said you're a communist
online once you're out bye-bye >> importance of birthright
well I think he might have assumed my position was like the reason
they do birthright is to convert you to Judaism which is obviously
not true
is Spencer citing his power level he's not hiding it in his private
paid community he's not about he's he's trying to sanewash himself
he's not hiding his power level obviously he's still neo-Nazi
I don't think actually we're openly calling for the mass killings
of Germans Probably not. I've seen Destiny saying Netanyahu is
a bash and save war criminal needs to go. Yeah.
True. Finlestein is a [__] You ignorant [__]
He pretends not to be, but then never covers how Israel has messed
up and currently I can't do the voice. I'd say try to do the
line. You fantastic [__] I can't do the voice. It's
like not quite. You fantastic [__] I can't do it.
I just sound like I'm racist. I'm sorry. I tried my best. I tried.
I failed. I'm hit and play on the screen. >> Crashed out
on Miss Rachel for being pro Palestine. To be fair, I saw Miss
Rachel say some uh some actually anti-Semitic. She was like liking
some anti-semitic stuff. Uh so, you know, people are like, "Oh,
she's just saying like don't kill kids." But I'm like, "Well,
Miss Rachel, you like this comment that says like don't want
you to know this or some weird like that." I was like, "I hope
you did that one on accident." Dude, I swear to God,
just stop killing kids. You liked something that said the don't
want you to know this. That's like where the line is. Like literally
there's a comment that you liked on a post about kids getting
killed and people are like way more than they're outraged about
the kids getting killed. They're like you you liked a comment
that said that don't want you to know this. Are you not concerned
about your attitude? ARE YOU NOT CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR ATTITUDE
AND THE THING YOU'RE FOCUSED ON RIGHT NOW? You seem pretty inhuman
to me. Okay. You seem like you are not a person.
How in the world did I tell you a bunch of kids got killed and
then I liked a comment that said, "Oh, don't want you to know
this." instead of the Israelis don't want you to know this and
now I'm the monster. Are you serious? Are you for real? There's
got to be some There's got to be some name for this pattern that
unfolds, right? There has to be somewhere out here. What is this
barbarism critic thing to buy? I would like to buy
a burrito.
And in that burrito,
I would like
I would like chocolate chips
and if you have them
some grapefruit
and if you do not >> bro I remember watching
>> I can't pause this Twitter's broken >> with ketchup
>> with chocolate chips. >> We're stuck here now
>> and with pieces >> we're stuck here.
I will not be supporting
your
in the same way I will not support the
genocidal regime of the Israeli government and the way it treats
its
both in and out of Gaza and the West
>> dude. It's It's actually just taking like as long as
Norfinkle scene. That's how I know it's accurate. I just like
come on today, man. Today.
What are we doing?
Dan and Destiny have an inside joke about Miami chasing Dan to
convert him. The point is they don't try to convert non-Jews.
Uh, okay, that's fair. They're usually chasing the secular Jews.
That's because it's so much easier than getting anyone else on
board. Yeah. Fent for a >> Is that why they Is that why
they do it? Because it's way easier getting secular Jews on board
than anyone else. Is that
Are you sure? Do you Do you think that's why? Do you think that's
it? >> Holy war against Jews and supports
>> I don't know. There's so many people who are in total
denial about it being an ethnore religion. And I it makes no
sense to me. Like yeah there are like edge cases to where the
ethno religion stuff doesn't necessarily apply 100%. And they
are willing to take with like significant devotion people from
outside of the ethnic group but it is by and large and the way
it is by and large propagated is as an ethnore religion.
They don't have any problem saying it. Are you?